THE LEGISLATIVE.
BUDGET CONFERENCE COMMITTEE.
WE ARE VERY PROUD TO COME
TOGETHER TONIGHT WE HAVE A ABOUT
A HUNDRED ITEMS HUNDRED ISSUES.
TWO.
VALIDATE AND APPROVE
WHICH REPRESENT THE.
AGREEMENT.
BETWEEN THE ASSEMBLY THE SENATE
AND THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
BECAUSE THIS AGREEMENT ON.
FROM THE ASSEMBLY POINT OF USE A
CULMINATION OF OVER EIGHTY.
THREE HEARINGS THROUGH OUR
VARIOUS SUBCOMMITTEES. ARE HOURS
OF TESTIMONY AND PUBLIC COMMENT
AND PUBLIC FEEDBACK.
WE'VE HAD FIVE CONFERENCE
HEARING SO FAR.
TO TO CONFERENCE A TO CONFERENCE
AND.
I BELIEVE THAT IS THIS OUR
BUDGET THAT WE HAVE BEFORE US AS
WE DISCUSS THE TONIGHT SOMETHING
THAT. WE AS CALIFORNIANS CAN BE.
VERY PROUD OF WE'VE MADE NO
PROGRESS ON MANY MANY ISSUES
ON OR WHETHER IT IS HOMELESSNESS.
WE ARE FAR PUT FORTH A PATH
TO OF MOVE CLOSER TOWARD
UNIVERSAL HEALTHCARE DOWN THE
ROAD.
WE ALSO ARE TRYING TO ENSURE
THROUGHOUT OUR BUDGET PROCESS
THAT THE CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE.
I'M REALLY THE POOREST IN OUR
STATE ARE ALSO ARE GETTING.
GETTING SOME RESOURCES THAT THEY
HAVE LONG DESERVED AND LONG
NEEDED.
ON.
WITHOUT.
WE HAVE HISTORIC ó WITH
HISTORIC INVESTMENTS IN
EDUCATION FROM K. TWELVE AS WELL
AS HIGHER EDUCATION. IS SO VERY
EXCITED TO. BE ABLE TO CHAIR
THIS MEANS NIGHT AND GO THROUGH.
ALL THIS HERE WITHOUT WOULD BE
SENIOR CENTER MITCHELL HAS AN
OPENING COMMENTS.
I WITHOUT THE STATE'S TOP OF THE
EVENING TO YOU MISTER CHAIR BUT
I THINK THAT WOULD NOT BE THE
APPROPRIATE USE OF THAT TERM I
DON'T THINK IT'S A TOP OF THE
EVENING SO GOOD EVENING.
ON TO MY COLLEAGUES I WANNA
THANK EVERYONE FOR BEING HERE AT
THIS RELATIVELY LATE HOUR OF THE
DAY.
WE CERTAINLY APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE.
AS WE WORK VERY HARD TO MEET
THE DEADLINES WE HAVE BEFORE US
TO GET. A BUDGET BILL COMPLETED
IN TIME TO PRINT.
IF YOU DON'T MIND THINK CHAIR
I'D LIKE TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO IT'S TO THANK.
OUR COLLECTIVE BUDGET STAFF LA
EL DEPARTMENT FINANCE
ALL OF OUR COLLEAGUES HERE IN
BUDGET COMMITTEE IN THE
CONFEREES FOR THEIR HARD WORK.
ON THE BUDGET PROCESS EVERY YEAR
IS A COMPLICATED COMPLEX.
SPIRITS AND WE ALL KNOW.
THAT THERE ARE COUNTLESS HOURS
THAT ARE POURED INTO THIS
PROCESS MANY HOURS YET TO COME
ON TO GET A DOCUMENT TO US ON
THAT WE CAN VOTE ON ON BEHALF OF.
ALL THE CONSTITUENTS WHO
REPRESENT.
THE BEAUTY FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
OR THE DRAMA THE BUDGET
DEVELOPMENT PROCESS IS IT AND
HOW IT CULMINATES IN THE.
.
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE IS THAT
EACH HOUSE BRINGS TO THE TABLE
AN IDEA OR CONCEPT. AND WE
ADVOCATE IN ITS BEHALF THE WHOLE
POINT OF THE CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE PROCESS. IS TO
SKILLFULLY MERGE ALL THE VARIOUS
IDEAS INTO ONE DOCUMENT.
I IT'S NEVER OUR INTENT TO
WILLFULLY PICK WINNERS VERSUS
LOSERS BUT RATHER WE WORK TO
DEVELOP A PLAN THAT BROADLY
SUPPORTS THE PRESSING NEEDS OF
ALL CALIFORNIANS. IN A FISCALLY
RESPONSIBLE WAY ON AS THE
CHAIRMAN SAID.
THE ACTIONS WILL BE TAKING
TODAY ARE THE RESULT OF
NEGOTIATIONS.
BETWEEN BOTH HOUSES LEADERSHIP
OF BOTH HOUSES PLUS THE
ADMINISTRATION.
WE'RE ALREADY HEARING FROM
ADVOCATES AND STAKEHOLDERS WHO
HAVE SOME DEEP CONCERNS ABOUT
ITEMS THAT WON'T BE FUNDED.
MANY OF US SHARE YOUR CONCERNS
AGAIN IT'S AN EFFORT TO CREATE A
FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE BALANCED
BUDGET THAT WILL MOVE CALIFORNIA
FORWARD WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE CHAIRMAN.
FOR ALL HIS LEADERSHIP IN THIS
PROCESS.
ON AND I BELIEVE VERY TO GET
STARTED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
I DO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND I WANT TO THANK
YOU
CERTAINLY FOR ACCOMMODATING THE.
REPUBLICANS NEED TO HAVE TIME.
THE DELIBERATE.
AND REVIEW DOCUMENTS.
FRANKLY IT'S VASTLY LESS TIME
THAN THE MAJORITY GOT THAT WE'RE
VERY APPRECIATIVE OF GETTING
WHAT TIME.
WE DID GET.
THAT'S WE BEGIN THIS SO CALLED
CLOSURE.
I MUST COMMENT.
FLAWED PROCESS THAT WE HAVE BEEN
GOING THROUGH HERE FOR SEVERAL
DAYS.
AND IT IS.
NOT THE NORM.
IN VERY KEY RESPECTS.
IN THOSE RESPECTS IN YOUR TO THE
DISADVANTAGE.
THE PEOPLE WE REPRESENT.
THEIR REPRESENTATIVES LARGELY
DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON.
AND HAVEN'T TO THE LAST MANY
DAIS.
INCLUDING TO THIS DAY.
THEY THEREFORE.
WON'T KNOW EITHER.
AND MAJOR MAJOR POLICY YET AGAIN.
IS BEING AFFECTED.
IN THE BUDGET.
AND WE HAVEN'T EVEN SEEN ALL THE
TRAILER BILLS WHERE MOST OF THE
LITTLE GAMES.
A CAR.
I WOULDN'T TREAT.
OUR LEADERS.
AND OUR MEMBERS.
THAT OUR MEMBERS DO HAVE A SAY.
DEMOCRAT AND REPUBLICAN.
NEXT NEXT YEAR IT NOT BE DONE.
THIS WAY.
EVERYTHING SO FAR.
EXCEPT ABOUT FOUR VOTES.
HAS BEEN DONE BEHIND CLOSED
DOORS.
A CONFERENCE COMMITTEE PROCESS
HISTORICALLY IS WHERE BY.
TWO VERSIONS OF A BILL OR A
BUDGET.
NOW RECONCILED HERE.
IN A ROOM LIKE THIS.
MEMBERS TALK WITH EACH OTHER.
NEGOTIATE.
MAKE COMPROMISES THE WHOLE WORLD.
AND WE VOTE.
AND WE WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ALONG THE WAY.
AND THERE WAS A DAY.
WHEN GEORGE DEUKMEJIAN.
TEN BEING THE BIG FIVE.
I WAS A PART OF THAT FOR FIVE
YEARS.
THE BIG FIVE WHERE THE.
REPUBLICAN AND DEMOCRATIC
LEADERS IN THE GOVERNOR.
WHOEVER THEY WERE.
AND THEY MET ONLY ON THE MOST
YOUR RESOLVABLE ISSUES.
FEW YEARS AGO WE HAD THE BIG
FIVE DOING ALL BUDGET.
THE WHOLE BUDGET.
THE ONE IS THE REST OF US IN
HERE YOU GO.
NOW.
WE ONLY HAVE THE BIG THREE.
FRANKLY OTHER THAN A BUNCH OF
WORDS THROWN UP IN THE SKY HERE.
AND BOATS IN THE SUB COMMITTEES.
WHICH ALREADY HAVE BEEN PUNY
BEEN DISREGARDED AND CHANGED THE
SUBCOMMITTEE ACTIONS.
WELL WE'VE HAD OUR SAY AND WE'VE
HAD OUR VOTES.
BUT NO REAL HAND.
IN CRAFTING OF THESE MAJOR
ISSUES.
SO MISTER CHAIRMAN WITH THANKS
TO YOU AND TO ALL OF OUR STAFF.
I DO HAVE A LARGER COMPLETE.
ABOUT THE PROCESS WE HAD JUST
ENDURED.
AND WE DON'T EVEN KNOW YET WHAT
IS TO COME.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR SIMILAR BELOW.
MISTER CHAIR AND AND MY THE ONLY
ONE.
WHO? HAS NOTICED THAT WE WAITED
JUST LONG ENOUGH TO BEGIN THIS
HEARING FOR THE GOLDEN STATE
WARRIORS. TO BECOME NBA
CHAMPIONS.
THE I MAYBE I MEAN I THINK
YOU'RE THE ONLY ONE BECAUSE THE
REST OF US WERE GETTING READY
FOR EMIT MISTER CHAIR I MAY.
I GOT AN ALERT ON MY PHONE.
I MAYBE A LAKERS FAN.
AND I WILL ALWAYS BE A LAKERS
FAN BUT I THINK IT'S. IT'S IT'S
A GREAT THING THAT A CALIFORNIA
TEAM HAS TAKEN THE CHAMPIONSHIP
PLAN.
ON A NIGHT WHEN WE'RE GOING TO
BE DISCUSSING AND MAKING
PROGRESS ON CALIFORNIA'S BUDGET
WHICH.
ON I THINK IS ALSO A CREDIT TO
THIS GREAT STATE OF OURS THAT
TOUCHES ON SO MANY ISSUES THAT
ARE OF IMPORTANCE TO.
CALIFORNIANS WE HAVE MUCH TO
CELEBRATE BE THANKFUL FOR.
THANK YOU SUMMIT OBERNOLTE.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I'D
LIKE TO AMPLIFY SOMETHING THAT
SENATOR MITCHELL SAID BUT WE MAY
BE HERE LATE AT NIGHT AND BE
HERE LATER STILL TONIGHT BUT.
THEY ARE BUDGET COMMITTEE STAFF
HAS BEEN WORKING LATE NIGHTS FOR
WEEKS ON THIS BUDGET AND SO I
THINK IT'S ONLY FAIR TO US A BIG
THANK YOU. TO OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE OF LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND ALL OF OUR
RESPECTIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE
STAFFS FOR ALL OF THEIR HARD
WORK. ARE ALSO I'D LIKE TO
AMPLIFY SOMETHING THAT.
THAT SENATOR NIELSEN WAS
TALKING ABOUT NOW AND THAT IS
THAT THE. THIS REALLY COULD BE A
MUCH MORE TRANSPARENT PROCESS
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
FRUSTRATES ME IS I LIKE MAKING
INFORMED DECISIONS. ON THE
THINGS THAT I VOTE ON.
EVEN IF ARE NOT IN THE MAJORITY
SOMETIMES I LIKE THOSE DECISIONS
TO BE INFORMED AND WHEN WE GET.
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE IS RUINED OUR CLEAR
WHAT WE'RE VOTING ON SO IT WOULD
BE NICE IN THE FUTURE IF WE
COULD SEGMENT OUT THOSE SECTIONS
OF THE BUDGET. FOR CONSIDERATION
LATER BECAUSE WE COULD RUN BUT
BUDGET TRAILER BILLS LATER IN
THE YEAR USUALLY WITHOUT. ARE
AFFECTING THE PROCESS THAT WE DO
ANNA IN A VENUE LIKE THIS
EVENING. BUT I WANNA THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP MISTER
CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU SENATOR MORLOCK.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I'D LIKE
TO DIRECT MY THOUGHTS TO THE
OVERALL BUDGET AND AND THE
DIRECTION.
WE ARE LOOKING AT WHAT I WOULD
CALL A BUMPER CROP.
HAVING GONE THROUGH SOME PRETTY
ROUGH YEARS.
AS AN ELECTED OFFICIAL ARE
RUNNING ONE OF THE LARGEST
COUNTIES BY POPULATION IN THE
COUNTRY.
IT'S KIND OF NICE TO BE. IN THIS
POSITION WHERE YOU HAVE A LITTLE
EXTRA MONEY AS OPPOSED TO MAKING.
LAYOFFS OF ABOUT A THOUSAND
PEOPLE.
SO EQUITIES ARE UP UNEMPLOYMENT
IS DOWN.
AND IT SEEMS THAT WHEN YOU GET
A LITTLE BIT OF A BONUS WE
SHOULD BE PAYING DOWN OUR CREDIT
CARD BALANCES.
OR WE SHOULD BE PUTTING FUNDS
ASIDE.
THAT'S A GOOD THING WE'RE DOING
THAT IN THIS BUDGET.
BUT BUT PAYING DOWN A LITTLE
MORE ON OUR PENSION PLAN
LIABILITIES OR A RETIREE MEDICAL.
NOW.
LIABILITIES REP TO NINETY ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION IN.
WE'LL BE STARING US IN THE FACE
WITH THE JUNE THIRTIETH.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN BALANCE SHEET
WHEN IT COMES OUT NEXT SPRING.
THAT'S MY CONCERN ABOUT THE
WHOLE THE WHOLE PROCESS IS THE
BIGGER PICTURE IN. AND SO.
IF WE WERE TO PAY DOWN A
PENSION PLAN LIABILITY THAT THAT
THAT SEVEN PERCENT INTEREST
BECAUSE IRAQ WILL BE EARNING. AS
OPPOSED TO.
YOU KNOW LESS THAN A HALF A
PERCENT RIGHT NOW IS IT
LANGUISHES IN THAT THE STATE
TREASURY.
SO I WANT TO IMPROVE THE BALANCE
SHEET SO THAT WOULD BE SOME OF
MY BIASES AS. I APOLOGIZE FOR
BEING WILL. MAYBE CAN
ULTRACONSERVATIVE OR MAYBE AS
OBSERVING THE GLASS IS HALF.
FULL. I'M BUT SOMETIMES I SIT I
THINK WE'RE DANCING ON THE DECK
OF THE DIKE TITANIC AND.
SO I THINK WE NEED TO BE REAL
CAREFUL WE SHOULD LISTEN TO THE
GOVERNOR.
WHEN HE SAYS WE NEED TO BE
PREPARED FOR THE NEXT RECESSION
BECAUSE HE AND I ARE OLD ENOUGH.
TO KNOW WE GO THROUGH THEM.
SO WITH THAT.
.
MISTER CHAIR THIS BUDGET IS
DOING A LOT OF GOOD THINGS AND
IN A COULD DO MORE.
SO WITH THAT I I JUST HAD ONE
QUESTION FOR YOU SINCE.
THIS IS MY SECOND GO ROUND IN.
IT MADE HIM TO BE INTERESTING. A
LAST MINUTE INTO THE NIGHT KINDA
DEALS.
THIS ONE WAS A LITTLE.
MORE.
.
BUT WALKING IN THE DARK FOR ME.
NOTHING WAS CLEAR.
I WILL ONE FOOT AHEAD AND SO I'M
JUST ONE IF YOU CAN GIVE AN
EVALUATION OF THE PROCESS.
THIS YEAR.
AND AND THEN MAYBE THEN. WHAT WE
DO TO IMPROVE IT OR MAYBE IT'S
THE WAY IT IS AND THAT?
OR YOU KNOW BECAUSE THINGS HAVE
EVOLVED SENATE AND CENTER
NIELSEN ALREADY MENTIONED. BIG
FIVE BIG THREE HE.
YOU NO I I AND SO I WANTED KIND
OF WONDER OUR WE RELEVANT. OR
ARE WE NOT DO WE NEED TO JUST
CLOSE DOWN OR DO WE NEED TO RE
EVALUATE. THE WHOLE SYSTEM.
I THINK THAT WILL FIRST THANK
YOU.
TELL MY COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR
GREAT COMMENTS
I DID WANT TO. JUMP OFF ON WHERE
MISTER OBERNOLTE MENTIONED IN
JUST AGAIN THANK THE STAFF. THAT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE LA O. R.
ASSEMBLY.
BUDGET STAFF THAT THE
REPUBLICAN STAFF THE SENATE
BUDGET STAFF ALL THE HOURS AND
HOURS OF WORK. ON.
IT JUST AND TAKING THAT THAT
FEEDBACK. THAT THE BUDGET IS NOT.
DONE IN CONFERENCE COMMITTEE.
THE BUDGET IS A.
FOR A FIVE MONTH PROCESS
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE START IN
FEBRUARY WILL BE AND YOU KNOW
YOU AN EARLIER WE START IN.
JANUARY WITH IT WITH THE INITIAL
BUDGET PROPOSAL. O. WE HAVE
HOURS AND HOURS AND HOURS ON THE
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARINGS DEBATE
DISCUSSION.
ON WE HAVE PUBLIC TESTIMONY
PUBLIC COMMENT THE BULK OF THE
BUDGET IS DONE IN THAT PROCESS
THE VERY. LARGE BALK I DON'T
KNOW THE EXACT NUMBER BUT I
WOULD SAY PROBABLY NINETY TO
NINETY FIVE PERCENT BUDGETS
HUNDRED AND. FORTY BILLION
DOLLARS YOU'RE PROBABLY SINGLE
LARGE PART OF IT DONE STOOD OUT
SUBCOMMITTEE PROCESS AND THAT
DISCUSSION THAT DEBATE
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE.
IRONS OUT THE FINAL FINAL FINAL
DETAILS THE FINAL PUBLISHED FEW
BILLION DOLLARS THAT WE ARE
EARNING OUTSIDE OF PROP NINETY
WHICH.
.
IT'S OBVIOUSLY A LARGE CHUNK OF
THE BUDGET A SEPARATE FROM THAT
THAT THE FINAL. EVALUATION OF
THAT HOME WE ARE IN DISCUSSION
ABOUT REALLY JUST FINE TUNING
THE ULTIMATE DETAILS OF OUR
BUDGET. LARGE PART OF IT AGAIN
GHOSTS WITHOUT SUBCOMMITTEE
PROCESS THROUGH EXHAUSTIVE
DISCRETION IF YOU STICK TO OUR.
OR SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER ONE
WHICH IS.
DOCTOR ARAMBULA CHAIRS AYE IF
YOU CAN TELL YOU ABOUT HOW MANY
HOURS AND HOURS.
HEARINGS ON EVERY SINGLE ITEM
THEY HAVE NOT NOT HAVING HAVING
SAID IT A WHAT IT CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE ITSELF COULD BE
IMPROVED AYE I THINK ABSOLUTELY
THERE'S ALWAYS ROOM FOR
IMPROVEMENT. I THINK THIS YEAR
ON. EVERY ETHNIC EVERY BUDGET IS
REALLY DEPENDENT ON HOW
DISCUSSIONS GO. TO AND HOW THAT
FEEDBACK IS DONE TO WEAR IT.
THE DIFFERENT VERSIONS ARE AND
HOW THAT.
DISCUSSION OR GOES THROUGH WHEN
THIS YEAR DID SEEM TO BE A
LITTLE BIT HARDER THAN THE
PREVIOUS TWO YEARS THAT I'VE
BEEN INVOLVED IN THE BUDGET. ON
THINK THERE VARIETY OF FACTORS I
DON'T THINK ANY OF THEM ARE.
TOM YOU KNOW ARE ANY OF THEM ARE
SOME THINGS THAT WE WOULD CARRY
OVER TO NEXT YEAR. BUT I THINK
IT'S JUST DEPENDENT ON WHERE THE
WHERE THE HOUSES ARE AND WHERE
THE GOVERNOR'S.
BUT AGAIN I THINK THE ARM BULK
OF THE BUDGET THIS IS WHAT I
FIVE HAD NO NUMBER TOM RESOURCES
WITH RESTORED NOTED THAT. THE
BULK OF THE BUDGET THE
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT THE
DISCUSSION IS DONE AND THAT SUB
COMMITTEE. PROCESS. AND THAT IS
DONE THROUGH HOURS AND HOURS AND
HOURS A PAINSTAKING TESTIMONY
AND FEEDBACK AND IT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE.
WILL TAKE VERY SERIOUSLY I KNOW
ALL OUR STAFF TAKE VERY
SERIOUSLY AND I JUST ENCOURAGE.
EVERYBODY WHETHER IT'S US AS
SENATORS ASSEMBLYMEMBERS OR OR
THE PUBLIC OR. LA EL OR FINANCED
THAT IS REALLY WHERE I FEEL LIKE
THE BULK OF THE GIVE AND TAKE ON
THE BUDGET PROCESS ART DID THIS
IS REALLY DEFINE. THE FINE
TUNING THIS IS SORT OF LIKE
ICING ON THE CAKE AT THAT POINT
THE KICKS ALREADY. BEEN BACK
THROUGH THAT PROCESS SO THAT'S
THAT'S HOW I WOULD.
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION FOR MAYBE
JUST TO.
TERM ROUTE RESPOND.
MY REVIEW OF THIS. LITTLE
RESEARCH I GOT ON THE STATE
CONSTITUTION IS YOU'RE RIGHT YOU
GO THROUGH THE.
SUBCOMMITTEE PROCESS AND I'VE.
WRITTEN A LITTLE TOO GOOD BINDER
FULL OF STUFF.
THIS YEAR IN SUB ONE IN. AND
BRIGHT ENJOY THE PROCESS. AND
AND FLY HOME LATE ON THURSDAYS
BECAUSE OF IT.
BUT. THAT THE GOVERNOR SUPPOSED
TO GIVE THE. BUDGET ON JANUARY
TEN WE GO THROUGH SUB WHAT WE GO
THROUGH OUR SUBCOMMITTEES.
AND.
AND THEN WE SHOULD GO THROUGH
BUDGET CONFERENCE COMMITTEE.
BUT SUCH AND THEN IT GOES TO THE
GOVERNOR.
THAT'S HOW I I INTERPRETED THE
CONSTITUTION BUT NOW IT'S.
JANUARY CHEN SUBCOMMITTEES
THE GOVERNOR INSERTS.
WE GET A BUDGET AND THEN IT
COMES TO THE CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE SO WE GET A PRESS
RELEASE THIS MORNING ITS HAS
EVERYTHING'S DONE AND. OVER IN.
AND SO.
I THINK MAYBE A REVIEW OF WHAT
THE CONSTITUTIONAL REQUIREMENTS
ARE.
I THINK THAT MIGHT BE GOOD FOR
REVIEW OUR FAVORITE SOUND WE
WERE GIVEN A GOOD PAPER ON IT
I'D I'D APPRECIATE THAT FOR FOR
NEXT YEAR.
THANK YOU MUCH THANK YOU.
SEEING NO OTHER COMMENTS I
BELIEVE WE CAN GO TO.
BUDGETS ARE CENTER OFF DID YOU.
I'M AYE POLITICS WAS SPEAK FEEL
FREE NOT NOW IS THE TIME.
WE ARE GOING TO GO TO MISS
COSTA DEPARTMENT FOR.
THANK YOU GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIRMAN I'M VICE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS IN THE COST OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE MANY GET
JUST A COUPLE OF HIGH LEVEL
COMMENTS GIVEN THE LATENESS OF
THE HOUR AND TEN FOR MY
TESTIMONY TO BE CHRIS.
HOWEVER MEMBERS SHOULD FEEL FREE
TO STOP ME AT ANY TIME WITH ANY
QUESTIONS I'LL HIGHLIGHT THE
HIGH DOLLAR AMOUNT NUMBERS THAT
ARE PACKAGED WHEN WITHIN EACH
EACH OF THE ISSUES AND TRY AND
PICK OUT THE TOPICS THAT WERE
DISCUSSED AT LENGTH DURING THE
COMMITTEE PROCESS.
THERE MAY BE A NUMBER OF
LEGISLATIVE AUGMENTATIONS THAT I
WILL DEFER TO THE CHAIR AND THE
VICE CHAIR TO EXPLAIN BECAUSE
THEY'RE PART OF THE.
AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THAT.
LEGISLATIVE LEADERSHIP.
I ISSUE ONE OMINOUS BEEN A
LITTLE BIT OF TIME ON THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE BECAUSE IT
REALLY UNDER PENS THE STRUCTURE
OF THE BUDGET ITSELF. INSULA BE
A COUPLE OF ITEMS I'M GOING TO
PREVIEW THAT WILL GET TO LATER
BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO DO WITH
RESERVES FINDS AND REALLY THE
FUNDAMENTALS OF THIS PARTICULAR
BUDGET. THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE ADOPT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S BIG THREE
REVENUE ASSUMPTIONS AND THE LA
OWES PROPERTY TAX GROWTH RATE
ESTIMATE.
OR FISCAL ESTIMATES ARE
PRELIMINARY AT THIS POINT A
BECAUSE WE WILL RECONCILE ALL OF
THE AMOUNTS AFTER CONFERENCE
COMPLETE AND WE CAN TALLY ALL OF
THE TOTAL SO PLEASE NOTE THAT
THESE ARE ROUGH ESTIMATE FROM
THE LARGE NUMBERS.
BUDGET YEAR REVENUES AND
TRANSFERS ARE ROUGHLY ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN POINT
SEVEN BILLION WITH PROPOSED
EXPENDITURES ESTIMATED AT ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT POINT
SIX BILLION. TOTAL FUNDS ARE
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED
BILLION.
THE COMPROMISE FULLY FUNDS THE
BUDGET STABILIZATION ACT TO THE
CONSTITUTIONAL TARGET BY
PROVIDING A FOUR POINT THREE SIX
BILLION DOLLAR DEPOSIT.
BRINGING THE TOTAL READY DAILY.
FUND ABOUT TO THIRTEEN POINT
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS.
WE ALSO CREATE TWO NEW RESERVES
TO ASSIST THE STATE AND
WEATHERING OUR NEXT RECESSION.
THE SENATE'S SAFETY NET RESERVE
IS CREATED WITH AN INITIAL
DEPOSIT OF TWO HUNDRED MILLION.
THESE INITIAL FUNDS ARE FOR CAL
WORKS AND FUTURE FUNDS CAN BE
UTILIZED FOR CAL WORKS AND THAT
A CALCULATED.
THE ASSEMBLY IS BUDGET DEFICIT
SAVINGS ACCOUNT HAS ALSO CREATED
AND WILL HOLD THE AGREED UPON
SUPPLEMENTAL BUDGET.
THE BSA AMOUNT OF TWO POINT SIX
BILLION ONCE THE RAINY DAY FUND
AMOUNT IS UPDATED IN NEXT YEAR'S
MAY REVISION FUNDS WILL BE
TRANSFERRED TO THE BUDGET
STABILIZATION ACCOUNT TO MEET
THE CONSTITUTIONAL TEN PERCENT
GOAL. ANY REMAINING BALANCE WILL
BE DIVIDED BETWEEN THE BUDGET
DEFICIT SAVINGS ACCOUNT. AND THE
AFOREMENTIONED SAFETY NET
RESERVES.
BUT FILLING THE RAINY DAY FUND
WE ARE ALSO BEGINNING FUTURE
INFRASTRUCTURE AS REQUIRED UNDER
PROPOSITION TWO IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY THROUGH TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO. WE ESTIMATE
ROUGHLY FOUR HUNDRED AND TEN
MILLION DOLLARS WILL FUND STATE
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS
REMAINING FUNDS WILL BE
ALLOCATED EVENLY TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS AND RAIL
PROJECTS.
WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS.
VICTIMS COSTA ANY QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
OKAY SEEING NONE.
SHALL WE GO TO ISSUE ONE.
ISSUE NUMBER TWO MISTER CHERISH
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
CERTIFICATION.
WELL.
ISSUE TWO I APOLOGIZE.
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT AN ISSUE.
CARNESECCA.
SEVERAL YARDS LIKE TO BIFURCATE.
THE THE FOURTH BULLET COULD DO
THE FIRST THREE THAT NUMBER FOUR.
SEPARATELY.
OKAY.
SO YOU WOULD LIKE TO SEPARATE
OUT ALLOCATES PROPOSITION TWO
INFRASTRUCTURE.
REVENUES POLITICALLY CORRECT IS
THAT CORRECT OKAY.
YES.
WALK SHE OF ITS A CALCIFIED BOTH
MOTIONS FOR BOTH MEN WOULD JUST
TAKE A SEPARATE VOTE IF THAT'S
OKAY.
SO WE'RE GOING ON THE FIRST
THREE ONE OF THE FIRST THREE.
THE FIRST THREE BULLETS UPS ARE.
THE FIRST THREE BOATS.
WE'RE FIVE A FUNDS ARE FIGURE
FIVE OH FIVE ON THE FIRST THREE
VOTES.
OKAY NOW WE'RE TAKING THIS THE
LAST WILL ALLOCATE PROP TWO
INFRASTRUCTURE REVENUES.
I'M SAYING THREE.
TWO THREE TWO.
OKAY THREE TWO THREE TWO
.
ISSUE TWO.
PROPERTY CERTIFICATION.
WE SUPPORT THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISED THE SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY BOTH ADOPTED THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT CERTIFICATION
PROPOSAL WITH MODIFICATIONS TO
EXTEND THE TIMELINE FOR
LEGISLATIVE REVIEW OF THE
PROPOSED PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT MINIMUM GUARANTEE AND TO
INCREASE LEGISLATIVE AUTHORITY
IN THAT PROCESS.
THE CONFERENCE COMPROMISE
PROVIDES AN EXTENDED ONE MONTH
COMMENT PERIOD FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO PROVIDE FEEDBACK
ON ANY PROPOSED CERTIFICATION
BEFORE THE FINAL CERTIFICATION
IS ISSUED BY THE DIRECTOR OF
FINANCE.
AND RETAINS THE LEGISLATURE'S
ABILITY TO ADOPT AN ALTERNATIVE
PLAN FOR REPAYMENT OF SUBTLE LAP
FUNDING IDENTIFIED THROUGH THE
CERTIFICATION PROCESS.
THANK YOU.
I LIKED HER AGAIN DOCTOR
MEMBERS OUT THE ROOM FOR SECOND
FOR ISSUE ONE ARAMBULA.
I SO FIVE ALL FIVE OUT.
ON BOTH ITEMS.
SO FIRST THREE TO FIVE OO FIVE
OO THREE TWO THREE TWO EXCUSE ME
THANK YOU.
UP.
ISSUE TWO.
MOTION DOES A MOTION A SECOND
ISSUE TO.
THEN MOVE BACK INTO MORE LOTS
GET FIVE FIVE OH FIVE OUT. THANK
YOU ON ISSUE TO.
ISSUE THREE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA.
AND SPECIAL EDUCATION.
THANK YOU THIS OTHER ISSUE THREE
DEALS OF LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA IN SPECIAL EDUCATION IT
PROVIDE.
THREE POINT SIX BILLION ONGOING
FOR THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA
IT'S FOR HIM AND SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS ABOVE ABOVE PROPOSED
PROVIDES THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS ONE TIME AND PROCESS
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT I
GENERAL FUND. FOR THE LOW
PERFORMING STUDENTS BLOCK GRANTS.
AND.
THE AGENDA NOTES THAT THE
CONFERENCE COMPROMISE DOES NOT
INCLUDE ANY FUNDING FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION HOWEVER I WOULD KNOW
THAT IN THE LATER ITEM ON ISSUE
NUMBER SEVEN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO
RECRUIT SPECIAL EDUCATION
TEACHERS IS APPROVED.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOW.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
I'D LIKE TO RAISE AN ISSUE THAT
SAID.
ACTUALLY CAUSING ME SOME
CONCERN BECAUSE THEY'VE RECEIVED
A LETTER.
ALL ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS THAT
DATA EXPRESSES.
A GOOD DEAL OF CONCERN OVER THE.
.
NON INCLUSION OF THE.
ASSEMBLY BUDGET PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE. ONGOING FUNDING FOR
SUPPLEMENTAL. GRANTS FOR THE
LOWEST PERFORMING STUDENTS
SUBGROUP.
.
THAT IS A CONCERN.
A IN THE CAUCUSES IS SO DEEP
THAT.
OF THE LETTER EXPRESSES THE THE
THOUGHT THAT SOME OF A OF MY
COLLEAGUES MIGHT ACTUALLY NOT GO
UP ON THE BUDGET OVER THIS ISSUE
AND AS YOU KNOW.
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF MS COSTA
THAT'S A. PRETTY SERIOUS SIR OF
A THING TO SAY SO I'M I'M
WONDERING IF YOU COULD.
A TALK ABOUT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S THINKING ON
THIS ISSUE AND. WHY THE
ADMINISTRATION LAND WHERE TED?
THANK YOU I WOULD NOTE THIS WAS
A WOULD INITIALLY ORIGINALLY A
LEGISLATIVE AUGMENTATION AND
THAT THE FINAL PRODUCT
REPRESENTS AN AGREEMENT BETWEEN
THE THREE PARTIES BETWEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE RESPECTIVE
HOUSES.
CAN THE ADMINISTRATION PROVIDE
IT AT THIS.
SO THIS WAS A PROPOSAL FROM THE
ASSEMBLY AND AS I UNDERSTAND IT
THE ADMINISTRATION.
DIDN'T LIKE THE PROPOSAL SO IS
A MEMBER OF THE ASSEMBLY I'M
JUST ASKING WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S THINKING IS AND.
NOT BEING ABLE TO SUPPORT IT.
I DON'T KNOW THAT THAT'S AN
ACCURATE CHARACTERIZATION OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S VIEW OF THIS
PARTICULAR PROPOSAL THE SENATE
HAD A SIMILAR PROPOSAL. ON TO
DEAL WITH.
LOW PERFORMING STUDENTS THERE
WERE SLIGHT DIFFERENCES AND SO.
THE THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS ONE TIME REPRESENTS A
COMPROMISE.
BETWEEN THOSE TWO PROPOSALS BY
BY THE SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY.
I.
WHETHER OR NOT I'VE
CHARACTERIZED IT ACCURATELY.
YOU CAN CHARACTERIZE IT AND
PROVIDE US WITH SOME SUBSTANTIVE
RESPONSE ACTING.
THAT'S WHAT I'M ASKING FOR.
I THINK THE UNDERPINNING OF BOTH
POLICY PROPOSALS BUFF BROUGHT
FORWARD BY THE SENATE AND THE
ASSEMBLY. UP WERE TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO THE LOWEST
PERFORMING STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE SLIGHT DIFFERENCES ARE.
THE LANGUAGE APPROACH WHICH I
TESTIFIED TO A PREVIOUSLY THIS
WEEK.
ON AND THE FINAL PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT PACKAGE HAS ONE
TIME FUNDING APPROPRIATED FOR
THIS PURPOSE VERSES THE
ASSEMBLIES VERSION WHICH HAD AN
ONGOING FUNDING STREAM. BUT THE
POLICY UNDERPINNINGS OF BOTH
PROPOSALS ARE VERY SIMILAR AND I
THINK ENCOMPASSED IN THE
CONFERENCE COMPROMISE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM.
NEITHER.
QUESTIONS CENTER SKINNER.
I.
WANT TO ADD THAT I'M VERY
PLEASED THAT.
WE HAVE.
A GOOD AMOUNT OF FUNDS
PROVIDER SCHOOLS AND THAT WE ARE
INCREASING THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA.
THOUGH I AM DISAPPOINTED THAT WE
WERE NOT ABLE TO MAKE THE
ADJUSTMENT FOR SPECIAL ED. OR
THE ON GOING.
THE ABILITY TO DO THE ONGOING
FUNDING FOR THE LOW PERFORMING
STUDENTS BUT I THINK THIS BOTH
OF THOSE THAT IN THE SPECIAL ED.
NOT DIGESTING THAT.
ON.
IS STILL OF BED IN AREA THAT.
PUTS A LOT OF OUR CHILDREN AND
FURTHER AT RISK IN IS SOMETHING
THAT WE HAVE TO COMMIT OURSELVES
TO CONTINUING TO.
ADDRESSING WORK ON.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS SIMILAR.
I MAYBE MISSED CASA YOU COULD
EXPLAIN.
THAT YOU'RE ACTUALLY TAKING
CARE SPECIAL EDUCATION PRETTY
THOROUGHLY AND.
ISSUE SEVEN TWO TO BALANCE IT
OUT SO WAS A CONCERN OF MINE.
BECAUSE WELL AS PART OF SUB ONE.
I WANT TO JUMP TO FAR AHEAD BUT
WE DO HAVE A TEACHER RECRUITMENT
AND RETENTION UP BOZELL THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION INCLUDED. I'M
SPECIFICALLY FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHERS AND SO
ALTHOUGH THE PROPOSAL WAS FOR
SPECIAL ED EQUALIZATION WHICH
WOULD.
BE AN ON GOING FUNDING SOURCE WE
DO HAVE SAN AND.
DOLLARS BILL TEND TO HAVE
INCREASED THE NUMBER OF SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHERS IN CALIFORNIA
WHICH HAS BEEN A HISTORIC
SHORTAGE AREA FOR THE STATE.
A MOVIE I ITEM.
GREAT DRAGON A SECOND TO MOVE
FARTHER COMPASS COMMITTEE
COMPROMISE THE CONFERENCE COULD
CUT.
SENATE MITCHELL.
I WAS JUST.
ALSO AS WERE.
NOT TO JUMP AHEAD BUT AS WE
THINK ABOUT THIS POPULATION.
RECOGNIZE I THINK THERE ARE ALSO
SOME FUND AND THE CHILD CARE
SECTION WHICH IS SORELY NEEDED.
AROUND THE TRAINING AND
RECRUITMENT OF CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS ARE NOT NOT TO SAY
THAT EITHER THESE TWO PROPOSALS.
.
OUTWEIGH THE LOSS IN THE IN THE
IN THE LC FF FUNDING BUT AS WE
TALK ABOUT THIS HIGH NEED
POPULATION RECOGNIZING THE EARLY
CARE AND EDUCATION THAT THERE'S
INVESTMENT ALSO SO WE CAN GET TO
THAT LATER ON THE AGENDA BUT IT
JUST OCCURREDTO ME THAT WE WANT
TO. I WANT YOU JUST PINPOINT
THAT NOW AS WELL.
THANK YOU CENTER.
OKAY.
SEE NO THE COMET DOG CAN WE GET
A VOTE ON ISSUE NUMBER THREE.
FIVE OH FOR OUR.
FIVE OH FOR.
YOU FOUR KEY TWELVE ONE TIME
FUNDING AUGMENTATION.
THE CONFERENCE COMPROMISED
TOTALS A ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN
ONE TIME PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT FUNDING AGAIN I'M GOING TO
JUST HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE OF AND
AS.
THE BROADER ITEMS HERE.
.
AND INCLUDES I HAD TWO HUNDRED
AND NINETY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
IN K. TWELVE ONE TIME
DISCRETIONARY SPENDING.
IT INCLUDES.
ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY SEVEN
POINTS TO AN EARLY EDUCATION
EXPANSION GRANTS.
I'M AS A JUST REFERENCE THERE
SEVENTY FIVE.
MILLION DOLLARS FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHER RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS.
AHA AND WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
I THINK YOU MISS COSTA WE HAVE A
WITH THE MOTION IS SECOND.
SENATORS.
FIVE OO.
FOR.
ON THE ASSEMBLY FIVE OH ON THE
SENATE.
ISSUE FIVE CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION.
WE SUPPORT THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE.
OTHER CONFERENCE COMPROMISE
WOULD RETAIN ALL OF THE FEATURES
OF THE GOVERNOR'S ORIGINAL.
ON GOING CT <c.green> PROPOSAL BUT</c>
WOULD REDUCE FUNDING FOR THE
PROGRAM FOR THE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS WE PROPOSE TO
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION.
THE COMPROMISE WOULD PROVIDE AN
ADDITIONAL ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION TO PROMOTE HE FOUND THE
EXISTING CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION AND SENATE GRANT.
OPERATED WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
THE COMPROMISE ALSO INCLUDES
ADDITIONAL ACCOUNTABILITY
LANGUAGE TO ENSURE BETTER
REPORTING OF OUTCOMES FOR THIS
PROGRAM. WITH PARTICULAR FOCUS
ON THE ALIGNMENT OF THIS PROGRAM
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IN
THE EXISTING CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STRONG
WORKFORCE PROGRAM.
THANK YOU MISS BECAUSE THE KIND
OF OUR ANY QUESTIONS.
SIR NIELSEN.
I'D WOULD SALUTE COMPROMISE I
MIGHT HAVE BEEN A LITTLE HAPPIER
WITH MORE IN THE INCENTIVE GRANT.
BUT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT THE
GOVERNOR EXPANDED.
AN INCENTIVE GRANT FROM LONG AGO
A FEW YEARS AGO AND IT'S BEEN
VERY VERY VALUABLE.
TO ADVANCING CT <c.green>.</c>
GIVING THE LOCAL PROVIDERS AND
THE SCHOOLS SOME OPPORTUNITY.
FOR A LITTLE BIT OF ADVANCEMENT
THIS BEEN A VERY HELPFUL TO CT.
THANK YOU SIR I'M OF THE
GOVERNOR.
LIVE A MOTION AND A SECOND TO
APPROVE THE COMPROMISE.
FIVE OH ON THE SENATE.
FIVE OH ON THE ASSEMBLY.
THANK YOU.
ISSUE SIX KINDERGARTEN PRESCHOOL
AND AFTER SCHOOL.
WE SUPPORT THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE.
THIS COMPROMISE PROVIDES ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME
NON PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND FOR FACILITIES TO
INCREASE ACCESS TO EXTENDED DAY
KINDERGARTEN PROGRAMS YOU MAY
RECALL WE TALKED ABOUT THIS
ISSUE EXTENSIVELY EARLIER THIS
WEEK. ONE OF THE BIGGEST
BARRIERS TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
PROVIDING EXTENDED DAY
KINDERGARTEN AS A LACK OF
APPROPRIATE FACILITIES AND THE
ADMINISTRATION AGREES THAT
TARGETING FUNDS FOR THIS PURPOSE
IS A GOOD USE OF OUR ONETIME
RESOURCES.
THE FUNDS WILL PROVIDE GRANTS TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT CURRENTLY
DO NOT PROVIDE FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN TO CONSTRUCT A
RETROFIT CLASSROOMS TO
ACCOMMODATE THE EXPANSION WITH
PRIORITY FOR FINANCIAL HARDSHIP
DISTRICTS AND THOSE LOCATED IN
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. WITH
HIGH POPULATIONS OF STUDENTS
ELIGIBLE FOR FREE OR REDUCED
PRICE MEALS.
THANK YOU MISS COST.
ACT TO THE COMMITTEE.
SO WITH A MOTION AND A SECOND TO
ADOPT THE COMPROMISE WE HAVE
FIVE OH IN THE SENATE.
WE HAVE THREE TWO IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
ISSUE SEVEN TEACHER WORKFORCE
INVESTMENTS.
THANK YOU THIS IS THE ISSUE I
REFERENCE MO ADD JUST A FEW
MOMENTS AGO.
WE SUPPORT THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE.
ON IT WOULD PROVIDE FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT FOR THE
LOCAL SOLUTIONS GRANT PROGRAM TO
PROVIDE GRANTS TO LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES DEVELOP NEW
OR EXPAND EXISTING LOCALLY
IDENTIFIED SOLUTIONS. THAT
ADDRESS THEIR LOCAL NEED FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHERS.
THE COMPROMISE ALSO INCLUDE
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS ONE
TIME PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
FOR THE TEACHER RESIDENCY GRANT
PROGRAM SPECIFYING THAT FIFTY
MILLION IS SET ASIDE FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION. AND TWENTY FIVE
MILLION FOR OTHER TEACHER
SHORTAGE AREAS INCLUDING STEM
AND BILINGUAL EDUCATION.
I CAN DISCUSS BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
I TO UP MOTION A SECOND TO MOVE
THE COMPROMISE.
WE HAVE.
FIVE.
IN THE ASSEMBLY FIVE ON THE
SENATE THANK YOU.
ISSUE WAIT DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION STATE OPERATIONS.
CAN WE HAVE ANOTHER A COMPROMISE
PROPOSAL HERE THE COMPROMISE
ALLOCATES TWO MILLION DOLLARS A
FEDERAL TITLE THREE FUNDS TO THE
EXISTING ELEVEN COUNT.
EDUCATION AT REGIONALES.
AND ESTABLISHES PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE HOLDING THE COUNTY
OFFICES ACCOUNTABLE FOR IMPROVE
STUDENT PERFORMANCE WITHIN THEIR
RESPECTIVE AGENCIES.
THE COMPROMISE PROVIDES THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE EDUCATION
WITH FOUR HUNDRED AND THIRTY
SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
FEDERAL TITLE THREE FUNDS TO
DEVELOP A TEACHER OBSERVATION
PROTOCOL.
FOR EVALUATING THE ENGLISH
PROFICIENCY OF ENGLISH LEARNERS.
HE WAS GONE.
AND A MOTION A SECOND TO ADOPT
THEIR CONFERENCE COMPROMISE.
FIVE A ON THE ASSEMBLY.
I FOR ONE ON THE SENATE.
I ISSUE NINE.
NIELSEN.
I ISSUE NINE K. TWELVE FEDERAL
FUNDS.
I HAVE TO APOLOGIZE I READ THE
WRONG ITEM STUFF WHAT I JUST
READ WITH ACTUALLY ISSUE NINE
WHICH IS THE KEY TWELVE FEDERAL
FUNDS ARE JUST AS A POINT OF
CLARIFICATION.
THE SOCIAL WILL SO YOU DID VOTED
ON ISSUE NUYS YOU KNOW THAT'S
WHAT I PRESENTED TO THE
COMMITTEE I APOLOGIZE.
OKAY I'M SORRY WE WILL REDO THE
VOTE ON ISSUE NUMBER NINE.
ISSUE NINE WE HAVE. A WE WILL
SUBSTITUTE THE MOTION FOR
PREVIOUS TO TAKE A VOTE ON ISSUE
NINE OF K. TWELVE FEDERAL FUNDS.
WE HAVE.
FOR.
ON THE ASSEMBLY AND WE HAVE.
FOR ONE SKINNER NIELSEN.
NO. MISTER KILEY ABSTAINED.
ON ISSUE NINE SO WE'RE GOING TO
GO BACK TO ISSUE EIGHT WHICH IS
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION STATE
OPERATIONS.
THANK YOU I APOLOGIZE FOR THE
CONFUSION ISSUE EIGHT IS THE
CONFERENCECOMPROMISE INCLUDING
ACTIONS RELATED TO THE PARDON OF
EDUCATION'S STATE OPERATIONS
FUNDING.
HER MOTION.
IF YOU.
I MOTION AND A SECOND TO ADOPT
THE CONFERENCE COMPROMISE WE
HAVE FIVE OO IN THE ASSEMBLY
FIVE OO IN THE SENATE THANK YOU
FOR ISSUE IT.
ISSUE TEN K. TWELVE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE.
WE SUPPORT THE COMPROMISE IT
INCLUDES.
REPEALING THE OUTDATED STATUTES
RELATED TO THE ACADEMIC
PERFORMANCE INDEX WHICH HAVE
BEEN
SPEND IT SINCE TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN.
I IT THE CONFERENCE COMPROMISE
DOES NOT INCLUDE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE REQUIRING THE OFFICE OF
PUBLIC SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION TO
PROCESS THE ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION APPLICATIONS FOR
PROPOSITION FIFTY ONE SCHOOL
FACILITIES FUNDING EACH YEAR.
THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
THREE AND TO INCOME FOR ALL
FUNDS.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DID
ALREADY INCLUDE SIX HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
SCHOOL FACILITIES WHICH ALIGNS
WITH THE CURRENT STAFFING LEVELS
AND THE PRODUCTION AT THE OFFICE
OF PUBLIC SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND TO
MOVE.
THE COMPROMISE FOR ISSUE TEN.
FOUR ZERO ON THE ASSEMBLY. FIVE
OH ANDREA SENATE WITH MR
CURRENTLY UPSTANDING.
THE ISSUE ELEVEN CHILDCARE.
THANK YOU WE SUPPORT BIG
CONFERENCE COMPROMISED
COMPROMISE SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASES ACCESS TO CHILDCARE
PROGRAMS MAKING TARGETED
INVESTMENTS IN RATES IN QUALITY
IN A MATTER THAT ACCOUNTS FOR
THE UNCERTAINTY AROUND THE
CONTINUED ALLOCATION OF INCREASE
FEDERAL FUNDS.
THE CONFERENCE COMPROMISED FOR
CHILD CARE INCLUDES A TOTAL OF
ONE BILLION DOLLARS FOR
CHILDCARE AND EARLY LEARNING
LEARNING PROGRAMS BETWEEN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND NINETEEN
TWENTY WITH FEDERAL SPUR. FUNDS
SPREAD OUT THROUGH TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. IT INCREASES ACCESS
TO SUBSIDIZE CHILDCARE VOUCHERS
FOR THIRTEEN THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED CHILDREN THROUGH TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO. IT INCREASES
REIMBURSEMENT RATES FOR
PROVIDERS SERVING INFANTS AND
TODDLERS AND CHILDREN'S WITH
DISABILITIES OF THE VICE CHAIR
MENTIONED EARLIER. AND IT
PROVIDES FOR ANNUAL INSPECTIONS
FOR LICENSED CHILDCARE I HAVE
PROVIDERS CURRENTLY INSPECTIONS
HAPPENED APPROXIMATELY ONCE
EVERY THREE YEARS.
THANK YOU.
I LET MOTION IS SECOND TO ADOPT
A COMPROMISE FOR ISSUE ELEVEN.
FIVE OH FIVE WELL THANK YOU.
ISSUE TWELVE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA PACKAGE.
FINANCE SUPPORTS THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISED FOR THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA PACKAGE IT
INCLUDES FUNDING PROPOSED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THIS PACKAGE
REFLECTS THE MIX OF ONE TIME AN
ONGOING RESOURCES TO SUPPORT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
OPERATIONAL NEEDS. AND ROLE
ADDITIONAL STUDENTS AND SUPPORT
UC BERKELEY'S EFFORTS TO ADDRESS
THE CAMPUSES OPERATING DEFICIT.
THE CONFERENCE ACTION A IS TO
PROVIDE ONE HUNDRED FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS ONE TIME GENERAL FUND TO
THE UNIVERSITY REFLECT THE
STATE'S COMMITMENT TO
MAINTAINING AND AFFORDABLE. AND
HIGH QUALITY EDUCATION FOR
STUDENTS ATTENDING THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
FURTHER THE COMPROMISE ACTION
SHIFTS AN ON GOING EIGHT POINT
SIX MILLION FROM THE OFFICE OF
THE PRESIDENT BUDGET TO SUPPORT
ENROLLMENT GO GROWTH. AND
PROVIDES AN ADDITIONAL FIVE
MILLION ON GOING ON A TO SUPPORT
ENROLLMENT GROWTH.
COMBINED THESE RESOURCES WILL
SUPPORT THE ENROLLMENT AT TWO
THOUSAND ADDITIONAL STUDENTS IN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
THANK YOU MISS COSTA.
SENATOR MORLOCK.
CHAIR OF THIS COST OF.
A QUICK QUESTION TO THE NEXT
ITEM ISSUE THIRTEEN.
SEEMS TO HAVE A STRONGER ONGOING
SUPPORT FOR THE CSU VERSES.
THE UC AND SINISTER SORT OF
SISTERS I JUST KINDA.
CURIOUSWHY THE DIFFERENCE.
I WOULD ACTUALLY KNOWN I DON'T
WANNA SKIP AHEAD TO FAR BUT
THERE'S ALSO A ONE TIME
COMPONENT IN THE C. ISSUE BUDGET
YOU ARE RIGHT THERE IS AN
ONGOING COMPONENT TO THIS YES
YOU.
BUT BOTH SEGMENTS ACTUALLY AS
PROPOSED HAVE SOME A ONE TIME
MONEY.
ON AND I THINK.
IT'S SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT WHEN WE
GET TO SEE ISSUE ON THE ONE TIME
BECAUSE HOUSE TO DO WITH AND. I
THINK BLENDING THEIR GRADUATION
INITIATIVE FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA I THINK.
THERE A COUPLE OF DIFFERENT
ITEMS HERE EONS.
.
SOME OF THIS HAS TO DO WITH THE
OVERALL PRIORITIES.
OF GENERAL FUND SPENDING IN THE
STRUCTURE OF THE BUDGET ITSELF.
SO YOU THINK AT THE END OF THE
DAY IT.
SORT OF BALANCES OUT THE.
ONE TIME MONEY GOING TO UC'S.
COMPARABLE TO THE ONGOING. GOT
GOING TO THE CSU.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT BALANCES OUT
BETWEEN THE TWO SEGMENTS I THINK
THAT FUNDAMENTALLY THEY SERVE
VERY DIFFERENT STUDENTS AND.
DIFFERENT NUMBERS OF STUDENTS
CANDIDLY BETWEEN THE SEGMENTS.
I THINK THAT IT BALANCES THE
OVERALL STRUCTURE OF THE BUDGET
IN WHICH
ALL WE WANTED TO LIMIT OUR
ONGOING RESOURCES AND BUILD UP.
PRETTY.
ROBUST RESERVE FUNDS.
OKAY.
CHAIR.
ARE.
YOUR YOUR MATERIAL PROVIDES
BULLET POINTS.
SO YES IT'S KIND OF HARD TO SAY
NUMBER FOUR OR.
THE OR FOURTH.
WELL IF YOU WANT TO READ WHICH
PULL A POINT YOU WANT TO BREAK
OUT FEEL FREE TO AYE I'D LIKE
HIS BREAKOUT TO FOR MY VOTE
MISTER.
CHAIR A. I WOULD BE OPPOSED TO.
WELL I LIKE TO VOTE SEPARATELY
ON THE TWENTY FIVE MILLION ONE
TIME. FOR YOU SEE BOOK BERKELEY
MAYBE THAT.
AS CASA CAN EXPLAIN WHY ONE
CAMPUS NEEDS TO HAVE FUNDING I
I'M BY NO BETTER NO WORSE
BECAUSE IT'S THE BEST CAMPUS IN
THE COUNTRY.
BUT THAT'S JUST MY PERSONS I
WOULD HAVE TO CONCUR I WISH I'D
DONE THERE BUT NOT AS HANDSOME
AS YOU.
AND THEN THE THE OTHER IS THE
FOUR MILLION ONE TIME TO PROVIDE
LEGAL SERVICES FOR UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS STUDENTS I LIKE THAT.
HAVE THOSE TO PULL.
OKAY WERE THERE ANY OTHER ITEMS
I WANTED TO BE DONE SEPARATELY.
YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE.
I WAS ALSO POLL THE ONE POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
UCLA RAFT RALPH. J. BIRCH CENTER.
BUNCH OF THE BUNCH.
SENATOR NIELSEN.
MISTER CHAIRMAN THE UP FROM THE
SECOND PAGE THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE. CAMPUSES HAVE TO
REPORT USES OF FUNDING.
AT AND THAT LIKE TO PUT THAT
ONE AND A SEPARATE ONE.
THAT DID THIS IS SO DATA THAT
WILL BE PRESENTED THAT I THINK
COULD BE USED IN.
HUESO I JUST PREFER NOT TO.
SUPPORT.
THAT IS THE FIFTH BULLET ON THE
SECOND PAGE PAGE THIRTY FIFTH
BULLET DOWN.
VERY GOOD WORSE IS ADOPT
ASSEMBLY VERSION OF TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE.
REQUIRED CAMPUSES TO REPORT ON
USES OF FUNDING AND OUTCOMES
RELATED TO EFFORTS TO ADDRESS
STUDENT HUNGER AND THEY
SICKENING SUCCESSOR.
AND THEN ALSO MISTER CHAIRMAN
THE.
FARMS ARE NOW I AND WITH
POSTING THEM DEMOGRAPHIC AND
COMPENSATION.
SO THOSE WOULD BE TOO ON THE
SECOND PAGE THE NUMBER ONE
BULLET AND THE NUMBER FIVE
BULLET ON PAGE TWO.
HERE MOVE THE COMPROMISE WITH
THE EXCLUSION.
ASIDE.
I APOLOGIZE WE WERE MAKING ONE.
CORRECTION TO THE AGENDA WE ARE
REMOVING THE FIRST BULLET ON
PAGE TWO WHICH SAYS. ENCOURAGES
YOU SEE TO ANNUALLY POST
EMPLOYEE DEMOGRAPHIC AND
COMPENSATION INFORMATION THAT IS
BEING TO LEAD IT.
AND I WILL REMOVE THE AND DELETE
THE MOTION.
THE VERY FIRST ONE FOR.
PITCH TO.
.
BUT YOU YOU DID WANT TO SEPARATE
OUT THE.
PLUS OUR.
SO YOU'RE OK WITH THIS WHAT THE.
THE CAMPUS IS TO REPORT ON USES
OUTCOMES.
THIRD THE FOURTH BULLET DOWN YOU
STILL WANTED TO.
TAKE OUT CENTER NEAR YES THAT IS
CORRECT.
THE FIFTH BOOK I POTS OF IF
BULLARD ON THE SECOND PAGE THINK
FIRST ONE THEN YOU HAVE ALREADY
DELETE PERFECT THANK YOU.
SO COULD I GET A MOTION TO
APPROVE EVERYTHING BUT THE
BULLETS.
SORRY CETERA APPROACHES
SENATE.
TAKE A SECOND.
SEC PERFECTLY AND THAT IS TO
APPROVE.
ALL THE BULLETS THAT WERE NOT
PULLED OUT CENTER SKINNER.
THANK YOU CHAIR I JUST WANTED TO.
SPEAK TO THIS VERY BRIEFLY I'M
PLEASED THAT. I WISH THAT WE HAD
FUNDED.
THE ARE YOU SEE PACKED TO LEVEL
THE LEGISLATURE HAD HOPED FOR
BUT I AM VERY PLEASED THAT IT IS
HIGHER THAN THE PREVIOUS YEAR
AND I'M ALSO EXTREMELY PLEASED
THAT THERE'S TWENTY MILLION. FOR
IN THE WORLD MAKE GROWTH.
BECAUSE.
WE KNOW THAT THE DESIRE TO
ATTEND.
THE DESIRE BY CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS TO ATTEND OR UC SYSTEM
IS HIGHER THAN THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS WE CAN ADMIT SIZE VERY
VERY HAPPY TO SEE ME ENROLLMENT
GROWTH AND I WOULD JUST FINALLY.
POINT OUT. THAT THE SCHOOLS
ACCORDING TO A RECENT RESEARCH
REPORT. YOU SEE CALIFORNIA
SYSTEM DOES SIGNIFICANTLY BETTER
THAN OTHER FOUR YEAR COLLEGES
UNIVERSITIES AROUND THE COUNTRY
WHEN IT COMES TO ENROLLING LOW
INCOME STUDENTS. AND SEE THEM
ACROSS THE FINISH LINE IN OTHER
WORDS AT APT ACTUALLY ACHIEVING
DEGREES. SO I APPRECIATE OUR
ONGOING EFFORT TO PROPERLY FUND
ARE UC SYSTEM.
IF YOU SERVICE CENTER NIELSEN.
ON THIS PROJECT.
BUT MY VERY HAPPY TO SEE THE.
OPTED OF SOME ROMAN GROWTH.
AND PARTICULARLY IN VIEW OF THE
FACT THAT BOTH YOU AND CSU HAVE
BABY.
FOCUSED EFFORT TO INCREASE THE
CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS BEING PLACED THERE IT.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER BELOW.
I I DON'T WANT IT AND I JOIN MY
COLLEAGUES IN SUPPORTING THIS
ITEM BUT.
I AM DISAPPOINTED THAT THERE IS
NO ADDITIONAL ONGOING FUNDING.
FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
I THINK IT'S VIRTUALLY
IMPOSSIBLE FOR THAT UNIVERSITY
TO REALLY PLANET'S FUTURE
WITHOUT UNDERSTANDING WHAT IT'S
SO ONGOING FUNDING IS GOING TO
BE AND I. HOPE THAT WE TAKE
CORRECTIVE ACTION. ON A IN THAT
REGARD IN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU.
SIMILAR.
CLARIFICATION AT THE VERY TOP
THE FIRST PARAGRAPH ON PAGE
TWENTY NINE.
SAYS A PROPOSAL OF NINETY TWO
POINT ONE MILLION I'M GOING.
BUT I ONLY SEE FIVE MILLION ON
GOING IN THE FIRST BULLET. WHAT
AM I MISSING?
IF I MAY CLARIFY IT BUILDS UPON
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WHICH
DID INCLUDE SOME ONGOING FUNDING.
SO THAT WAS THE ORIGINAL
PROPOSAL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISCAST.
THANK YOU.
WITH THAT WE I WE HAVE A MOTION
SECOND WERE VOTING ON THE ALL
THE BULLETS THAT WERE NOT
ALREADY PULLED OUT.
WE A FIVE THOUGH IN THE ASSEMBLY
FIVE OH IN THE SENATE THANK YOU.
WE'RE GONNA HOLD A SEPARATE
VOTE ON THE FOUR BULLETS THAT
WERE PULLED OUT.
CONSECUTIVE THANK YOU FOR.
THREE THEM SELLING THREE TWO
THREE TWO THREE TWO THREE TWO
THANK YOU.
ISSUE THIRTEEN CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY PACKAGE.
WE SUPPORT THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE THIS PACKAGE REFLECT
THE MIX OF APPROX THE PROXIMALLY
ONE HUNDRED NINETY SEVEN POINT
ONE MILLION ON GOING GENERAL
FUND RESOURCES AND ONE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY ONE POINT SEVEN
MILLION GENERAL FUND ONE TIME.
SUPPORT SEE ISSUES OPERATIONAL
NEEDS AND ROLL ADDITIONAL
STUDENTS AND FURTHER EXPAND THE
EFFORTS OF THE GRADUATION
INITIATIVE. THE CONFERENCE
ACTION PROVIDES ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND AVAILABLE OVER A FOUR YEAR
PERIOD FOR THE C. ISSUED TO
PROVIDE AN ADDITIONAL THREE
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED AND FORTY
ONE UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS. WITH
ACCESS TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY. THESE FUNDS IN
COMBINATION WITH THE CONFERENCE
ACTION TO PROVIDE SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION ON GOING FOR THE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE. WILL.
BETTER ENABLE TRANSFER STUDENTS
AND FIRST TIME FRESHMEN TO
ACHIEVE THEIR EDUCATIONAL GOALS
WITHIN A TWO YEAR AND FOUR YEAR
PERIOD RESPECTIVELY.
THANK YOU MS COST.
COMMITTEE.
MISTER OBERNOLTE.
I DO HAVE A MOTION TO MOVE LOT
CANNOT MOVE THE ITEM YOU WOULD
LIKE.
OKAY WELL I DON'T GO GO AHEAD MR
WHEN I WAS GOING TO MOVE THE
ITEM WITH THE EXCEPTION OF. A
THREE BULLET POINTS THE SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME TO
LEGAL SERVICES FOR UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS STUDENTS.
THE REQUIREMENT THAT THE CSU
YOUR MARKET LEAST TWENTY FIVE
MILLION TO THE INCREASE.
OF TENURE TRACK FACULTY AND OF
THE ALLOWANCE FOR CSU TO
CONTRACT WITH ELIGIBLE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS.
TO PROVIDE LEGAL SERVICES TO
UNDOCUMENTED.
OKAY I'M LOOKING FOR THE LAST
FOUR WHIMS YEAH.
GARCETTI YEAH OFFICERS OVERSIGHT
FIRST AND SECOND THE SECOND PAGE.
AS WELL AS THE.
FIFTH BULLET DOWN ON THE FIRST
PAGE SO. THOSE THREES PROLIX ARE
PULLED OUT.
SO YOUR POINT THEM OUT AND YOU
WANNA MAKE IT YOU WANT TO VOTE
ON THOSE THREE ITEMS SEPARATELY
THE STUDENT ONE FIRST.
SO. WE GET A VOTE ON THOSE THREE
BULLETS THAT WERE PULLED OUT BY
MISTER OBERNOLTE.
THREE TWO THREE TWO.
OKAY CAN I GET A MOTION TO
APPROVE THE REMAINDER OF THE
FLOATS.
AND CUT.
WE A FIVE OH FIVE THANK YOU.
ISSUE FOURTEEN HASTINGS COLLEGE
OF LAW DIVERSITY PIPELINES CROSS
YES WE SUPPORT THE CONFERENCE
ACTION. THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE FOR UC HASTINGS
PROVIDES FOUR POINT FIVE MILLION
GENERAL FUND ONE TIME TO FUND
SCHOLARSHIPS FOR STUDENTS FROM
THE AMERICAN UNIVERSITY IN
ARMENIA AND THE HISTORICALLY
BLACK COLLEGES AND UNIVERSI
UNIVERSITIES TO ATTEND UC
HASTINGS.
OKAY.
THREE TWO ON THE ASSEMBLY FIVE
ON THE SENATE THANK YOU.
ISSUE FIFTEEN CALIFORNIA
EDUCATION LEARNING LAB.
THANK YOU WITH SUPPORT THE
CONFERENCE ACTION THE CONFERENCE
PACKAGE FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH
PROVIDES A TEN MILLION DOLLAR
GENERAL FUND ON GOING TO THE
CALIFORNIA EDUCATIONAL LEARNING
LAB.
THE FOCUS OF THIS INITIATIVE
WILL BE TO DEVELOP A REDESIGN
ONLINE AND HYBRID LOWER DIVISION
STEM COURSES TO SPECIFICALLY
EMIGRATE ADOPTIVE LEARNING
STRATEGIES AND THE PRINCIPLES OF
LEARNING SCIENCE INTO THE
CURRICULUM.
THANK YOU.
SEVERAL.
MAYBE A CLERK
WIENER.
HELP FOR OTHER ITEMS AS WE GO.
THIS IS NOT.
THIS IS A NOT IN CONFERENCE
ISSUE.
SO MAYBE THAT TERM COULD BE
EXPLAINED.
I BELIEVE THIS ISSUE WAS NOT
ORIGINALLY IN CONFERENCE AND
BECAUSE I BELIEVED THAT IT WAS A
DOES THAT MEAN IF WE DIDN'T DO
IT AND AND THE SUBCOMMITTEES OR
THAT IT WASN'T IN THERE DO YOU
MAYBE. I LOOK AT YOU KNOW SOCKS
AND I TORE.
AS OUR OWN MIGHT DISSOLVES
SAYING THEY PREVIOUSLY BOTH.
HOUSES HAD A REJECTED IT THAT
HIS COMEBACK ISSUES COME BACK.
THANK YOU SO WASN'T CONFERENCE
BECAUSE NEITHER HOUSE PUTTING
CONFERENCE
SO IT'S IT'S COME OUT AS A
RESULT OF THE. BIG THREE
DISCUSSION AB OR THE SPECIFICS.
OF.
MISTER CHAIRMAN ANY MEMBER
CONVICTED REQUESTED A NOT A
CONFERENCE INTRODUCTION.
CORRECT THANK YOU I CONSIDER
NIELSEN.
GREAT WHO WE ARE WE HAVE.
I BELIEVE WE HAD A MOTION IS
SECONDS ARE CORRECT.
YES.
TO HAVE A VOTE ON ISSUE FIFTEEN.
THREE TWO ON THREE TWO.
FOR ONE ON THE SENATE FOR ONE OF
THE SENATE.
THREE TWO. IN THE ASSEMBLY THANK
YOU.
ISSUE SIXTEEN CALIFORNIA STATE
LIBRARY AUGMENTATION.
WE SUPPORT THE CONFERENCE
VERSION.
THIS ACTION COMBINED WITH
AUGMENTATIONS INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROVIDES FOUR
POINT THREE MILLION ON GOING IN
ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTEEN MILLION ONE TIME TO
IMPROVE INTERNET ACCESS TO
LIBRARY PACKED PATRONS PROTECT
THE STATE'S HISTORY. ENABLE
LIBRARIES TO DEVELOP FREE SUMMER
MEAL PROGRAMS SUPPORT LITERACY
AND LEARNING EFFORTS AND EXPAND
ACCESS TO INFORMATION FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
TAKING THIS COST.
SIMILAR.
I JUST WANT TO.
PULL OUT THE THE.
SECOND LAST BULLET.
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
ELIMINATING THE SUNSET.
OKAY.
THE TRILLING I LANGUAGE RIGHT TO
SUNSET PROVISION OF LAW
REQUIRING CITY SEEKING TO
CONTRACT FOR LABOR SERVICES.
WITH A FOR PROFIT COMPANY TO
CONDUCT A PUBLIC NOTICE A
COMPETITIVE BIDDING PROCESS.
I.
THANK YOU SO WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
A VOTE FIRST ON THE REMAINING
BULLETS.
FELLOW.
RIGHT SO WE HAVE OUT WE HAD A
FIRST AID YOUR SECOND SO.
FIVE OH ON THE SENATE BIBLE ON
THE ASSEMBLY.
AND WE WILL TAKE A VOTE I GET A
MOTION TO APPROVE THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE BOOK.
SECOND.
TO TAKE A VOTE ON THAT.
THREE TWO THREE TWO THANK YOU.
ISSUE SEVENTEEN CALIFORNIA
STUDENT COMMISSION.
WE SUPPORT THE CONFERENCE ACTION
WHICH IMPROVES FIVE POINT TWO
MILLION ONGOING GENERAL FUND TO
EXPAND THE CAL GRANT ELIGIBILITY
TO FOSTER USE UP TO AGE TWENTY
SIX INCLUDES EIGHT YEARS OF
RENEWAL ELIGIBILITY. THESE FUNDS
WILL FURTHER SUPPORT FOSTER
YOUTH IN ACHIEVING THEIR
EDUCATIONAL GOALS.
THANK YOU.
SENATE BLOCKS I LIKE TO.
REMOVED
THE THIRD BULLET.
YOU'D LIKE TO REMOVE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FIRST OF MAX
AND CAL GRANT FOR STUDENTS
ATTENDING A CREDIT FOR PROFIT
INSTITUTIONS PLEASE.
OKAY WE'VE VOTE A ON THE FIRST
TWO BULLETS.
OKAY THE TARGET I HAD YOU HAD A
MOTION A SECOND YEAH. AND A
SECOND.
OKAY AND WE HAVE.
FIVE OH ASIDE A FIVE OH IN THE
SENATE FOUR ONE WITH MR
OBERNOLTE NO IN THE ASSEMBLY.
I'D LIKE TO GET A MOTION TO
APPROVE THE THIRD BULLET
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET VERSION OF
FACTS AND CAL GRANT.
OKAY.
VOTE WE HAVE. THREE TWO IN THE
SENATE.
THREE TWO IN THE SENATE THANK
YOU.
SO WE HAVE TO.
TO WHERE WE.
WE'RE ON THE BULLET FOR
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET VERSION OF
MAXIMUM. CAL GRANTS LIVE.
NOT BECAUSE.
THE CITY OF.
I HAPPEN.
OKAY IN THE SENATE YOU HAVE TWO
EYES TO NOSE WARRANT ABSTENTION.
IN THE ASSEMBLY WE HAD THREE.
AND TO.
WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THIS ITEM
OPEN FOR NOW.
ISSUE EIGHTEEN ONLINE COLLEGE.
CALIFORNIA COMMUNICABLE THE
MINISTRATIONS SUPPORTS THE
CONFERENCE COMPROMISE WHICH
APPROVES ONE MILLION ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME
AND TWO HUNDRED MILLION ON GOING
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND TO ESTABLISH AN ONLINE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE REFLECT THE TIMELINE FOR
SEEKING ACCREDITATION. ADVISORY
COUNCIL PROCESS AND CLARIFYING
VARIOUS PROVISIONS.
ADDITIONALLY THE CONFERENCE
ACTION PROVIDES THIRTY FIVE
MILLION ONE TIME PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND TO THE
ONLINE EDUCATION INITIATIVE FOR
GRANTS TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS TO. DEVELOP ONLINE
CONTENT.
THINK IT WAS COSTA.
TATUM.
MOTION TO APPROVE THE COMPROMISE.
I GUESS SECOND.
SECOND OKAY.
GO GET A VOTE WE HAVE.
FOUR ZERO WITH MR CONLEY OF
STANDING ON THE ASSEMBLY AND WE
HAVE FOUR ONE IN THE SENATE WITH.
BUT WE HAVE THREE ONE I'M SORRY
WE HAVE THREE ONE WITH SENATOR
SKINNER ABSTAINING AND SENATOR
MORE LOCK.
VOTING NO.
ISSUE NINETEEN COMMUNICATE WHICH
FUNDING FORMULA.
WE SUPPORT THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE.
FOR THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FUNDING FORMULA WHICH REFLECTS
AN INCREASE OF APPROXIMATELY
THREE HUNDRED SEVENTY EIGHT
MILLION PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND IN EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN THE COMPROMISE INCLUDES
A THREE YEAR PHASE AND OF A NEW
STUDENT CENTERED FUNDING FORMULA.
DURING THE FIRST YEAR SEVENTY
PERCENT A FUNDING WOULD BE
DISTRIBUTED BASED UPON
ENROLLMENT. TWENTY PERCENT ARE
BASED UPON ENROLLMENT OF LOW
INCOME STUDENTS AND TEN PERCENT
BASED ON STUDENT SUCCESS METRICS.
OVER A THREE YEAR PERIOD THE
FORMULA WOULD SHIFT O SIXTY
PERCENT BASED ON ENROLLMENT
TWENTY PERCENT BASED ON A WOMAN
OF LOW INCOME STUDENTS AND
TWENTY PERCENT BASED ON STUDENTS
IS.
ACCESS METRICS
THE CONFERENCE COPPER MINES ALSO
INCLUDES A HOLD HARMLESS
PROVISION THAT INSURERS ALL
RECEIVE AT A MINIMUM. A COST OF
LIVING INCREASE FOR THREE YEARS
ADDITIONALLY THE ADVISORY ENTITY
WILL BE CREATED TO MONITOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE FUNDING
FORMULA AND REPORT BACK. TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMISSION AND
ADMINISTRATION ON POTENTIAL
IMPROVEMENTS.
THANK YOU MISS COSTA.
.
LIMON.
OKAY A WORD DARBY OF A MOTION A
SECOND TO APPROVE THE COMPROMISE
ON ISSUE NINETEEN. WE HAVE FIVE
ZERO FIVE ZERO THANK YOU.
ISSUE TWENTY COMMUNICABLE IT'S
AUGMENTATIONS.
THANK YOU WE SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL THE
CONFERENCE COMPROMISED THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE PROVIDE FORTY NINE
POINT NINE MILLION A PROP.
FIFTY ONE GENERAL OBLIGATION
BONDS FOR FIFTEEN CONTINUING AND
SIX NEW CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS
FOR THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
THE SIXTY PROJECTS ALIGNED WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION STATEWIDE
POLICY OF ADDRESS ADDRESSING
CRITICAL FIRE LIFE AND SAFETY
ISSUES AND EITHER HAVING A LOCAL
MATCH OR A SUFFICIENT
JUSTIFICATION AS TO WHY A LOCAL
MATCH IS NOT POSSIBLE.
OKAY THINKING THIS COST.
SENATOR MORLOCK.
COMMISSION CHAIR LIKE TO PULL
OUT.
THE FIRST TWO ITEMS.
YES AND I LIKE PEOPLE AND ON THE
SECOND PAGE NOT TO PULL OUT THE
INCREASE FULL TIME FACULTY IN
THE INCREASE PART TIME FACULTY
IS THAT CORRECT CORRECTIONAL
BECAUSE.
AND THEN THE.
FIFTH ITEM ON PAGE TWO OF THE
LEGAL SERVICES
OKAY THE LEGAL SERVICES SO. I'LL.
YOU ARE MOVING TO POLL THOSE
THREE ITEMS OUT AND MOVED EUROPE.
AND YOUR MOVING TO APPROVE THE
REMAINDER IS THAT. CORRECT THANK
YOU SO CAN WE VOTE ON THE
REMAINDER NOT THE THREE ITEMS
THAT WERE PULLED OUT.
FOUR ZERO WITH MISTER COUNTY OF
STAVING FIVE HOW ON THE SENATE
THANK YOU.
CAN GET A MOTION TO APPROVE THE
THREE BULLETS ARE PULLED OUT.
THANK YOU CAN WE VOTE ON THE
THREE. THEY'LL PULL DOWN THREE
TWO IN THE ASSEMBLY.
THREE TWO IN THE SENATE THANK
YOU.
ISSUE TWENTY ONE HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE EXPANSION AFFORDABLE.
THANK YOU WE SUPPORT THE
CONFERENCE COMPROMISE WHICH
INCLUDES.
XTO IN ONE TIME GENERAL FUND AND
A TRAILER BILL TO IMPLEMENT AN
ALL PAYERS CLAIMS DATABASE.
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND ONE TIME TO ESTABLISH A
TASK FORCE AND TRAILER BILL
ESTABLISHING INTENT TO
ACCOMPLISH UNIVERSAL COVERAGE
AND A UNIFIED.
PUBLICLY FINANCED HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM.
THEY CAN DISCUSS TO.
SENATE NIELSEN.
AND THREE TWO AND THREE SO
APPROVING THE FIVE MILLION
GENERAL FUND ONE TIME.
THAT WOULD BE THE PATHWAY TO
UNIVERSAL COVERAGE RIGHT AND
THEN NUMBER TWO THE MORE THREE
WAS APPROVED TRAILER BILL
CONNECTION WITH TASK FORCE
ACTION ABOVE CORRECT SUBSIDIES
YES OKAY SO. I. IF I GET AMEND
YOUR MOTION YOU'RE GONNA MOVE
THE REMAINING BULLETS.
IS THAT OKAY.
SECOND I GOT A FIRST OR SECOND.
SO.
FIVE ZERO.
FIVE ZERO IN THE SENATE THREE
TWO IN THE ASSEMBLY ON THE. OF
BULLETS THAT WERE NOT PULLED OUT.
SO CAN I GET A MOTION TO APPROVE
THE TWO BULLETS THAT WERE PROVED.
OKAY
AND WE HAVE A VOTE THREE TWO IN
THE SENATE.
THREE TWO IN THE ASSEMBLY.
ISSUE TWENTY TWO HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE.
THANK YOU WE SUPPORT THE
CONFERENCE COMPROMISE WHICH
ENDING WOULD INCLUDE FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND ONE
TIME FOR GRADUATE MEDICAL
EDUCATION WITHIN THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA.
IT WOULD INCLUDE FIFTEEN MILLION
GENERAL FUND ONE TIME AND BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE FOR PSYCHIATRIC
GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION
UTILIZING PSYCHIATRIC
TELEMEDICINE WITHIN THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
AND IT WOULD INCLUDE TEN MILLION
ONE TIME PROP SIXTY THREE STAY
ADMIN FUND AND BUDGET THE
LANGUAGE FOR THE WEB PROGRAM.
THANK YOU MISS COSTA.
WE HAVE A SECOND FIRST A SECOND
MY MOTION A SECOND TO APPROVE
THE COMPROMISE.
WE HAVE A FOUR ZERO WITH MISTER
KILEY ABSTAINING IN THE ASSEMBLY
FIVE ZERO IN THE SENATE THANK
YOU.
ISSUE TWENTY THREE YEAR PROVIDER
RATES IMPROPER FIFTY SIX FUNDS
IN MEDI CAL I DO HAVE A.
THE AN AMENDMENT TO THE AGENDA
ITEM SO ON THE FIRST BULLET
INSTEAD OF APPROVE OF PLACING.
OF ONE BILLION TWENTY ONE
BILLION TWENTY TWO MILLION POINT
THREE.
.
NO.
OKAY UP WE ARE GOING TO AMEND A
NUMBER TO EIGHT HUNDRED AND
TWENTY TWO POINT THREE MILLION.
SO JUST PLEASE MAKE A NOTE A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO POINT
THREE. MILLION OKAY.
I MISS COST.
THANK YOU WE SUPPORT THAT ACTION
AND THAT DOLLAR AMOUNT OF EIGHT
HUNDRED TWENTY TWO POINT THREE
BILLION AND PROPOSITION FIFTY
SIX FUNDING. WE PLACE INTO A NON
BUDGET ITEM TO BE APPROPRIATE.
TWO POINT THREE MILLION.
MILLION PARDON ME TO BE
APPROPRIATED WE STARTED A
BILLION WHERE THE MILLION. TO BE
APPROPRIATED THROUGH A.
FUTURE BILL I'M IN SHORT ORDER.
JOINT.
CAN I ASK.
THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF PROP FIFTY
SIX FUNDING THAT WE'RE BUDGETING
FOR NEXT YEAR THEM.
ANOTHER WAS WHAT PERCENTAGE OF
THE TOTAL IS THAT EIGHT HUNDRED
TENTY TWO MILLION.
I THINK.
ADAM DORSEY DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
SO IN THE DEPARTMENT HEALTHCARE
SERVICES THEIR ALLOCATIONS SO
WE'RE REALLY FOCUSED ON THAT THE
HEALTH CARE SERVICES PORTION OF
THE ALLOCATION.
THEY HAVE ONE BILLION TO LEARN
FORTY SIX POINT NINE MILLION IN
THE BUDGET YEAR.
SO I MEAN THIS IS A ONE ITEM
THAT WE'VE HAD INTENSE DEBATE
ABOUT IN PREVIOUS BUDGETARY
CYCLES. BECAUSE ONE PROP FIFTY
SIX WAS PASSED IT WAS DONE SO
WITH AN EXPRESS PROVISION BY THE
VOTERS THAT IT BE USED TO EXPAND
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE AND SO
THERE BUT A NUMBER OF US. ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE THAT
EXTRA EXPRESSED CONCERN. WHEN
WE'RE USING SOME OF THOSE PROFIT
TO SIX DOLLARS TO SUPPLANT
GENERAL FUND SPENDING BECAUSE WE
DON'T THINK THAT THAT WAS THE
INTENT OF THE VOTERS WHEN THEY
VOTED ON. THAT.
THAT ADDITIONAL CIGARETTE TAX
SO I'M CONCERNED THAT IN
LOWERING THE AMOUNT. A HERE IN
COMMITTEE THAT WE ARE ALL GOING
BACK TO.
TO THE BAD OLD DAYS WHEN WE ARE
ARE PUTTING THAT MONEY IN THE
GENERAL FUND INSTEAD OF SPENDING
IT ON EXPANSION HEALTH CARE. AND
I WILL ALSO POINT OUT THAT. THEY
WERE GONNA KICKING THE CAN DOWN
THE ROAD HERE BECAUSE THE HARD
WORK OF ALLOCATING THOSE THAT
MONEY. YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT SHOULD
BE DONE THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS WE ARE WE'RE JUST SAYING
WE'RE GOING TO DO IT LATER WHICH
IN AUDIT. MYSTIFIES ME BECAUSE I
THOUGHT THAT THAT WAS GOING TO
BE A PART OF THE GIVE AND TAKE.
SO THIS IS JUST TO CLARIFY THE
AMENDMENT ON WITH THE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION REDUCTION. WE
WILL BE THERE'S ANOTHER
AMENDMENT ON ISSUE THIRTY TO THE
SAFETY NET RESERVE. OF ADDING
TWO HUNDRED MILLION TO THE
RESERVE FOR MEDI CAL.
SO WITH THE AROUND ONE POINT OH
TO TWO POINT THREE BILLION.
ON ONE OR TWO TWO POINT THREE
BILLION.
IS ALL STILL FOR MEDI CAL
WITHIN THIS CONSTRUCTION IS JUST
TWO HUNDRED IS GOING INTO IT
RESERVE.
UP ALL THANK YOU FOR THE
CLARIFICATION MISTER CHAIRMAN
LET ME ALSO POINT OUT. THAT THE
INTENT OF THE VOTERS WHEN THEY
IMPOSE THAT TAX WAS NOT TO HAVE
IT FUND RESERVES FOR MEDI CAL
WAS HAVE IT TO HAVE IT EXPAND
ACCESS TO MEDICAL. AND I'M NOT
SURE THAT THAT THAT PARTICULAR
ALLOCATION SUPPORTS THAT GOAL.
THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A MOTION TO MOTION A
SECOND TO APPROVE. I ISSUE
TWENTY THREE OF MISTER CHAIR
WOULD YOU.
CAN WE JUST TELL TAKE SEPARATE
VOTES ON THESE TWO ITEMS PLOTS
ARE WOULD JUST CAN WE JUST.
THE US PUT OUT THE PEDIATRIC
DAYCARE HEALTH CENTER.
YEAH ALL ALL ALL CAN I MOVE JUST
THAT ONE ITEM THE PEDIATRIC. DAY
HEALTH CENTERS SUCH AS TEN POINT
EIGHT MILLION IN.
PEDIATRIC DAY CARE IF THEY
HEALTH CARE SERVICES ARE CRAP
THAT'S CORRECT OKAY SO THAT SO
JUST THE VERY. LAST ITEM IN THE
SECOND BULLET WHICH IS TEN POINT
EIGHT MILLION.
THAT WAS CHARM TARGETS A WHOLE
SECOND WHAT.
YES OR THE WHOLE SECOND BULLET
HOLE SECOND BLOW THAT I
APOLOGIZE PAPA APPROVED BUDGET
BILL AND EIGHT POINT NINE
MILLION EXCEPT.
THAT ITEMS NOW MOVED UP.
SO WE WILL AMEND THE MOTION TO
APPROVE EVERYTHING BUT THAT ONE
BULLET.
OKAY.
WE HAVE.
FIVE ALL IN THE SENATE.
I'M SORRY THREE.
FOUR ONE IN THE SENATE WITH A
CENTER NIELSEN DANNO IN THREE
TWO IN THE ASSEMBLY.
I'M SORRY.
NO WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING ELSE.
SORRY THREE TO.
THREE TWO THREE TWO.
THREE TWO THREE TWO NOW WE CAN'T
GET A MOTION TO APPROVE THE
SECOND PAUL.
SO THE.
SO FIVE OH IN THE ASSEMBLY.
SENATE NIELSEN.
FIVE LOWERING THEIR SENATE THANK
YOU.
ISSUE TWENTY THREE. ISSUED
TWENTY FOUR HEALTH CARE OF
LEGISLATIVE AUGMENTATIONS.
THIS ITEM CARRIES VARIOUS
AUGMENTATIONS MADE TO THE MEDI
CAL PROGRAM INTO NON MEDI CAL
HEALTH CARE PROGRAMS.
WE SUPPORT THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISED INCLUDES APPROVING
TWO MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
ONE TIME FOR A WHOLE GENOME
SEQUENCING PILOT PROGRAM. AND
ONE MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
ONE TIME FOR PEDIATRIC MOBILE
OPTOMETRY SERVICES.
THANK YOU.
MR WOULDN'T.
MISTER CHAIR I'D LIKE TO MOVE
THE ASSEMBLY VERSION.
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO MOVE THE
ASSEMBLY VERSION.
OTHER WORDS I DON'T LIKE THE
COMPROMISE UNLIKELY ASSEMBLY
VERSION.
OKAY WE WILL TAKE A VOTE ON THE
ASSEMBLY VERSION.
FIRST.
WE'RE VOTING ON THE ASSEMBLY
VERSION.
WE HAVE.
.
IN THE ASSEMBLY TO A VOTE OF TWO
THREE.
WE DO NOT HAVE IN FRONT OF YOU
WE WILL HAVE IT IN YOUR PREVIOUS
DOCUMENTS.
TWO THREE. AND WE HAVE ONE.
WITH THREE KNOWS AND ONE
ABSTENTION IN THE SENATE WITH US
ANYMORE LIKE TO.
OKAY WE'RE MOVING COMPROMISE.
SECOND.
TO MOVE THE GOVERNMENT OKAY WE
NOW WE HAVE FOUR.
IT WITH AN EXTENSION ON THE.
ASSEMBLY.
AND WE HAVE FIVE OH THANK YOU.
ON ISSUE TWENTY FOUR.
THANK YOU.
I ISSUE TWENTY FIVE HEALTH CARE
NO COST LEGISLATIVE ACTIONS.
MR WANTED.
BOB MISTER CHAIRMAN I JUST LIKE
TO POINT UP PURSUANT TO THE
COMMENTS THAT I MADE AT THE
BEGINNING THIS IS ONE OF. THE
INSTANCES WHERE WE ARE DON'T
HAVE.
IMPRINT THE VERSION THE
LANGUAGE FOR MOST OF THESE
TRAILER BILLS THAT REFERRED HERE
SO THAT'S WHY IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT FOR SOME OF US STOOD
TO MAKE A VOTE ON THIS.
FAIR ENOUGH THINKING.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
TO APPROVE.
THE CONFERENCE COMPROMISE.
THREE ZERO BUT TO EXTENSIONS AND
THREE.
ZERO.
STEP THREE ZERO THREE ZERO.
WITH TWO ABSTENTIONS ON EITHER
SIDE THANK YOU.
ISSUE TWENTY SIX PUBLIC HEALTH
LEGISLATIVE AUGMENTATIONS.
THIS ITEM INCLUDES VARIOUS
AUGMENTATIONS TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH AS WELL AS THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
INCLUDES EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND ONGOING TRAILER
BILL AND BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE TO
EXPAND THE BLACK INFANT HEALTH
PROGRAM. INCLUDES FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND ONE TIME
ANDBUDGET BILL LANGUAGE FOR HIV
AIDS PREVENTION. INCLUDES TWO
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND ONE
TIME AND BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
FOR S. T. D. PREVENTION. AND
INCLUDES EIGHT MILLION GENERAL
FUND ONE TIME FOR VALLEY FEVER
OUTREACH AND RESEARCH AS FOLLOWS.
TWO MILLION FOR OUTREACH
AWARENESS AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH HEALTH THREE
MILLION FOR RESEARCH THE VALLEY
FEVER INSTITUTE AT KERN MEDICAL
AND THREE MILLION FOR RESEARCH
DIRECTLY TO THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU SIR NIELSEN.
SENATOR NIELSEN.
SO YOU'RE MOVING ITEMS ONE. THE
LS SYSTEM OF CARE
.
ALPHAWORKS.
BUT WOULD BE.
BULLETS.
SEVEN ALL CHILDREN THRIVE EIGHT
BORDER HEALTH TEN LA COUNTY.
THEN THEN I WOULD MOVE THE REST
OF THEM FOR AND I.
OKAY I APOLOGIZED TO SARAH
CENTER NIELSEN SEE YOU ARE.
ASKING.
TO REMOVE.
BULLET SHERMAN ALL CHILDREN
THRIVE EIGHT BORDER HEALTH TEN
LA COUNTY OFFICIALS I.
OKAY I THINK TO BE EASIER IF
IT'S OKAY LET ME CUT JUST TAKE.
A MOTION AND A SECOND TO APPROVE
EVERY BULLET AND WE'LL JUST HAVE
INDIVIDUAL VOTES ONE BY ONE VERY
QUICKLY IF THAT'S OKAY. I THINK
IT'LL BE EASIER TO DO.
SO CAN I GET A MOTION.
NO NO.
HOW HOW DO YOU GET A VOTE ON THE
WHOLE LIST YEAH I DON'T KNOW
WHAT WE'RE GONNA GO ONE BY ONE
GOING TO VOTE INDIVIDUAL BULLETS
ONE BY ONE OKAY?
SO MOVED TO ELICIT THROUGH FEAR.
THE ONE. THING GIVEN THAT MOTION
FRAIL MATHIS MCCARTY TO
SUBSTITUTE THAT MOTION AND
SECOND FOR EACH OF THE BULLETS
AT THAT TICKET OF SILICON.
SO THEY'LL S.
SO THE FIRST ITEM IS APPROVED
NINE MILLION HAIL LASTEST MATURE.
FIVE
FIVE OH IN THE SENATE A SORCERER
NIELSEN EARLIER.
THREE ZERO IN THE SEATS IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
OKAY EIGHT MILLION GENERAL FUND
ONGOING TRAILER BILL.
FOR BLACK INTO HEALTH PROGRAM.
FIVE OH.
THREE ZERO IN THE ASSEMBLY.
FIVE MILLION HIV AIDS.
THREE ZERO IN THE ASSEMBLY FIVE
OH IN THE SENATE.
TO THE HAVE.
MILLION GENERAL FUND DIABETES
ARE RICH.
THREE ZERO IN THE ASSEMBLY FIVE
ON THE SENATE.
THREE ZERO IN THE REPLY AND IN
THE ASSEMBLY FIVE ON THE SENATE.
I EIGHT MILLION FOR THE VALLEY
FEVER.
FIVE OO FIVE OO THANK YOU. A TEN
MILLION FOR ALL CHILDREN THRIVE.
THREE TWO IN THE SENATE.
THREE ZERO IN THE ASSEMBLY THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND FOUR BACK
FEELING THE LOSS OF FEDERAL
FUNDS REPORTER HEALTH EFFORTS.
THREE TWO.
UP FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND FOR UC
DAVIS THE CAL SERVE MOSQUITO.
SURVEILLANCE FIVE I'LL.
FIVE OTHER THANK YOU SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND FOUR I LA
COUNTY.
THREE.
ZERO IN THE ASSEMBLY THREE TWO
IN THE SENATE.
AND THE REMAINING.
BULLET APPROVING THE MAY
REVISION THE LAST BULLET ON THE
SECOND PAGE FOR SPLIT SECOND
BRIDGE.
FIVE OUT.
THREE ZERO IN THE ASSEMBLY FIVE
ON THE SENATE THANK YOU.
ISSUE TWENTY SEVEN.
PUBLIC HEALTH NO COST.
THESE ISSUES CARRY VARIOUS NO
COST HEALTH PUBLIC HEALTH
PROPOSALS INCLUDES A PLACEHOLDER
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT LANGUAGE TO
REQUEST THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH TO PROVIDE PUBLIC HEALTH
DATA. TO THE LEGISLATURE NO
LATER THAN THE START OF BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARINGS AND TWENTY
NINETEEN.
THANK YOU.
SEVERAL.
HOW MOVED BULLET NUMBER TWO AND
BULLET NUMBER FOUR?
APPROVED PLACEHOLDER
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT LANGUAGE AND
DENY TRAILER BILL TO AUTHORIZE
HOSPITAL EMPLOYEES GRAY COULD
GET A SECOND. GRADE SO THIS IS
TO.
APPROVED BULLET NUMBER TWO
AMPLE NUMBER FOUR. OTHER
PLACEHOLDER SUBMIT A REPORT
LANGUAGE TO REPRESS DEPARTMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH EXETER. AND THE
DENIED TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO
AUTHORIZE HOSPITAL EMPLOYEES
SO WE HAVE.
FIVE OH FIVE I THINK YOU COULD
GET A MOTION.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. REGULAR VOTE.
THREE TWO IN THE SENATE.
THREE A THREE ONE AND ZERO THREE
ONE ON ONE WITH THAT MR COVERAGE
TO.
ISSUE TWENTY EIGHT MENTAL HEALTH
LEGISLATIVE AUGMENTATIONS.
THIS ITEM CARRIES THAT COVERS
EXCUSE ME VARIOUS MENTAL HEALTH
PROPOSALS AN AUGMENTATION.
IT INCLUDES MODIFY TRAILER BILL
TO ESTABLISH AN INCOMPETENT TO
STAND TRIAL MENTAL HEALTH DAY
VERSION PROGRAMS THAT REQUIRES
APPROVAL OF COUNTY PLANS BY BOTH
THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE
HOSPITALS AND THE COUNCIL ON
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH.
PROVIDES ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN PROP SIXTY
THREE STATE OUT MEN PER YEAR FOR
THREE YEARS AND ONE POSITION
THAT TO THE COUNCIL.
IT ALSO PROVIDES A PROP SIXTY
THREE STATE ADMINISTRATIVE FUND
CAP PACKAGE THAT INCLUDES FOUR
POINT THREE MILLION ONGOING. FOR
SUICIDE HOTLINES ONE MILLION
DOLLARS ON GOING FOR THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS AFFAIRS
TO SUPPORT MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FOR VETERANS.
TEN MILLION ONE TIME FOR THE WEB
PROGRAM TEN MILLION ONE TIME
OVER THREE YEARS AND BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO IMPLEMENT
THE ALL CHILDREN DRIVE PROGRAM.
THANK YOU SEVERAL.
CHAIR CAN WE DO WILL YOU DID.
A LITTLE WHILE AGO AND AND WE
JUST VOTE FOR EACH BULLET OKAY
CUKAI GET A MOTION TO APPROVE
THE FIRST BULLET FELLOW.
OKAY
AS CHAIRMAN.
YES SIR NIELSEN.
LIKE TO MAKE AN OBSERVATION
THOUGH THAT THIS IS A.
INCOMPETENCE STAND TRIAL.
MENTAL HEALTH DIVERSION PROGRAM.
AND.
I WOULD JUST OBSERVE THAT THIS
IS.
FAR MORE COMPLICATED AND MAJOR
POLICY ISSUE THAN TO JUST SO
SUMMARILY CONSIDER.
YOU AND PART YOU'RE DEALING
WITH CRIMINAL OFFENDERS WHO HAVE
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
AND THERE MANY STATUTES TO
RELATE TO THIS INCLUDING MENTAL
DISORDER DEFENDERS CIVIL
COMMITMENT.
IT CAN GET EVEN INCLUDE SECTOR
VIOLENT PREDATOR CIVIL
COMMITMENT.
AND VARIOUS BEHAVIORS THAT CAN
BE REQUIRED AS CONDITIONS OF
PAROLE SO.
AND MY ARGUMENT IS.
THE CAUTIOUS ON THIS PARTICULAR
ONE BECAUSE IT HAS SOME BIG
DOWNSIDES AND.
AT THE HEAD DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT IT
RIGHTLY SO.
WE DON'T KNW EXACTLY WHAT THIS
LANGUAGE IS GONNA SAY AND THE
WAY THINGS HAVE BEEN GOING
AROUND HERE FOR QUITE AWHILE
LATELY IN THIS AREA I DON'T HAVE
ANY TRUST SO. I JUST WOULD
BLACKS.
QUESTION ON THAT PARTICULAR ITEM.
THANK YOU CENTER.
THE CASING OTHER COMMENTS WHERE
IT'S GONNA GO TO THE FIRST
BULLET APPROVED MODIFY TRAILER
BILL.
WE HAVE. SOME MOVED WE WE HAVE
FAR.
THREE.
ONE AND ONE SO WITHOUT CENTER
MORE LIKE ABSTAINING IN THE
SENATE.
THEN WE HAVE THREE ONE ON ONE
WITH MR KILEY ABSTAINING IN THE
ASSEMBLY. ARMY COLLEAGUE A
NUMBER OF STEPS TO DRAW MOTIONS
WERE GONNA VOTE ON FOUR POINT
THREE MILLION ONGOING. D. H. CS
FOR SUICIDAL.
SO WE'RE JUST GONNA SUCH TO THE
MOTION FOR ALL THE WILL GET IT
DONE INDIVIDUALLY FIVE OO.
FOR.
OR FIVE I'M SORRY FIVE OH FIVE
UP THANK YOU.
A ONE MILLION VETERANS AFFAIRS.
FIVE OF TITLE.
SIX HUNDRED SEVENTY THOUSAND
ONGOING COMPETE TO THE
COMMISSION TO ESTABLISH CUSTOMER
CONTACT.
IN THE ASSEMBLY IS THREE ONE ONE
WITH MISTER KILEY ABSTAINING AND
THREE TWO IN THE SENATE.
I WE GOT THE SEVEN HUNDRED
NINETY FIVE THOUSAND FOR COUNCIL
ON CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
WE HAVE FOUR ONE WITH MISTER
NIELSEN CENTER NIELSEN NO.
AND IN THE ASSEMBLY WE HAVE
THREE ZERO.
A TEN MILLION FOR THE WHAT
PROGRAMS.
WE FIVE OH IN THE SENATE
THREE ZERO IN THE ASSEMBLY. AYE
WE ALREADY APPROVED THE.
ALL CHILDREN THRIVE ó ONE
MILLION ON THE PRIMARY CARE
MENTAL HEALTH.
THE MACHINE
YES.
THE OTHER TEN MILLION FOR THE
ULTIMATE RIGHT WE HAD JUST TAKEN
ACTION ON THAT OTHER BULLET.
OKAY THE PRIMARY CARE MENTAL
HEALTH FELLOWSHIPS.
A THREE ONE.
SITE FOR.
AND ZERO IN THE ASSEMBLY WITH
MISTER KILEY ABSTAINING AND FIVE
OO IN THE SENATE THANK YOU.
WE HAVE WE APPROPRIATE TWENTY
MILLION TO SB EIGHTY TWO.
FIVE ALL IN THE SENATE.
THREE ZERO IN THE ASSEMBLY.
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND TO THE
COUNCIL CRIMINAL JUSTICE.
THREE ZERO IN THE SENATE.
FOUR ONE SORT FOUR ZERO IN THE
ASSEMBLY WITH MISTER KILEY OF
STANDING.
AND THEN APPROVING THE MAY
REVISION.
FIVE OH.
THREE TWO IN THE SENATE FIVE ON
THE ASSEMBLY THANK YOU.
AS OUR.
FOR ZERO WITH MISTER KILEY
ABSTAINING. THANK YOU.
ISSUED TWENTY NINE SSI CALSHOT
REVERSAL.
WE SUPPORT THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE TO PROVIDE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND TO AND THE SS I CASH OUT
EFFECTIVE JUNE OF TWENTY
NINETEEN. WHICH ALLOWS SSI
RECIPIENTS TO RECEIVE CAL FRESH
BENEFITS
IN ADDITION THIS PROPOSAL HOLD
HARMLESS CURRENT CAL FRESH
HOUSEHOLDS THAT LOSE BENEFITS OR
BECOME INELIGIBLE. DUE TO ENDING
THE CASH OUT POLICY.
THANK YOU BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
MOTION I'LL MOVE IT MOVE THANK
YOU AND I'M.
TO IT CENTERS CAN.
VERY IMPORTANT THING
GLAD WE ARE FINALLY DOING IT.
THANK YOU WE ALL VERY MUCH AGREE
THAT ALL OF US.
FOUR OH IN THE ASSEMBLY OF
MISTER KILEY OF STAVING AND FIVE
ON THE SENATE THANK YOU.
ISSUE THIRTY COUNTY
ADMINISTRATION DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES.
WE SUPPORT THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISED TO PARA I'D ONE TIME
INCREASES TOTALING FIFTY MILLION
TO COUNTIES ACROSS VARIOUS
PROGRAMS.
CAL WORKS SINGLE ALLOCATION I
HSS ADMINISTRATION AND CONTINUUM
OF CARE REFORM RELATED
ADMINISTRATIVE ACTIVITIES.
THANK YOU.
A MOTION IN A SECOND. WE HAVE A
VOTE
FIVE OH IN THE ASSEMBLY FIVE OH
IN THE SENATE THANK YOU.
ISSUE THIRTY ONE CAL WORKS HOME
VISITING INITIATIVE.
WE SUPPORT THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE TO ESTABLISH A
VOLUNTARY HOME VISITING PILOT
PROGRAM WITHIN THE CAO WORKS
PROGRAM.
THE BUDGET SETS ASIDE ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY ONE POINT SIX
MILLION AND FEDERAL TANNA FUNDS
TO FUND THE PROGRAM THROUGH
CALENDAR YEAR TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO.
I FROM MOTION A SECOND.
WE HAVE.
.
FIVE OH IN THE SENATE.
THREE ZERO IN THE ASSEMBLY THANK
YOU.
MR AND. I JUST WANNA TAKE A
MOMENT TO THANK THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR THE WORKING
ON THAT PROGRAM AND ALSO THE
REMOVAL OF THE SUNSET.
THIS IS A WONDERFUL PROGRAM THAT
CAN HELP MANY CALIFORNIANS.
THANK YOU.
ISSUE THIRTY TWO SAFETY NET
RESERVE ARM AGAIN WAS GONNA MAKE
AN AMENDMENT.
TO PUT TWO HUNDRED MILLION TO
ADD THE TWO HUNDRED MILLION.
TO THE MEDI CAL RESERVE ACCOUNT.
FROM PROP FIFTY SIX
THANK YOU FROM ISSUE I BELIEVE
IT WAS TWENTY THREE.
SO
FIRST AND SECOND TO APPROVE.
THREE TWO THREE TWO. THANK YOU.
ISSUE THIRTY THREE NO CHILD ANTI
POVERTY.
WE SUPPORT THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISED PROVIDED TEN PERCENT
GRANT INCREASE TO CAL WORK
GRANTS EFFECTIVE APRIL FIRST
TWENTY NINETEEN AS AN INITIAL
STEP TO HELP CAO WORKS FAMILIES
GET TO FIFTY PERCENT OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL.
ANNUALIZED COST OR ESTIMATED TO
BE THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
MILLION GENERAL FUND.
THANK YOU.
SENATE SENATE IS JUST AN
OBSERVATION.
I TEND OF STAIN ON THIS IS THAT
I CONSIDER THIS A VERY
SIGNIFICANT POLICY ISSUE.
WITHOUT TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
SHE A I'D I'D JUST RELUCTANT TO
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
MOTION A SECOND TO VOTE WE HAVE
OFF FOUR ZERO. IN THE SENATE
THREE TWO IN THE ASSEMBLY.
WITHOUT CENTER NIELSEN OF STATE
THAT YOU.
ISSUE THIRTY FOUR COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENTS.
WE SUPPORT THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE TO CODIFY A STATE
COLA FOR SS I SS PAEAN CAO WORKS
GRANTS BEGINNING IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE AND MAKES THE
COOLEST SUBJECT TO FUNDING IN
THE ANNUAL BUDGET ACT.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND.
THREE TWO IN THE ASSEMBLY.
FOR ONE WITH CENTER NIELSEN KNOW
WHEN TO SEND THANK YOU.
ISSUE THIRTY FIVE WAIVER
PERSONAL CARE SERVICES
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES.
WE SUPPORT THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISED TO ESTABLISH COUNTY
PUBLIC AUTHORITIES AS THE
EMPLOYERS OF RECORD FOR
PROVIDERS OF WAIVER PERSONAL
CARE SERVICES.
TO ACHIEVE PARITY BETWEEN W. PCS
AND I JUST ASK PROVIDERS.
THIS ITEM PROVIDES THREE MILLION
GENERAL FUND ANNUALLY TO REFLECT
THE ESTIMATED INCREASING COUNTY
HEALTH BENEFIT COSTS.
THANK YOU HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND TO APPROVE.
THREE ZERO IN THE ASSEMBLY.
FOR US ARE THREE ONE AND ONE WAS
SENATOR NIELSEN NO IS CENTER
MORLOCK ABSTAINING THANK YOU.
ISSUE THIRTY SIX I EACH SS SICK
LEAVE PROVIDER BACK OBSESSED.
WE SUPPORT THE COMPTONS
COMPROMISE TO A DROPPED TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE AND SUPPLEMENTAL
REPORTING LANGUAGE TO RECONVENE
A WORK GROUP ON PAID SICK LEAVE
FOR AYE HSS PROVIDERS. AN UPDATE
THE LEGISLATURE ON THE USE OF
PAID SICK LEAVE WHICH IS
SCHEDULED TO BEGIN ON JULY ONE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THERE ARE NO
FISCAL IMPACTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THIS LANGUAGE.
THANK YOU.
THAT YOU IN A MOTION AND A
SECOND TO APPROVE THE COMPROMISE.
IN THE ASSEMBLY IT'S THREE TO.
IN THE SENATE IT IS THREE ZERO
THANK YOU.
ISSUE THIRTY SEVEN MAY REVISION
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE ON HOME
BASE FAMILY.
THIS REFLECTS AN ADOPTION OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THAT CLARIFIES THE
APPROPRIATE FOSTER CARE RATES.
ELIGIBILITY FOR CHILDREN WHO
ARE PLACED IN PERMANENCY ON OR
BEFORE DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST
TWENTY SIXTEEN THERE IS NO
FISCAL IMPACT ASSOCIATED WITH
THIS LANGUAGE.
THINK.
THANK YOU HAVE MOTION A SECOND
TO APPROVE.
FOUR ZERO WITH MISTER COUNTY
ABSTAINING.
THREE THE.
CENTER NIELSEN.
THREE ZERO IN THE SENATE THANK
YOU.
ISSUE THIRTY EIGHT LEGISLATIVE
AUGMENTATIONS.
WHAT DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES
AND DEPARTMENT OF AGING?
THERE ARE VARIOUS AUGMENTATIONS
IN THIS ITEM INCLUDES FIVE POINT
FIVE MILLION GENERAL FUND WINE
ONE TIME FOR FOOD BANK
INFRASTRUCTURE. TEN MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND ONE TIME
WITH PLACEHOLDER BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE FOR SERVICES FOR
TEMPORARY PROTECTED STATUS
RECIPIENTS. AN UNACCOMPANIED
UNDOCUMENTED MINORS.
TEN MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
ONE TIME WITH PLACE HOLDER
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE FOR DIAPER
DISTRIBUTION.
FOUR MILLION GENERAL FUND
ONGOING FOR THE DEAF ACCESS
PROGRAM.
THINK IT SAMUELSON.
ITEM SEVEN.
WE'RE GONNA REMOVE ITEMS SEVEN
OKAY.
NUMBER MOVE YOUR ARE YOUR TAKE A
SEPARATE VOTE ON ITEM SEVEN OKAY.
CAN WE VOTE SO LET'S VOTE ARE
CAN WE ARE.
SO YOU.
SO CENTER NIELSEN YOU WOULD LIKE
TO THIS MOVE EVERYTHING ELSE.
THANK YOU CAN GET A SECOND FOR
THAT.
SECOND OKAY.
I VOTE ON EVERYTHING ELSE BUT
I'VE NUMBER SEVEN.
FOUR ZERO WITH MISTER COUNTY
ABSTAINING FIVE ZERO IN THE
SENATE.
CAN I GET A MOTION TO APPROVE
ITEM SEVEN.
VOTE ON ITEM SEVEN.
THREE TWO THREE TWO THANK YOU.
MOVING ON TO ISSUE THIRTY NINE
OTHER LEGISLATIVE AUGMENTATIONS
AGAIN SOCIAL DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES. AND DEPARTMENT OF
CHILD SUPPORT SERVICE.
THIS INCLUDES VARIOUS
AUGMENTATIONS INCLUDING.
FOR THE U. CIVIC ENGAGEMENT TWO
MILLION GENERAL FUND ONE TIME.
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND ONE TIME WITH PLACE HOLDER
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE FOR
IMMIGRATION SERVICES FOR
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY FACT
STUDENTS AND STAFF TO THE
IMMIGRATION SERVICES FUNDING
PROGRAM AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES.
THANK YOU.
SIR NIELSEN FIVE ELECTED BROUGH
REMOVED FOUR SEPARATE VOTE ITEMS
FIVE SIX AND SEVEN MISTER
CHAIRMAN.
SO WOULD YOU LIKE TO MOVE THOSE
ARE NOT VOTE ON THOSE. SKIS ME
SO YOU DO WANT TO MOVE ITEMS ONE
THROUGH FOUR.
OKAY CENTER NIELSEN IS MOVING
ITEMS ONE THROUGH FOUR.
SECOND.
VOTING ITEMS ONE THROUGH FOUR.
SIR NIELSEN.
SO YOU'RE.
FIVE OH IN THE ASSEMBLY.
FIVE ON THE SENATE THANK YOU.
OH SORRY.
FOR.
IN THE SENATE WITH SENATOR
SKINNER OBSTINATE APOLOGIZE
SO CAN I GET MY A MOTION TO
APPROVE ITEMS FIVE SIX AND SEVEN.
OKAY.
VOTING FIVE SIX AND SEVEN.
THREE TWO IN THE ASSEMBLY THREE
TWO IN THE SENATE THANK YOU.
START
THREE ZERO IN THE ASSEMBLY THREE
TO IN THE SENATE THANK YOU.
ISSUE FORTY HUMAN SERVICES
LANGUAGE.
THIS ITEM REFLECTS A CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE TO ADOPT LANGUAGE
RELATED TO VARIOUS HUMAN
SERVICES PROGRAMS SUPPLEMENTAL
REPORTING LANGUAGE REQUIRING THE
ADMINISTRATION TO UPDATE THE
LEGISLATURE ON THE C. MIPS TO
GOVERNANCE. DEVELOPMENT OF THE
APPLICATION HAVE FOR CAL WORKS
AND CAL FRESH AND ON THE STATUS
OF IDENTIFYING OPPORTUNITIES TO
IMPROVE THE FILE CLEARANCE
PROCESS FOR. CAL WORKS CAL FRESH
AND MEDICARE RECIPIENTS AND
TECHNICAL TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
RELATED TO ALLOWABLE CAO WORKS
WELFARE TO WORK ACTIVITIES THERE
IS NO FISCAL IMPACT ASSOCIATED
WITH THIS LANGUAGE.
THANK YOU.
OKAY GREAT WE'RE MOTIONS SECOND.
LET'S TAKE ABOUT AN ISSUE FORTY.
FIVE OH IN THE SENATE THREE TO
THE ASSEMBLY THANK YOU.
ISSUE FORTY ONE BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE FOR LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN.
THIS ISSUE REFLECT THE TECHNICAL
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE CHANGE
REGARDING THE TIMING OF RELEASE
OF FUNDS FROM THE STATE HEALTH
FACILITY CITATION PENALTIES
ACCOUNT TO THE LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM. THERE'S NO
FISCAL IMPACT ASSOCIATED WITH
THIS LANGUAGE THANK YOU CAN I
GET A MOTION A SORT OF.
GREAT.
FIVE OH IN THE ASSEMBLY.
AND MARK.
FIVE I WON THE SECOND.
ISSUE FORTY TWO BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE FOR E. I. T. C. AVERAGE.
WE SUPPORT THE COMPROMISE HERE
THIS WOULD PROVIDE.
TWO POINT TWO MILLION IN
REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY TO THE.
COMMUNITY SERVICES AND DEVELOP.
TO REFORM OUR REACH ON BEHALF OF
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD FOR THE
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT.
THANK YOU WE.
.
THREE.
ONE AND ONE.
WITH MISTER KILEY OF STANDING IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND WE HAVE FOUR
ZERO.
IN THE.
SENATE WITH SENATOR MORLOCK
ABSTAINING PICK IF.
ISSUE FORTY THREE BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE FOR ELECTRONIC VISIT
VERIFICATION FOR IN HOME SUPPORT
SERVICES.
THIS IS A CONFERENCE COMPROMISED
TO ADD BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
AUTHORIZING THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING OF UP TO ONE MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
TO COMPLY WITH FEDERAL
ELECTRONIC VISIT VERIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE I. H. AS AS
PROGRAM.
THANK YOU GOD MOTION AND A
SECOND.
FIVE OH IN THE ASSEMBLY FIVE OH
WHEN THE SENATE THANK YOU.
ISSUE FORTY FOUR.
THIS REFLECTS THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE ON THE
ADMINISTRATION'S BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING
TO SUPPORT THE OFFICE OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT SUPPORT.
ON GOING ON ANNUAL COSTS OR SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND GENERAL FUND.
PREVIOUS SECOND. SECOND THANK
YOU.
WE HAVE THREE ZERO IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
THREE TWO IN THE SENATE THANK
YOU.
ISSUE FORTY FIVE DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES ISSUES.
THIS IS THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE AND IT INCLUDES A
BRIDGE RATE INCREASE FORWARD
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY
PROVIDERS.
THE CONFERENCE COMMITTEE.
COMPROMISE PROPOSES TWENTY FIVE
MILLION GENERAL FUND ONE.
BUDGET ILL LANGUAGE AVAILABLE
THROUGH TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
FOUR RATE INCREASES DIRECT CARE
SERVICE STAFF
CONSISTENT WITH THE A B.X. TWO
ONE FRAMEWORK USED TO AUGMENT
PROVIDER RATES.
SENATE IS.
I WOULD LIKE TO REMOVE ITEM TO
IF I MAY PLEASE.
A COMMENT BRIEFLY.
SURE WHAT WELL BALL DIDN'T COULD
COULD YOU MOVE TO APPROVE ONE
THREE AND FOUR.
ONE THREE AND FOUR.
OKAY WE ARE MOVING TO APPROVE
FOUR ZERO WITH MISTER KILEY OF
STAINING FIVE OO IN THE SENATE.
AND NOW WE ARE MOVING ON TO ITEM
TWO CENTER NIELSEN. THE HALF DAY
BUILDING WAS A PART OF A.
COMPROMISE AND THAT KINDA LIKE
TO SEE THAT WE WOULD KEEP OUR
WORD ON THAT COMPROMISED.
OKAY.
I GET A MOTION TO APPROVE ITEM
TO.
WE HAVE.
THREE ONE IN ONE WITH MISTER
MORLOCK ABSTAINING. AND WE HAVE
THREE TWO IN THE ASSEMBLY THANK
YOU.
MR BELOW THANK YOU.
VERY BRIEFLY I'M AYE AYE AYE
FOR I'M SUPPORTING ALL THESE.
.
MOTIONS ON DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES ON BUT THERE'S A GOOD
DEAL OF DISAPPOINTMENT IN THE
COMMUNITY AND AND AROUND THE
STATE ON THE LEVEL OF FUNDING
AND DUH I JUST LIKE TO SAY THAT
I THINK WE ALL NEED TO. WORK
HARDER TO DO BETTER IN THE
FUTURE AND THE.
CERTAINLY TRY TO DO THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THAT TO COMMENT CENTER YES BUT
IF WE MADE TWO THREE AND FOUR
REMOVE.
WHO WOULD KNOW WE'RE STILL ISSUE
FORTY FIVE?
DO YOUARE ALWAYS AHEAD OF US SO
WE ARE STILL ISSUE. WE ARE YOU
ARE MOVING FAST WE ARE STILL ON
ISSUE FORTY FIVE.
NO NO WE.
I NEED A MOTION TO APPROVE
NUMBER TWO BECAUSE WE DID NOT.
DO ANYTHING IN.
FOLLOW.
THAT'S ARE SO WE DID THAT I
APOLOGIZE YOU'RE RIGHT. WE DID
THAT AND THEN MISSED MISTER
BLOOM MADE A SPEECH THANK YOU I
POLITICS SO NOW WE'RE GOING TO
ISSUE FORTY SIX THANK YOU.
YEAH.
DIGITAL RECORDING SIX THERE ARE
SEVERAL LEGISLATIVE
AUGMENTATIONS WE'VE IT NO.
THE CONFERENCE COMPROMISE
PROPOSES A TWENTY NINE POINT
THREE MILLION GENERAL FUND AND
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE ON A ONE
TIME BASIS TO DELAY THE FOURTEEN
DAY UNIFORM HOLIDAY SCHEDULE
STATUTE IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
THE BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE SUSPEND
THE ENFORCEMENT OF ANY UNIFORM
HOLIDAY SCHEDULE ON REGIONAL
CENTERS INTEL JULY ONE TWENTY
NINETEEN AND PROVIDES ASSOCIATED
FUNDING FOR THIS PURPOSE. THANK
YOU.
THE KIT WE ARE MOTION TO APPROVE
ONE THROUGH FOUR
I WANTED TO REMOVE TWO THREE AND
FOUR OKAY SO IT'S A MAJOR CENTER
NIELSEN IS MOVING TO APPROVE
ISSUE ONE.
THAT
OKAY
BUT ONE ISSUE ONE.
THREE TO IN THE ASSEMBLY FIVE OH
IN THE SENATE AND.
COULD I GET A MOTION TO APPROVE
TO FOR.
OKAY THREE TWO IN THE ASSEMBLY.
THREE TWO IN THE SENATE AQ.
ISSUE FORTY SEVEN SUSTAINABLE
FUNDING FOR FISH AND WILDLIFE.
FOREIGN RESOURCES THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE ACCOMPLISHES THREE
OBJECTIVES IT ADDRESSES THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND GAME
PRESERVATION FUND STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT FOR THREE YEARS WHICH IS
AN ISSUE WE'VE TALKED ABOUT IN
THE. PREVIOUS YEARS FREQUENTLY
WITH THE COMMITTEE. PROVIDES AN
ADDITIONAL TEN MILLION TO
ENHANCE DEPARTMENT ACTIVITIES
THAT ALIGN WITH THE PRIORITIES
IDENTIFIED BY THE STAKEHOLDER
ADVISORY GROUP AND THE MOST
RECENT UPDATE TO THE
DEPARTMENT'S STRATEGIC VISION
REPORT AS DIRECTED BY THE
LEGISLATURE. LASTLY ALLOWS FOR
SERVICE BASE BUDGET REVIEW AND
THE DEVELOPMENT OF A TRACKING
SYSTEMTO SUPPORT AN ANALYSIS OF
THE DEPARTMENT'S EXISTING
PROGRAM ACTIVITIES AND REVENUE
STRUCTURE.
THANK YOU.
THE MOTION TO APPROVE THE
COMPROMISE.
THE SECOND AND SENATOR NIELSEN.
YOU WOULD LIKE TO VOTE ON THE
TIRE FRONT SEPARATELY.
ANYTHING ELSE TO BE SEPARATE OUT
MISTER OBERNOLTE.
I JUST WANT TO MAKE A COMMENT ON
THE TIRE FUND'S PROFIT JUST THE
SAME COMMENT THAT SATURDAY ALSO
HAVE WHICH IS JUST. IN MY
OPINION IT'S VERY INAPPROPRIATE
TO USE TIRE FEE FUNDS.
TO OUR.
PLUG THE STRUCTURAL DEFICIT IN
THE DFW THOSE FUNDS WERE. ARE
TAKEN FROM CONSUMERS FOR A
SPECIFIC PURPOSE NOT TO ARE.
TAUGHT TO OUR GIVE TO THE VFW
FOR FOR OUR CURATED DEFICIT SO.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR MORE LOCK YOUR.
OKAY.
CHO CARE.
YEAH THE.
TIME FOR THE BAD JOKES HAVE
STARTED.
OKAY SO.
CENTER NIELSEN HAS MOVED TO
PROVE EVERYTHING BUT THE TIRE
FRONT
IS THAT IS A FAIR MOTION. THANK
YOU CAN.
WE'LL A MOTION SO WE ARE TAKING
A MOTION TO APPROVE EVERYTHING
BUT THE TARIFF AND THE TRYING TO
BILL LANGUAGE ON NUMBER
THE THE SECOND.
AND WHO DO. NOT THE FOOT DON'T
JUST A FUN BUT THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE IN THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE OKAY VERY CA.
OKAY IT TO LELAND DO WE HAVE
THAT. YES OKAY.
FIVE OH FILO THANK YOU CALIGULA
MOTION TO APPROVE THE REMAINING
LANGUAGE.
THREE TWO THREE TWO THANK YOU.
ISSUE FORTY IT
CLEAN DRINKING WATER.
WE SUPPORT THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE WE WOULD NOTE THE
LEGISLATURE HAS INDICATED A
COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE
DISCUSSIONS ON A COMPREHENSIVE
PACKAGE TO ADDRESS SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER NEEDS
THIS SUMMER.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT TWENTY THREE
POINT FIVE MILLION GENERAL FUND
HAS BEEN SET ASIDE TO ADDRESS
SAFE DRINKING WATER NEEDS AS
PART OF THESE CONTINUING
DISCUSSIONS.
THE CONFERENCE COMPROMISE
PROVIDES FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND.
SUPPORT CRITICAL LEAD TESTING
REMEDIATION AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FOR CHILDCARE CENTERS
WITH A PRIORITY TO CENTERS THAT
SERVE CHILDREN AGES OF ZERO TO
FIVE YEARS.
WE ARE MOTION AND A SECOND TO
APPROVE THE COMPROMISE.
AND MISTER BLOOM LIKE TO SPEAK
BEFORE THE ARAB THIS IS A AS I
SAID BEFORE AN EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR MANY MANY
CALIFORNIANS PARTICULARLY THOSE
WELL. IN PARTICULARLY THOSE WHO
LIVE IN THE AREAS THAT ARE
AFFECTED BY. A OF.
A TAPE TO DRINKING WATER. IT'S
PRETTY OUTRAGEOUS THAT.
.
AT THIS POINT IN TIME IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE SO MANY
PEOPLE HAVE TO EXPERIENCE THOSE
CONDITIONS SO. I'M I'M
DISAPPOINTED THAT WE HAVEN'T
GOTTEN THERE YET BUT I'M VERY
OPTIMISTIC THAT WE ARE GOING TO
GET TO A. A RESOLUTION WORKING
WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO SOLVE
THAT PROBLEM.
THANK YOU.
MISTER OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I THINK
WE'RE UNIFIED IN OUR BELIEF THAT
EVERY CALIFORNIA DESERVES ACCESS
TO CLEAN AND SAFE DRINKING WATER
I'M VERY HAPPY THAT. THE.
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL FOR A
TAX INCREASE ON WATER WAS
REJECTED IN THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL
AND I'M HOPEFUL THAT IN OUR
NEGOTIATIONS AS TIME MOVES
FORWARD HERE THAT WE CAN FIND A
WAY TO PRIORITIZE SPENDING. WITH
THE GENERAL FUND TO AVOID HAVING
TO TAX SOMETHING THAT IS A
FUNDAMENTAL NECESSITY FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
THANK YOU.
OKAY SO WE HAVE A MOTION TO
APPROVE FOR ISSUE FORTY.
THREE FIVE ZERO FIVE ZERO THANK
YOU.
ISSUE FORTY NINE PROP SIXTEEN
ALLOCATIONS.
WE SUPPORT THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE WHICH REFLECTS THE
VARIOUS PROPOSITION SIXTY EIGHT
INVESTMENTS ABOVE THE GOVERNOR'S
MAY REVISION
PACKAGE THAT ALIGNED THE
STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS.
SET FORTH IN THE INITIATIVE
PASSED BY CALIFONE YOUR VOTERS
EARLIER THIS WEEK.
WE HAVE A MOTION SECOND TO
APPROVE ISSUE FORTY NINE SENATOR
MORE LOCK YOUR QUESTION.
SURE I.
I I'M HAVING TROUBLE WITH THE
LAW A LOT OF THESE BUT ALL
COLLEGES VOTE.
OKAY.
GREAT.
GOV WE HAVE A MOTION TO APPROVE
THE WHOLE THING THANK YOU.
SO NIELSEN I'M HUNDRED TO PULL
THE FIRST IN THE LAST IF I MEAN
YOU WOULD LIKE TO PULL IT WOULD
LIKE TO MOVE THE FIRST THE LAST
YOU WANNA MOVE EVERYTHING ELSE
BUT I WOULD HOLD ON THOSE THAT
MAKE A MOTION ON THE REST OF
THEM AND THEN JUST. TOLD THOSE
OUT. THANK YOU.
SO YOU'LL HAVE YOU WOULD HAVE
YOUR YOU WOULD LIKE TO APPROVE
EVERYTHING ELSE BUT THE SUTTER
BUTTE FLOOD MANAGEMENT AGENCY
NON ON ON ALSO THAT WOULD BE THE.
THE THE WE WOULD WOULD MAINTAIN.
NUMBER SIXTY EIGHT SOVIET FLOOD
MANAGEMENT. AND THE PROP SIXTY
EIGHT INVESTMENT.
THE VERY LAST ONE.
YOU WOULD LIKE TO MOVE TO
APPROVE THOSE TO. THANK YOU.
OKAY MOVED TO APPROVE THOSE TWO
BULLETS.
THREE ONE AND ONE WITH MR ARE
KILEY ABSTAINING AND WE HAVE
FIVE OO IN THE SENATE.
AND WE HAVE OF MOTION ALREADY TO
PROVE EVERYTHING ELSE SO.
NO NO. OKAY
EVERY DOLLAR EVERY EVERYTHING
ELSE.
NO I'M A NO ON THAT THREE TWO
THREE TWO THANK YOU.
AND WE ARE AT HALF TIME.
SO WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A FIVE
MINUTE HALFTIME BRICK.
TO STRETCH.
GO TO THE RESTROOM OR TAKE CARE
YOU KNOW MISS COSTA COULD GO GET
SOME MORE COKES
.
SOME OF THESE I DON'T CARE PARTS.
NOT.
SO I.
BUT I HAVE. N'T.
BUT UNTIL TONIGHT BUT I DECIDED
TO.
IS NOT A GOOD FOR.
AS MUCH AS WELL.
COMES A TIME.
PROBABLY
BUT.
BUT THEY'RE DIVIDED LOYALTIES.
TROUBLES WITH HIM DAY IN.
THE HARDEST THING I HAVE TO DO.
KEEP MY SHOW.
WHAT NO IT ISN'T THE HARSH?
VERY GOOD ACTORS SAYING I LEARN
MORE MONEY GOES TO.
TONIGHT.
SO.
WHEN THINGS REALLY UPSET ME.
I MAKE SURE THAT I
THANK YOU WE ARE GOING TO
RESUME.
WE ARE IN ISSUE FIFTY INVASIVE
PESTS.
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FOOD IN
OUR CULTURE.
ALTHOUGH THE TABLE OF CONTENTS
AND NOTES THIS ITEM AS INVASIVE
PETS I BELIEVE IT IS PASSED.
THE ADMINISTRATORS EASE OF PETS
SO THE ADMINISTRATION SUPPORTS
THE CONFERENCE COMPROMISE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL FOR
FIVE MILLION ON GOING FOR CITRUS
PASSED RELATED ACTIVITIES. TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION GENERAL FUND
AND TWO POINT FIVE MILLION
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE FUN.
FIVE MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND AND BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
FOUR SHOT HOLE BORDER BEETLE
MITIGATION. AN ADDITIONAL TEN
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
FOR CITRUS PASSED RELATED
ACTIVITIES. AND LASTLY TWO
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
FOR INVASIVE WE'D ABATEMENTS.
SO THE MOTION TO APPROVE.
SENATOR NIELSEN
I JUST ON THAT POINT MISTER
CHAIRMAN I WOULD LIKE TO
EMPHASIZE THAT THE THIS KIND OF
INVASIVE SPECIES ISSUE.
INVASIVE PAST IS NOT SIMPLY AN
AGRICULTURAL PROBLEM IT'S A THE
URBAN ONE AS WELL. THOSE WHO
HAVE ANY KIND OF CERTAIN.
CITRUS IN THEIR.
BACKYARDS OR WHATEVER.
I REMEMBER THE MED FLY YEARS AND
WHAT ALL THAT MEANT SO THAT THIS
IS A IT'S NOT JUST AN
AGRICULTURAL ISSUE I WOULD ARE
EMPHASIZE.
I WOULD MOVE IT.
THANK YOU.
SEEING OTHER SCHEDULED OF THE
VOTE.
FIVE OH ON THE ASSEMBLY.
FIVE ON THE FACT THAT YOU.
ISSUE FIFTY ONE VARIOUS ISSUES
AND CD AFFECT.
WE SUPPORT THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE WHICH PROVIDES FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR GRANT TO
THE CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP FOR
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY.
AS WELL AS A COMPROMISE ON BE
SAFE TO APPROVE ONE POINT NINE
MILLION ON A THREE YEAR LIMITED
TERM BASIS. AND COMPLETE THE
PROPOSED REPORT BY JANUARY TENTH
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
WE HAVE A MOTION A SECOND TO
APPROVE THE COMPROMISE.
FIVE OO IN THE ASSEMBLY FIVE ON
THE SENATE THANK YOU.
ISSUE FIFTY TWO.
A VARIOUS ISSUES AND THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION.
WE SUPPORT THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE THIS COMPROMISE A
LINES FOR THE POLICY GOALS OF
SEVERAL OF THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSALS FOR CAO RECYCLE THE
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC SUBSTANCES
CONTROL AND THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD. WE NOTE THAT ALTHOUGH
FUNDING FOR THE AGRICULTURAL
DIESEL ENGINE REPLACEMENT AND
UPGRADES PROGRAM WAS ULTIMATELY
NOT INCLUDED IN THIS BUDGET THE
ADMINISTRATION LOOKS FORWARD TO
FURTHER DISCUSSIONS ON THIS ITEM
DURING THE CAP AND TRADE
NEGOTIATIONS IN THE COMING WEEKS.
THANK YOU.
THE SECOND.
DIE THE SECOND TO MEDICAL ADVICE
OKAY SONYA SEPARATE OUT TENANT
ELEVEN IF WE COULD MISTER
CHAIRMAN SEPARATE ON TEN ELEVEN
WHICH I BELIEVE.
BOB THEY'LL.
THE BOTTLE BILL.
THEN DISASTER RECOVERY
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO.
THAT'S BOTTOM.
ONE IN TERMS OF PLASTIC MARKET
DEVELOPMENT PAYMENTS IN ONE IN
TERMS OF CHP ENFORCEMENT CORRECT
THANK OKAY.
SO LETS VOTE ON EVERYTHING ELSE
BUT THOSE TWO BULLETS FIRST.
THANK YOU.
FOR ONE WAS CENTER MORE LOCKS
ARE THREE TO.
AND THREE TO THANK YOU.
WE WILL NOW VOTE ON THE BOTTLE
BILL THE PLASTIC MARKET
DEVELOPMENT PAYMENTS.
I GOT THREE TO FIVE ARE THREE
TWO IN THE ASSEMBLY FIVE ON THE
SENATE.
WE'RE GONNA GO SEE H. P.
ENFORCEMENT.
THREE TWO IN THE ASSEMBLY.
THREE TWO IN THE SENATE.
NOW WE'RE GONNA GO WITH DISASTER
RECOVERY ASSISTANCE PROGRAM.
FIVE OH IN THE ASSEMBLY FIVE ON
THE SENATE THANK YOU.
ISSUE FIFTY THREE.
THIS CONFERENCE COMPROMISE
INCLUDES LANGUAGE RELATED ISSUES
THAT WILL PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
TRANSPARENCY TO THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GENERAL PUBLIC AND ONE
TIME EXPENDITURES FOR
CAPITAL IMPROVEMENTS AND MOVING
COSTS AND TENANT IMPROVEMENTS.
YOU IT US ANYMORE LA.
AND JERRY I MOVE NO MORE BULLET
POINTS.
SO NOTED I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT
WHAT CAN WE DO FOR YOU INITIAL
PART TIME I'M BACK AND FORTH ON
ALL OF THESE I DON'T KNOW IF I
WANT TO PUT IT IN GROUPS ARE
PROBABLY GOING TO SEPARATE LOOK
JUST.
LET'S TAKE A MOTION TO VOTE ON
THE FIRST ONE AND THEN WILL
SUBSTITUTE FOR EACH OF THE
BULLETS AND THEN WE'LL JUST
BOUGHT THEM INDIVIDUALLY.
CAN I GET A MOTION TO APPROVE
SOUTH YUBA RIVER.
OKAY.
FIVE OO FIVE OO.
AND I'M A SUBSTITUTE ALL THE
MOTIONS FOR ALL THE BULLETS SO
SALTON SEA.
THREE TO IN THE ASSEMBLY THREE
TWO IN THE SENATE.
SORRY.
THREE ONE AND ONE WITH MISTER
COLLIE ABSTAINING THREE TWO IN
THE SENATE.
A. REGULATION FORSMAN
TEMPERATURES GO BABY CDC.
THREE ZERO.
IN THE ASSEMBLY THREE TWO IN THE
SENATE THANK YOU.
OUR RELOCATION BAY AREA METRO
CENTER.
THREE.
THREE ONE ONE IN THE ASSEMBLY
WITH MISTER KILEY ABSTAINING
THREE TWO IN THE SENATE.
STATE WATER PROJECT AGING
INFRASTRUCTURE.
WE HAVE FOUR.
FIVE FIVE O. IN THE ASSEMBLY
FIVE ON THE SENATE.
FORCE CARBON PLAN.
FIVE OH FIVE ARE.
MALLARD.
AB IF ONE FORTY TWO REPORT.
IMITATION.
THREE ZERO IN THE ASSEMBLY THREE
ZERO IN THE SENATE.
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL GAME
COMMISSION BOARD MEETINGS.
THREE TWO THREE TWO.
THANK YOU
ITS YOU FIFTY FOUR LEGISLATIVE
INVESTMENTS AND.
NATURAL RESOURCES ARE JUST.
THIS I CONFERENCE COMPROMISED
REFLECTS VARIOUS ONE TIME
EXPENDITURES THAT ALIGN WITH THE
CONSTRUCT OF THE ADMINISTRATION
AND THE LEGISLATURE'S OVERALL
BUDGET FRAMEWORK.
THANK YOU MOVE THE COMPROMISED
KINDA SECRETARY. YEAH PROJECTS.
SERIOUSLY.
PROBLEMS ALL THE WAY THROUGH
HERE I.
REQUESTED WE DO AMENDED.
WE WILL BE VOTING ON EACH OF
THESE ITEMS INDIVIDUALLY.
A WE HAVE A MOTION.
TO.
KIND OF MOTION TO APPROVE THE
FIRST ITEM WHICH IS THE ITALIAN
AMERICAN MUSEUM OF OFFICIALS.
A SECOND OKAY AND THEN WE ARE
I'M A SUBSTITUTE THE MOTION FOR
EACH OF THE ITEMS WERE NOW GOING
TO VOTE ON THESE INDIVIDUALS
OKAY.
ITALIAN AMERICAN MUSEUM.
THREE ONE AND ONE WITH MR KHALID
STANDING THREE TWO IN THE SENATE.
I LGBTQ MUSEUM.
THREE ONE IN ONE MISTER COLLIE
ABSTAINING.
THREE TWO AND THE SENATE A.
SOCIAL PROTECTION COUNCIL.
THREE TWO IN THE SENATE.
THREE ONE AND ONE IN THE
ASSEMBLY WITH MISTER KILEY
EXTENDING THE CITY OF SANTA ANA.
I APOLOGIZE LOWER LA RIVER.
THREE TWO IN THE SENATE.
THREE ONE IN ONE WITH MISTER
KILEY OF STANDING IN THE
ASSEMBLY CITY OF SANTA ANA.
THREE ONE.
WITH MISTER KILEY ABSTAINING IN
THE ASSEMBLY.
FOR ONE WITH MISTER MORLOCK.
VOTING NO.
THE.
MUCKING FOLDER SPRINKLER SYSTEM.
THREE ONE IN ONE WITH MISTER
KILEY OF STAVING THREE TWO IN
THE SENATE.
FOR ONE IN THE SENATE THANK YOU
WITH THE SENATOR NIELSEN VOTING
NO CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION.
GENOMICS.
I'M.
THREE ONE IN ONE WITH MR KILEY
STAINING IN THE.
ASSEMBLY.
SENATE.
SEVERAL WHICH ARE KNOWN CENTER
NIELSEN.
YOU'RE STAYING.
FIVE OH I SEE YOUR THUMBS ARE
MORE.
FIVE OH IN THE SENATE AGOURA
HILLS.
THREE ONE IN ONE WITHOUT MISTER
KILEY ABSTAINING FIVE OH IN THE
SENATE.
SAN FRANCISCO SEA WALL.
THREE TWO IN THE SENATE.
THREE ONE IN ONE MISTER KILEY OF
STANDING CITY OF SANTA ANA.
FIVE OH IN THE SENATE.
THREE ONE IN ONE.
IN THE ASSEMBLY LASSEN
COURTHOUSE.
FIVE OH.
YOU GUYS SHOULD BE FIVE OH.
FIVE OH FIVE OH.
LET ME LET ME JUST HELP YOU ARE
IMAGES HELP YOU OUT HERE.
CITY OF DALY CITY.
THREE TWO.
THREE ONE IN ONE WITH MISTER
KILEY OF STANDING CITY OF COLTON.
THREE ONE IN ONE.
WITH MR KELLY OF STAVING THREE
TWO IN THE SENATE A LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS.
LOCAL CONSERVATION CORPS.
THREE TWO.
THREE ONE IN ONE MISTER COLLIE
OF STANDING.
SORRY I FOR ONE IN THE SENATE
WITH MISTER.
SENATOR NIELSEN VOTING NO
MOBILE EQUIPMENT.
FIVE OH WERE TRYING
FIVE OH.
THREE ONE IN ONE WITH MR
OBERNOLTE NO MISTER KILEY OF
STANDING.
I LEGISLATIVE INVESTMENTS CAPT
ALI FUNDING FOR CONTRACT
COUNTIES.
THREE TWO.
THREE ONE ON ONE MISTER KILEY OF
STANDING IN THE ASSEMBLY.
COUNTY SAN BERTINO TYPE THREE
ENGINE.
FIVE ALL IN THE SENATE.
FOUR ZERO IN THE ASSEMBLY MISTER
KILEY ABSTAINING.
MARTIN'S BEACH PUBLIC ACCESS.
THREE ONE IN ONE MISTER CARLY
ABSTAINING THREE TWO IN THE
SENATE.
GRANTOR TRUST LAND SEA LEVEL
RISE IMPACT AB SIX NINE ONE.
THREE TWO.
THREE ONE IN ONE MISTER KILEY OF
STANDING.
LEGISLATIVE INVESTMENT
CALIFORNIA WATERFOWL HABITAT.
FIVE OH.
THREE ONE IN ONE MISTER KILEY
ABSTAINING.
FIVE IN THE SENATE.
LIST THEY'VE INVESTMENTS
RECOVERING SUSTAINING
POPULATIONS OF MONARCH
BUTTERFLIES.
THREE TWO IN THE SENATE.
THREE ONE ON ONE MISTER KILEY
ABSTAINING IN THE ASSEMBLY.
I EXPLORE THE COAST.
THREE ONE AND ONE MISTER KHALID
STANDING IN THE ASSEMBLY AT FIVE
OO IN THE SENATE.
ELWOOD MESA HABITAT.
ALTHOUGH THE SENATE THREE ONE IN
ONE IN THE.
.
ASSEMBLY MISTER COUNTY OF
STANDING.
COASTAL BE FLOOD PREVENTION FUND
FIVE OO IN THE SENATE.
THREE ONE ONE MISTER OBERNOLTE I
KNOW MR KILEY UPSTANDING WEST
COYOTE HILLS.
FOR A THREE THREE ONE IN ONE IN
THE ASSEMBLY MISTER KILEY
UPSTANDING.
THREE TWO IN THE SENATE.
BENEFICIAL PILOT REUSE PROGRAM.
THREE ONE IN ONE.
IN THE ASSEMBLY MISTER
COMMUNISTE MARITIME MUSEUM.
FIVE OH.
THREE ONE IN ONE SO FIVE ON THE
SENATE THREE ONE ONE IN THE
FAMILY RESEARCH COUNTY
UPSTANDING.
A PEDESTRIAN BICYCLE ACCESS LA
HIS STATE HISTORIC PARK
THREE TWO. IN THE SENATE THREE
ONE AND ONE IN THE ASSEMBLY
MISTER COUNTY UPSTANDING CITY OF
WHITTIER.
THREE TWO.
IN THE SENATE THREE ONE ONE
MISTER KHALID STAYING THERE
SIMPLY.
I THE CITY WE ARE AGAIN LUMBER
OUT OF THEATER.
THREE TWO.
THREE ONE IN ONE THREE TWO
SENATE THREE ONE IN ONE IN THE
ASSEMBLY MISTER KHALID STAND.
CITY VALLEY CESAR CHAVEZ PARK.
THREE TWO THREE ONE IN WHAT
THREE TWO IN THE SENATE THREE
ONE IN ONE. IN THE ASSEMBLY.
LODI CIVIL RIGHT RUSSIAN PATROL.
THREE TWO.
THREE ONE ONE.
.
THREE ONE ONE MISTER CARLY OF
STANDING IN THE ASSEMBLY.
CITY COUNTY SAN FRANCISCO
RICHMOND COMMUNITY CENTER THREE
TWO.
THREE ONE ONE MISTER KILEY
ABSTAINING THREE TWO IN THE
SENATE SONOMA COUNTY COMMUNITY
SAID I AM. A.
THREE TWO IN THE SENATE.
THREE ONE IN ONE IN THE ASSEMBLY
MISTER KILEY OF STANDING. UP THE
CITY OF LA AT MID VALLEY MULTI
PURPOSE CENTER.
THREE TWO.
IN THE SENATE IN THE ASSEMBLY
THREE ONE AND ONE MISTER KILEY
ABSTAINING LA RIVER GREEN BIAS.
THREE TWO IN THE SENATE THREE
ONE A ONE MISTER KILEY OF
STANDING IN THE ASSEMBLY.
MID PENINSULA REFILL OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT.
THREE TWO IN THE SENATE THREE
ONE AND ONE IN THE ASSEMBLY
MISTER CARLY UPSTANDING TO NEED
IS CREEK.
THREE TWO IN THE SENATE THREE
ONE IN ONE IN THE ASSEMBLY.
AIDS MONUMENT WEST HOLLYWOOD.
THREE.
SUCK DOT THREE ONE IN ONE IN THE
SENATE MISS SENATOR NIELSEN
ABSTAINING. THREE ONE IN ONE IN
THE ASSEMBLY WITH MISTER KILEY
UPSTANDING FLOOD CONTROL
INFRASTRUCTURE.
FIVE OH FIVE OH WHILE.
THE SAN FERNANDO RESERVOIR.
AB ONE TO CARRY THREE ONE AND
ONE ON THE ASSEMBLY MISTER
COLLEGE STAINING THREE TWO IN
THE SENATE OKAY.
I SERVE FOR CHICANO ART AND
CULTURE.
THREE TWO IN THE SENATE THREE
ONE ONE IN THE ASSEMBLY WHEN
MISTER KILEY ABSTAINING OAKLAND
MUSEUM.
THREE TO IN THE SENATE THREE ONE
ON ONE MISTER KHALID STANDING IN
THE ASSEMBLY.
COMMUNITY BASED FIRE PREVENTION
WORK.
FIVE OO FIVE OO.
SANTA ANA RIVER CONSERVANCY.
FIVE OH.
IN THE SENATE THREE ONE ON ONE
IN THE ASSEMBLY MISTER KILEY OF
STANDING.
CITY OF LA HABRA.
THREE TWO IN THE SENATE THREE
ONE ONE MISTER KHALID STING IN
THE ASSEMBLY EAST BAY REGIONAL
PARKS JUST.
THREE TWO IN THE SENATE THREE
ONE IN ONE INDIA SEVEN MISTER
KHALID STAND. REDWOOD VALLEY
COUNTY WATER DISTRICT.
THREE TWO IN THE SENATE THREE
ONE AND ONE IN THE ASSEMBLY
MISTER KILEY UPSTANDING.
ADDITIONAL PARKWAYS CLEANUP
EXCITE.
THREE TWO.
IN THE SENATE THREE ONE ONE IN
THE ASSEMBLY MISTER COLLEGE TING
STANISLAUS COUNTY CAMP TAYLOR.
FIVE OH.
THREE ONE AND ONE MISTER KHALID
STANDING IN THE ASSEMBLY FIVE ON
THE SENATE BAO DIVERSITY
INITIATIVE.
THREE TWO BIODIVERSITY.
OUR LARGEST KEEPS GOING TO GO.
AND.
WE STOPPED.
WE.
DO YOU. WHICH WAS DO YOU HAVE.
I'M LOOKING A FINANCE MISTRUST
OF OURS DON'T HAVE THOSE ITEMS
UP.
I CAN'T TELL YOU THAT I NO AS
PART OF THE PACKAGE THERE IS AN
AUGMENTATION OF TWO MILLION
DOLLARS FOR BIODIVERSITY BUT I
DON'T SEE IT ON THIS AGENDA ITEM.
AS WELL SIX MILLION FOR PROJECT
PHOENIX WHICH IS NOT.
ON THIS AGENDA ITEM.
PROJECT PHOENIX.
SO THEY THEY WERE PROVED RIGHT
MISS COSTA THE BIO DIVERSITY
INITIATIVE IN THE PROJECT
PHOENIX MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
BOTH OF THOSE PROJECTS APART AT
THE THREE WAY AGREEMENT REACHED
BETWEEN THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION.
I APOLOGIZE FOR THE.
LACK OF CONSISTENCY REGARDING
THE AGENDAS.
OKAY.
WE JUST GET A MOTION CATHOLIC
HERE THREE TWO IN THE SENATE.
THREE.
THREE ZERO IN THE ASSEMBLY SORRY
MY APOLOGIES.
YEAH I JUST ABOUT TO GO.
ISSUE FIFTY FIVE.
LEGISLATIVE INVESTMENTS AND CAL
EPA.
WE WOULD KNOW ALTHOUGH FUNDING
FOR THE AGRICULTURAL ENERGY
EFFICIENCY PROJECTS WAS
ULTIMATELY NOT INCLUDED IN THIS
BUDGET THE ADMINISTRATION LOOKS
FORWARD TO FURTHER DISCUSSIONS
ON THIS ITEM DURING THE CAP AND
TRADE NEGOTIATIONS IN THE COMING
WEEKS.
JUST REMAIN THAT OF CHAIR.
ITEM
A FOURTH ITEM THE CODIFICATION
ALTERNATIVE MANURE MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM IF WE CAN.
THAT ONE OFF.
ON THAT ONE VOTE OKAY SO.
OUT ENTERTAIN A MOTION FROM YOU
SIGNATURE NIELSEN.
ON THAT ONE ITEM THE
CODIFICATION OF ALTERNATIVE NOR
ALL INTO A MOTION AND A SECOND.
PAULAALL SECOND THE MANURE
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM I APPRECIATE
YOU FOR DOING SO ON THE VOTE ON
THAT MOTION ON THE SENATE SIDE
IS.
FIVE ZERO ASSEMBLY SIDE IS.
OFFICE FOR ONE ABSTENTION.
MR ALL THREE ONE.
WE VOTED YES FULLER DEMOGRAPHIC
ON.
WHAT ONE FOR AND ONE ABSTENTION
MISS OBERNOLTE?
THEN NEXT MOTION I'LL ENTERTAIN
IS TO I ACCEPT EVERYTHING OTHER
THAN THE ACTUAL WE JUST TOOK.
SENATE VOTE OF.
THREE TWO.
ASSEMBLY VOTE OF THREE TO.
AMERICA FOR.
THANK YOU ISSUE FIFTY SIX
AGRICULTURAL ENERGY EFFICIENCY
PROJECTS.
I SKIPPED AHEAD I DEFER TO MY
PREVIOUS COMMENT WE LOOK FOR TO
THIS DISCUSSION AS PART OF CAP
AND TRADE.
THANK YOU.
SO ACTION IS TO ADOPT CENTER
VERSION.
SECOND.
THANK YOU SIR NIELSEN.
CHAIRMAN ON THIS ISSUE I DO HAVE
TO OF.
HAZARD AND OBSERVATION.
RATHER DISAPPOINTING TO MAKE.
OVER THE YEARS THAT AND
INCREASINGLY SO IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT. ORGANIZATIONS
OR INDIVIDUALS.
COME HERE AND.
LAKE AGREEMENTS.
THIS PARTICULAR ITEM.
ORGANIZATIONS MADE AGREEMENTS.
AND.
THAT THEY WOULD SUPPORT CAP AND
TRADE.
BUT THEY WANTED TO HAVE
SOMETHING THAT
WOULD BE HELPFUL TO THEM AS WELL
AS A PART OF THIS.
AGREEMENT.
SUPPORT.
THAT'S NORMAL BUSINESS.
BUT WATCH BUT INCREASINGLY
HAPPENING.
AND WHY I KEEP SAYING SO OFTEN
THERE'S NO TRUST AROUND HERE.
THAT DEAL HOLES FOR MAYBE ONE OR
TO YEARS.
AND THEN THE LEGISLATURE CHANGES
EVERYTHING.
AND.
WHAT'S ABOUT KEEPING YOUR WORD.
THIS IS BECOME MORE OF A HABIT.
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE ISSUES
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT.
THANK YOU CENTER.
SO WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND TO APPROVE.
THREE ONE AND ONE CENTER DEL SEN
NO CENTER MORE LOCK ABSTAINING.
THREE TWO IN THE ASSEMBLY.
ISSUE FIFTY SEVEN CAP AND TRADE
EXPENDITURE PLAN ELECTRIC
VEHICLES AND ZERO MISSION HE
VISA CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE
PLAN.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS COMMITTED
TO WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
ON A CAP AND TRADE IN ZERO
EMISSIONS VEHICLE COMPROMISE
PACKAGE IN THE COMING WEEKS.
THANK YOU.
THREE TWO IN THE SENATE.
FOUR ZERO IN THE ASSEMBLY MISTER
KILEY ABSTAINING THANK YOU.
YOU FIFTY SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS FOR TRANSPORTATION
AND ENERGY.
WE SUPPORT THIS ACTION WHICH IS
TO ADOPT SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING
LANGUAGE BURN ENERGY COMMISSION
ACCOUNT APY YOU SEE PROGRAM AND
TO CALTRANS PROGRAMS.
THANK YOU.
WE GET A VOTE.
THREE TWO IN THE SENATE
FIVE OH IN THE ASSEMBLY THANK
YOU.
ISSUE FIFTEEN NON TRANSPORTATION
LEGISLATIVE INVESTMENTS.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROVIDED
SIX POINT ONE MILLION MOTOR
VEHICLE COUNT FOR DESIGNING
CONSTRUCTION OF PERIMETER
SECURITY FENCES AT THIRTEEN
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLE
OFFICES.
THE CONFERENCE COMPROMISE
REFLECTS VARIOUS ONE TIME
INVESTMENT THAT ALIGN WITH THE
CONSTRUCTION OF THAT. AGREED
UPON OVERALL BUDGET FREE MARK.
OKAY WE WILL VOTE ITEM BY ITEM.
CHO GONNA MOSHE SECOND TO VOTE
ON EACH ITEM SO. TOOK UP.
THE MOTION FOR STATE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY AUTO TECH
TESTING DEVELOPMENT PILOT.
THREE TWO IN THE ASSEMBLY.
OUR CENTER NIELSEN YOUR AYE FOUR
FOUR ZERO WITH SENATOR MORE LIKE
TEN MAKE YOU RIVER THE RAILS.
THREE TWO IN THE ASSEMBLY.
THREE TWO IN THE SENATE THANK
YOU XIN STATION.
THREE TWO IN THE SENATE
THREE ZERO IN THE ASSEMBLY SABER
CAO TRAIL BRIDGE.
FIVE OH IN THE SENATE.
THREE OO IN THE ASSEMBLY NORTH
COAST RAIL AUTHORITY.
THREE ZERO IN THE ASSEMBLY FIVE
ON THE SENATE TRANSPORTATION
RESEARCH YOU SEE.
FIVE OH IN THE SENATE FIVE.
IN THE ASSEMBLY I CALTRANS
CONTRACTOR MANAGER GENERAL
CONTRACTOR AUTHORITY GOLDEN GATE
BRIDGE.
FOLLOW THE SENATE THREE OH IN
THE ASSEMBLY.
CALTRANS.
VENTURA COUNTY.
SIMILAR GUTHRIE ó IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
FIVE ALL IN THE SENATE THANK YOU
OPEN UNIFIED BUS SERVICE IF YOU
TRANSIT THREE OH IN THE ASSEMBLY.
FIVE ON THE SENATE THANK YOU.
WE ARE NOW MOVING TO.
START.
AND THE PERIMETER FENCE
PROVIDER FRIENDS ACTION I
POLITICS THANK YOU.
.
PROVIDER FENCE ACTIONS CENTERS.
NO I'M LOOKING FOR A VOTE.
IN THE ASSEMBLY IT'S FIVE OO IN
THE SENATE IT IS.
FOR ONE SENATOR MORE LOCK NO
THANK YOU ISSUE SIXTY HOUSING
AND HOMELESS.
THANK YOU WE SUPPORT THE
CONFERENCE COMPROMISE WHICH
INCLUDE SIX HUNDRED AND NINE
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN FOR
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS FOCUSED ON
ONE TIME BRIDGE FUNDING. AND
LOCAL FLEXIBILITY.
THESE INVESTMENTS BONTA THREE
PRIMARY CATEGORIES PLANNING
PREVENTION AND EMERGENCY AID. AS
PART OF THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IS PROVIDED IN EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN FOR A ONE TIME
HOMELESSNESS EMERGENCY AID BLOCK
GRANT. TO PROVIDE FLEXIBLE FUNDS
FOR JURISDICTIONS THAT DECLARE
SHELTER CRISIS AND COMMIT TO
LOCAL COORDINATION. THIS
INCLUDES THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION TO BE ALLOCATED THROUGH
CONTINUANCE OF CARE BASED ON
HOMELESS POINT IN TIME COUNTS
AND A HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
AND DIRECT ALLOCATIONS TO CITIES
WITH POPULATIONS OVER THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THOUSAND.
THE PACKAGE ALSO INCLUDES FIFTY
MILLION FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
INTENSIVE OUTREACH TREATMENT AND
RELATED SERVICES FOR HOMELESS
PERSONS IN NEED OF MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. AND ELEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES TO
FUND PROGRAMS FOCUSED ON YOUTH
AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
SURVIVORS.
THANK YOU.
SO WE GOT A MOTION A SECOND.
TO APPROVE AYE ISSUE SIXTY AND
WE HAVE.
I'M SORRY SIR OUT MISTER BLOOM
LIKE SPEAK OUT JUST VERY VERY
BRIEFLY I JUST WANT TO LAMENT
THE FACT THAT.
OF THIS FUNDING FALLS FAR SHORT
OF FOOD THE NEED THAT WE HAVE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA ON ONE
OF OUR MOST PRESSING.
ISSUES I UNDERSTAND WHY THAT'S
THE CASE BUT TO WE NEED TO FIND
A WAY TO DO BETTER.
THANK YOU.
OKAY.
THANK YOU WE HAVE FIVE OH.
IN THE SENATE THREE TWO IN THE
ASSEMBLY THANK YOU.
THIS YEAR SIXTY ONE TAX
PROVISIONS.
WE SUPPORT THAT CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSED TO EXPAND THE EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT TO FILERS
BETWEEN THE AGES OF EIGHTEEN AND
TWENTY FOUR AND OVER SIXTY FIVE
AND EXTENDS THE PHASE OUT RANGE
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN. TO THE
EQUIVALENT OF A FULL TIME JOB AT
THE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AT
MINIMUM WAGE RATE OF TWELVE
DOLLARS PER HOUR.
THIS IS ESTIMATED TO COST
SIXTEEN MILLION ANNUALLY. THE
ADMINISTRATION A PROPOSED THE
CALIFORNIA HIRING CREDIT AND WE.
ACCEPTS THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE THAT ADOPTS THE
ASSEMBLY POSITION TO EXTEND THE
CURRENT PROGRAM FOR FIVE YEARS.
LASTLY I WE SUPPORT THE TRIBAL
INCOME TAX EXEMPTION REVENUE
LOSSES ARE ESTIMATED AT ONE
POINT ONE MILLION PER YEAR
BEGINNING IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
THANK YOU SENATOR MORLOCK A MOVE
OTHER THIRD BULLET THE TRIBAL
INCOME TAX PARKING MOVING THE
TRIBAL INCOME TAX EXEMPTION
GUARD CARE SECOND.
TAKE A VOTE.
FIVE OH.
THE SENATE FIVE ON THE ASSEMBLY
THANK YOU.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION SORCERER
NIELSEN.
OKAY.
MIGHT BE HELPFUL TO THE SENATOR
TO KNOW THAT TO HOOK. UP OF
THOSE ITEMS ARE NOT ADOPTED AS
PART OF THE COMPROMISE SO YOU
VOTE I AM IN THIS YEAR.
SO THESE ARE CORRECT ME IF I.
DID THEY ARE OUT THERE AS
THERE'S NO ACTION TAKEN FOR
THOSE ITEMS.
YEAH MEANING THERE'S.
SO DON'T STORE WILL WORKABLE POP
TAKE DOCTOR MOTION.
WE'RE GOING TO VOTE ON
EVERYTHING ELSE.
THANK YOU.
S. WANTED TO.
ONE AND TWO IN THE BOTTOM WE
HAVE TO BE DO IF TAKE ACTION
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO RIVER CERTAIN
ACTION.
THE BOTTOM.
BECAUSE.
SAY SAY FOR CHILDCARE CREDIT
WERE ADOPTING SENATE VERSION
BECAUSE THE ASSEMBLY VERSION HAD
SOMETHING.
THE SENATE VERSION DID NOT JUST
FOR CLARIFICATION OKAY.
TO GET A VOTE.
THREE ONE AND ONE WITH MISTER
KILEY ABSTAINING THREE TWO IN
THE SENATE THANK YOU. ISSUE
SIXTY TWO CANNABIS.
WE SUPPORT THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE WHICH WOULD PROVIDE
TEN MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
TO THE BUREAU OF CANNABIS
CONTROL FOR GRANTS TO SUPPORT
LOCAL ACT.
THE KENTS AND LICENSEES WITHIN
LOCAL EQUITY PROGRAMS AND FOR
POSITIONS AND FOUR HUNDRED
EIGHTY THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS
CANNABIS CONTROL FUND FOR THE
BUREAU OF CANNABIS CONTROL. TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
LOCAL EQUITY APPLICANTS AND
LICENSEES TO NAVIGATE THE STATE
LICENSING PROCESS.
THANK YOU.
YOU GO GET SECOND.
SECOND THANK YOU GO GET A VOTE
ISSUE SIXTY TWO.
THREE ONE AND ONE WITH CENTER
MORE LUCK OF STANDING IN THE
SENATE THREE TWO IN THE ASSEMBLY
THANK YOU.
ISSUE SIXTY THREE LEGISLATIVE
REQUEST VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS.
THE ADMINISTRATION SUPPORTS
THESE VARIOUS ITEMS AS THEY FIT
WITHIN THE FRAMEWORK OF THE
BUDGET APPROVED BY THE
LEGISLATIVE LEADERSHIP.
I'D LIKE TO SEPARATE ITEM THREE
PUTS.
SEPARATE WHICH ONE.
I'D ITEM THREE.
I WE ME BUT SHOULD YOU WHAT YOU
WANT TO VOTE AND I WON FIRST OR
NOT.
BUT.
OKAY LET'S VOTE ON THE AUTISM.
.
CHICAGO IS MOVED TO THE CITY
FOURTH.
.
YEAH BREAKING BARRIERS IN AUTISM
WE'RE GONNA VOTE.
FIVE OH FIVE UP THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND TO APPROVE THE REMAINDER
OF THE.
THE SECOND.
SECOND THANK YOU.
FOR THE REMAINDER OF THE ITEMS.
MISTER CHAIR COULD YOU ALSO PULL
THE.
SECURE CHOICE RETIREMENT SAVINGS
INVESTMENT POURED IN THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL.
IF YOU WANT TO VOTE O THOSE ARE
YOU ARE YOU I'D LIKE TO SEPARATE
AT LEAST THE ARTS COUNCIL.
YEAH OKAY IF YOU'LL PULL THOSE
TO AND WE MAY WE CAN VOTE ON
THEIR BALLOTS. LOOKS LOOKS LET'S
VOTE ON THOSE.
SEPARATELY CAN HEARING TWO
DIFFERENT THINGS OKAY.
MOTION.
TO APPROVE FEE SECURE CHOICE.
SECOND
OKAY.
THREE TWO IN THE SENATE THREE
TWO IN THE ASSEMBLY THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL.
I AM SEEING THE THREE TWO IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND A FIVE OH IN THE
SENATE THANK YOU.
AND.
LET'S VOTE ON THE REMAINDER OF
THESE ITEMS.
FOUR ZERO IN THE ASSEMBLY WITH
MISTER KILEY ABSTAINING AND FOR
ONE WITH SENATOR BARLACH VOTING
NO.
THANK YOU.
ISSUE SIXTY FORGET MORE
MISCELLANEOUS ITEMS.
AB ONE A POLL CERTAIN ONES OR
VOTE ON CERTAIN ONCE ISSUE SIXTY
FOUR.
MR WORLD.
MISTER CHAIR COULD WE PLEASE
POLL THE STATE MANDATES.
CONFERENCE COMPROMISED REDUCE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
PAYMENT BY THIRTY ONE POINT
SEVEN MILLION AND THE CAL STIRS
REPORTING LANGUAGE.
OKAY.
THE.
.
THAT'S THE VERY BOTTOM WHAT.
OKAY AND THAT'S THE VERY BOTTOM
WHAT.
OKAY.
SO CAN I GET A MOTION TO APPROVE
THE REMAINING ITEMS BESIDES
THOSE THREE.
OKAY.
CAN WE VOTE ON THE REMAINING
ITEMS THAT AVE NOT BEEN PULLED.
WE HAVE OF FOUR ZERO WITH MISTER
KILEY ABSTAINING. AND WE HAVE
FOUR ZERO WITH SENATOR MORE LIKE
TO NOW.
WE WILL VOTE ON THE THREE ITEMS
THAT HAVE BEEN PULLED THE STATE
MANDATES THE CASTERS AND THE
PROP FIFTY SIX CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE.
THREE TWO IN THE ASSEMBLY.
THREE THE.
ITS ALL THREE OFTHEM TOGETHER
IN THE SHORT TO DO THEM
SEPARATELY STATE MANDATES.
CONFERENCE COMPROMISE CAL STORES
REPORTING LANGUAGE IN PROP FIFTY
SIX COMPLIMENTS COMPROMISE.
YOU'RE DOING ALL SEPARATE OKAY
LET'S LET'S VOTE ON STATE
MANDATES FIRST.
STATE MANDATES
THREE TWO IN THE ASSEMBLY.
THREE TWO IN THE SENATE THANK
YOU.
CALISTO IS REPORTING LANGUAGE.
THREE TWO IN THE ASSEMBLY.
TELSTRA'S REPORTING LANGUAGE.
THREE ONE AND ONE WAS CENTER
MARKET STANDING.
THE CONFERENCE COMPROMISE ON
PROP FIFTY SIX WAS CDFA.
THREE.
TWO IN THE SENATE.
FOUR ZERO IN THE ASSEMBLY WITH
MISTER KILEY ABSTAINING THANK
YOU.
ISSUE SIXTY FIVE STATE VETERANS
HOMES.
YES THERE ARE MORE LIKE.
WITH THE APPROPRIATE.
ISSUE MISSED
CHAIR TO DISCUSS THE.
NEW BE ONLY
THE.
EMPLOYEES THAT.
SHOULD BE EXEMPT
.
THAT WAS NOT AN ITEM A CONFLICT
OF COURSE YOU CAN. MAKE A MOTION
FOR THAT.
YEAH I JUST DID.
CAN I GET A SECOND.
OKAY A SECOND.
CAN WE GET A VOTE ON SENATOR
MARK CAN YOU RESTATE YOUR MOTION
SENATOR PLEASED THAT THE FIVE
MEMBERS OF THE. PARTIES FOR FIVE.
MEMBERS OF THE BOARD OF
EDUCATION THAT.
LEGALIZATION OF EQUALIZATION
SKILLS REYES RICHER TELEVEN
POCKETS OKAY ALTER THE DATA THAT
THEY HAVE UP TO RELEASED A
EXEMPT EMPLOYEE.
GREAT SO CENTER BALK IS
PROPOSING THAT EACH MEMBER OF
THE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION HAS
EIGHT EXEMPT EMPLOYEES.
SO WE HAVE OUR TO.
TWO THREE A.
AND ONE.
ONE THREE AND ONE ABSTENTION ON
THE ASSEMBLY WITH MISTER KILEY
INSTEAD.
THANKS AGAIN TO THREE IN THE
SENATE THANK YOU.
ISSUE SIXTY FIVE DAY VETERANS.
WE SUPPORT THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE WHICH WOULD ADOPT
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE AND TWO HUNDRED
FORTY ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS ON
GOING GENERAL FUND. FOR TWO
POSITIONS BEGINNING IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY TO SUPPORT
ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS FOR THE
MASTER PLAN.
ADDITIONALLY WE SUPPORT THE
SENATE VERSION. OF PROPOSED
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE REQUIRE
REPORTING ON LEASES AT THE
STATE'S VETERANS HOMES.
THANK YOU.
GO HERE VOTE.
SAY FIVE OH.
FIVE A THANK YOU.
ISSUE SIXTY SIX DEPARTMENT
VETERANS AFFAIRS VARIOUS
LEGISLATIVE INVESTMENTS.
WE SUPPORT THE CONFERENCE CALL
FROM COMPROMISE HOWEVER WE WOULD
KNOW THAT AND THERE'S A
CONFORMING ISSUE THE VETERANS
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
ONE MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING
FROM PROPOSITION SIXTY THREE WE
BELIEVE CONFORMS TO ISSUE NUMBER
TWENTY EIGHT.
ON WHICH WAS VOTED ON PREVIOUSLY
WE DO SUPPORT THE ASSEMBLY
ACTION TO PROVIDE ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND TO
THE ALAMEDA COUNTY VETERANS
SERVICES OFFICE.
I THINK YOU CAN GET A MOTION TO
APPROVE THE SECOND ITEM PALMER.
OKAY VOTE PLEASE.
FIVE OH BY THE THANK YOU.
ISSUE SIXTY SIX AGAIN DEPARTMENT
VETERANS AFFAIRS LATEST INVEST
OUTSIDE.
THAT'S THAT'S A SAME PITCH
EXCUSE ME ISSUE SIXTY SEVEN.
PRO RATA IN LEGISLATIVE
INVESTMENTS DEPARTMENT CONSUMER
AFFAIRS.
WE SUPPORT THE ASSEMBLY ACTION
WHICH APPROVED THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO
REDUCE THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS RESOURCES TWO
POINT THREE MILLION AND FIFTEEN
POSITIONS OVER THREE YEARS. THE
ASSEMBLY ALSO ADDED TWO
POSITIONS ON A LIMITED TERM
BASIS FOR THE DEPARTMENT TO
CONDUCT AN ORGANIZATIONAL CHANGE
MANAGEMENT REVIEW OF ITS
CENTRALIZED SERVICES.
ADDITIONALLY BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE WAS INCLUDED TO DIRECT
THE DEPARTMENT AND THE PRO RATA
WORK GROUP TO IDENTIFY AND
PRIORITIZE THE MOST CRITICAL
SERVICES TO BE REVIEWED. WITH
THE INTENT TO IDENTIFY
OPPORTUNITIES TO ACHIEVE THESE
EFFICIENCIES.
THANK YOU MISS DANIELS.
BRACKETS BULLET ON THE
TRANSCRIPT TRANSCRIPT
REIMBURSEMENT TO FROM THE OTHER
ITEM.
BUT VOTE IT VERY WELL
REIMBURSEMENT SO CAN YOU MOVE
ONE OF THOSE WHICH ARE REMOVED
FOR THE.
THE FIRST ITEM SIR MOVING TO
SENATOR USES MOVE IN THE FIRST
TIME.
THANK YOU HAVING A SECOND THANK
YOU.
WE HAVE FIVE ALL IN THE SENATE.
SO THIS IS THE FIRST BULLET.
DEPARTMENT CONSIDERS.
I FOR ONE IN THE ASSEMBLY WITH
MISTER COUNTY VOTING NO WE AT
FIVE OO IN THE SENATE CAN I GET
A MOTION TO APPROVE THE SECOND.
TRANSCRIPT REIMBURSEMENT FUND.
THANK YOU.
THREE TWO IN THE SENATE.
FOUR ZERO IN THE ASSEMBLY WITH
MISTER KILEY OF STATIC THANK YOU.
ISSUE SIXTY EIGHT AB ONE NINETY
FIVE.
SUSPENSION.
WE HAVE REACHED AGREEMENT WITH
THE LEGISLATURE TO PUT THIS
LANGUAGE INTO A TRAILER BILL
HOWEVER THE ADMINISTRATION IS
NOT PRESUPPOSING THIS IS AN
OUTCOME WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU. MISTER AND MISTER
SHARON MOVE THE SENATE ACTION.
WITH THE MOTION TO APPROVE THE
SENATE ACTION.
SUCK IT.
DO YOU A VOTE ON MISTER
OBERNOLTE IS.
WE HAVE TWO THREE IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
THIS IS TO.
SUPPORT MISTER OBERNOLTE MOTION.
WITH TO THREE IN THE ASSEMBLY WE
HAVE.
HOW MANY IN THE SENATE?
OKAY SO WE HAVE TO THREE IN THE
SENATE TWO THREE IN THE.
ASSEMBLY MEASURE FAILS.
NO WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT DOING
THAT.
WE ARE MOVING TO ISSUE SIXTY
NINE.
CYBERSECURITY
.
NO I.
WE ARE ON SIXTY NINE. AND
CYBERSECURITY.
THIS COST. WE SUPPORT THE
CONFERENCE COMPROMISE TO ADOPT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING
GENERAL FUND AND BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE FOR THE ESTABLISHMENT
OF THE OFFICE OF THE ELECTIONS.
CYBERSECURITY.
BUT WE ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT THE
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE WILL ENSURE
THAT THE SECRETARY OF STATE
CYBERSECURITY RESOURCES DON'T
LEAD TO DUPLICATION OR PARALLEL
STRUCTURES WHICH COULD LEAD TO
DIRECTIONS.
BEING PROVIDED TO ENTITIES THAT
IS CONTRARY TO INFORMATION BEING
PROVIDED BY THE EXISTING LEAD
AGENCIES WHICH INCLUDE THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY
MILITARY OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES IN THE CHP.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR MOTION TO
APPROVE.
THANK YOU.
WE HAVE ABOUT FIVE OO IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND WE HAVE THREE TWO
IN THE SENATE THANK YOU.
ISSUE SEVENTY LANGUAGE FOR
COUNTY VOTING SYSTEMS FUNDING.
WE SUPPORT THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE ON AYE WHICH ADOPTS
MODIFY TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO
GUIDE THE EXPENDITURES OF THESE
FUNDS. BOTH HOUSES APPROVED THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL FOR
ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOUR
POINT THREE MILLION GENERAL FUND
FOR THE PURCHASE OR LEASE. OF
ALLOWABLE VOTING SYSTEMS AND
TECHNOLOGIES AND ALL FORTY EIGHT
COUNTIES. THIS PROPOSAL SEEMS
THE STATE AND COUNTIES WILL
SHARE FIFTY PERCENT OF THE
ESTIMATED COST OF REPLACEMENT
AND ALL COUNTIES WITH FIFTY OR
MORE PRECINCTS. A WILL ADOPT THE
VOTE CENTER MODEL AUTHORIZED
UNDER S. B. FIVE FOUR FIFTY THE
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE ALSO GUIDE THE
EXPENDITURE OF THESE FUNDS.
THANK YOU.
GO GET A MOTION AND A SECOND.
THANK YOU SECOND.
OKAY KELLY CAPITAL OUT.
THREE TWO IN THE SENATE.
FOUR ZERO IN THE ASSEMBLY WITH
MISTER KILEY EXTENT.
ISSUE SEVENTY ONE PRECISION
MEDICINE.
WE SUPPORT THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISED WHICH WOULD APPROVE
THIRTY MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND FOR ADDITIONAL PRECISION
MEDICINE DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS.
AND MAINTAIN THE EXISTING
GOVERNMENT STRUCTURE WHEN THEN
THE OFFICE OF PLANNING AND
RESEARCH.
THANK YOU CLEAR SECOND.
SOURCE CENTER NIELSEN THAT
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO DIVIDE THE
QUESTION.
AS TO THE.
CONFERENCE
LANGUAGE THERE ABOUT THE
CREATION OF AN EIGHT THE USE OF
THE BUREAUCRACY TO ADMINISTER
I'D LIKE TO HAVE A SEPARATE VOTE
ON THAT THE FUNDING WITH ANYONE
THAT THE SENATE DID NOT.
.
IT'S A CONCERTED NOT BIFURCATE.
IF I MAY SENATOR NELSON THE
ACTION BEFORE YOU KEEP THE
EXISTING STRUCTURE THAT'S IN THE
CURRENT YEAR WHICH IS PLACE WHEN
THEN THE OFFICE OF PLANNING AND
RESEARCH THE I'M ITEM BEFORE YOU
DOESN'T CREATE A NEW ENTITY.
THANK YOU FOR THAT CLARIFICATION
SENATOR AND THIS COSTA.
SO WE ARE WE DO HAVE A MOTION
SECOND TO ADOPT THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE.
THREE TWO.
THREE ONE THREE TWO IN THE
SENATE THREE ONE AND ONE WITH MR
KHALID STANDING IN THE ASSEMBLY
THANK YOU.
ISSUE SEVENTY TWO CENSUS OUT
REACH.
WE SUPPORT THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE WHICH INCREASE
INVESTMENTS IN THE BUDGET YEAR
SHIFT THE STATE CENSUS OUTREACH
EFFORT TO THE GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS AGENCY TO ENHANCE
EFFECTIVENESS OF GOVERNANCE AND
ADMINISTRATION. AND APPROVED
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE WITH
SUPPLEMENTAL RECORDING REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS.
IN THIS COMPROMISE WE RECOMMEND
APPROVING A TOTAL OF NINETY
POINT THREE MILLION GENERAL FUND
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
AVAILABLE FOR THE DURATION OF
THE THREE YEAR AFTER. FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS
THE COMPROMISE INCLUDES SHIFTING
THE CENSUS OUTREACH EFFORT TO
THE GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY
WHICH OVERSEES MUCH OF THE STATE
EXPERTISE AND CONTRACTING
TECHNOLOGY AND PERSONNEL.
THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A MOTION TO APPROVE THE
COMPROMISE OKAY THREE TWO IN THE
SENATE.
FOR ONE IN THE ASSEMBLY WITH
MISTER KILEY NO.
ISSUE SEVENTY THREE.
REFERRED LIMITED STATE OFFICE
BUILDING WE SUPPORT THE
CONFERENCE COMPROMISE.
IT WOULD PROVIDE THREE HUNDRED
AND FIVE MILLION GENERAL FUND
FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE NEEDS
REPORTED BY DEPARTMENT STATEWIDE
THIS PROPOSAL WILL ALLOW
DEPARTMENTS TO ADDRESS THE
SIGNIFICANT BACKLOG OF STATEWIDE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE ACROSS
TWENTY DEPARTMENTS.
WE ALSO SUPPORT THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE TO INCLUDE A TRANSFER
OF SIX HUNDRED AND THIRTY
MILLION FROM THE GENERAL FUND TO
THE STATE PROJECT INFRASTRUCTURE
FUND.
THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND TO
APPROVE THE COMPROMISE.
WE HAVE A VOTE.
THREE TWO IN THE ASSEMBLY FIVE
OH IN THE SENATE THANK YOU.
ISSUE SEVENTY FOUR RESERVE
ACCOUNTS.
I MENTIONED EACH OF THESE
RESERVE ACCOUNTS IN MY OPENING
COMMENTS ON ISSUE ONE WE SUPPORT
BOTH THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THE
BUDGET DEFICIT SAVINGS ACCOUNT
AS A.
HAVE THE SAFETY NET RESERVE
ACCOUNT
WHICH NOW INCLUDES AN INITIAL
DEPOSIT OF FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS.
THINK YOU COULD GET A VOTE ASIDE
MISTER WINANT.
I JUST LIKE TO BRIEFLY SAY IT
ONCE AGAIN THAT. THERE IS NO
LIMIT ON THE AMOUNT OF MONEY WE
CAN PUT IN THE SPECIAL FUND FOR
ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTY.
SO THE ONLY REASON FOR CREATING.
A THIRD TYPE OF ACCOUNT THE
BUDGET DEFICIT SAVINGS ACCOUNT
WOULD BE TO AVOID. LOWERING THE
STATE SALES TAX RATE WHICH WILL
HAPPEN AUTOMATICALLY IF WE PUT
MORE MONEY IN THE US AFTER
YOU'VE SO. POPULAR REASON I POSE
THIS I THINK THAT IT'S
APPROPRIATE TO. OFFER THE PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA TO TO SHARE IN THAT
TAX SAVINGS.
THANK YOU SIR MORLOCK.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
I'D LIKE TO HAVE.
MISS COST TO REBUT THAT REMARK.
I'VE OFTEN TESTIFIED THAT WE
BELIEVE IN PRUDENT FISCAL
RESERVES.
I'VE TESTIFIED PREVIOUSLY BEFORE
THIS BODY THAT WE BELIEVE THE
SENATE'S PROPOSAL CERTAINLY HAS
MERIT WHICH WOULD PROVIDE A
RESERVE FUND FOR SOME OF OUR
SOCIAL PROGRAMS. THAT FREQUENTLY
HAVE CASELOAD INCREASES DURING A
RECESSION WHEN WERE OFTEN FACE
WITH CUTTING THOSE PROGRAMS. IN
A SIMILAR VEIN WE SUPPORT THE
ASSEMBLY PROPOSAL WHICH WOULD
PROVIDE A HOLDING ACCOUNT OF
SORTS FOR THE BSA TRANSFER. ON
INTEL WE KNOW BASED ON TRUE UP
THE TOTAL AMOUNT NEEDED FOR THAT
DEPOSIT.
THEN.
STATEMENT
MADE THAT.
TING UP A SEPARATE
WOULD.
MAYBE I'LL A LOOPHOLE OR IN
AROUND OR WHATEVER FOR THE SALES
TAX.
TERMINATION COMPONENT OF WHAT
THEY GOES PROPERTY FIVE SO I
JUST.
CHRIS IS THAT ACCURATE.
I CAN'T SPEAK TO THE INTENT OF
THE LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS I CAN
ONLY TELL YOU WE SUPPORT ROBUST
RESERVES AND THE INCLUSION OF
TWO ADDITIONAL SOMETHING THE
ADMINISTRATION SUPPORTS.
WELL YOU CAN OPEN A.
COUNT ON YOUR CHART OF ACCOUNTS
EMIL TIME I'M.
.
CHOMSKY I'M JUST TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT BECAUSE I WANT
RESERVES.
I'M WITH YOU BUT I BUT I WANT TO
BE HONEST. AT LEAST BE ABLE TO
TELL TAXPAYERS WHAT WE'RE DOING.
I WOULD KNOW THAT BOTH OF THESE
RESERVE FUNDS DO INCLUDE DEPOSIT
MECHANIZATION SO I DON'T THINK
IT'S JUST SOMETHING THAT'S ON
THE CHART OF ACCOUNTS THERE'S
ACTUALLY DOLLARS ASSOCIATED WITH
EACH.
ADOPTED RESERVE AS PART OF THE
BUDGET.
WE HAVE A DIFFERENCE OF OPINION.
THANK YOU SIR NIELSEN.
ON THIS QUITE AS SOMEBODY WHO
WORK FOR SO MANY YEARS FOR.
PROP TWO.
THE RESERVE.
I'M.
A LITTLE RESERVED ABOUT.
CREATING A WHOLE.
BUNCH OF NEW LITTLE.
RESERVE FOR WHATEVER PURPOSE AND
THERE WILL BE NO LIMITATION ON
THE NUMBER OF PURPOSES THAT
SOMEBODY'S GOING TO FIGURE OUT
FOR SOME SORT OF RESERVE.
PROSPECTIVELY.
THAT COULD THEN BECOME A BIT OF
A PROBLEM ALMOST LIKE THE GROWTH
OF COLORS OVER THE DECADES HAS
BEEN.
IF WE'RE GOING TO PROCEED DOWN
THIS PATH I WOULD REQUEST OF
FINANCE AND THE LEGISLATURE'S
WELL TO CONSIDER.
SOME OF THE PARAMETERS
THE CREATION OF THESE
RESERVE ACCOUNT.
IF WE DON'T IT'S JUST GONNA BE
WILLING LA AND THEY'RE GOING TO
BE ALL OVER THE PLACE AND WOULD
BE FILL IN THESE BUCKETS FROM
ALL COHEN'S KINDS OF SOURCES.
AND THEY WILL BE CREATIVELY
FOUND THE.
.
THE KIND OF INTERESTING WAY THAT
WE NOW DESIGNATE FEES AND
DIRECTLY EAST OF THINGS.
WELL I'M AFRAID THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO.
BURGEONING.
AND BUST
SO. I WAX CAUTIOUS
ON THIS IDEA.
THANK YOU.
WE GET A MOTION AND A SECOND TO
APPROVE.
THANK YOU CAN GET A VOTE.
THREE ONE AND ONE WITH A CENTER
BARLACH ABSTAINING.
AND THREE TWO IN THE ASSEMBLY.
THANK YOU.
FISHER SEVENTY FIVE FINANCIAL
INFORMATION SYSTEM FOR
CALIFORNIA. DISCOUNT.
WE SUPPORT THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE WHICH ADOPTS
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING LANGUAGE
REQUIRING THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TO PROVIDE A LIST OF
APPROVED BUDGET PROPOSALS.
RELATED DEFECTS CALS INTEGRATED
SOLUTION THE STATE CONTROLLER
OFFICES LEGACY SYSTEM RETIREMENT
AND MAINTENANCE COSTS.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR MORLOCK.
SURE AT LAST COUNT WE SPENT NINE
HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
ON THIS CALLER WE AT THE ONE
BILLION MARK AT.
HIS THEIR MISS KOSTER TO WE HAVE
A EXPENSE FOR FISCAL.
OR FINANCE.
EVELYN SHOULD DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE OUT WE ARE STILL WITHIN
OUR PROJECTED.
AT NIGHT HER IN THIRTY IN NOT
IMMIGRANT THIRTY MILLION AND
PROJECT COSTS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION TO HAVE A
SECOND TO APPROVE.
GO GET A VOTE ON FISCAL.
FIVE OH IN THE ASSEMBLY.
FIVE LOW IN THE SENATE THANK YOU.
IF YOU'RE SEVENTY SIX YOU THREE
INVESTMENT FUND ADULT REENTRY
AND DIVERSION.
WE SUPPORT THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE THIS LEGISLATIVE
REQUEST PROVIDES A ONE TIME
EIGHTY SEVEN POINT THREE MILLION
GENERAL FUND AUGMENTATION TO THE
BOARD OF STATE AND COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS.
TO ADMINISTER COMPETITIVE GRANT
PROGRAMS TO SUPPORT TRAUMA
INFORMED COMMUNITY BASED AND
HEALTH BASED INTERVENTIONS FOR
YOUTH.
AND RE ENTRY HOUSING IN
TRANSITION PROGRAMS FOR
OFFENDERS FORMALLY INCARCERATED
IN STATE PRISON.
THANK YOU CENTER NIELSEN.
EXPERIENCE CHAIRMAN.
.
DIRECTED ACOSTA.
DO YOU MAYOR MAY NOT HAVE THE
INFORMATION.
BUT.
AND THIS BILL LANGUAGE WILL
THERE BE ANY DEFINITION OF WHAT
CONSTITUTES DIVERSION AND WHAT
WILL BE THE CONDITIONS OF
DIVERSION.
A DIVERSION HAS SORT OF GONE
FROM BEING A SYSTEM OF KIND OF
REGULATED AND CONTROLLED.
REHABILITATION.
TO BE AND ALSO WAY.
OPEN DOOR OUT.
DIVERSION MEANING.
I WON'T GET INTO SPECIFICS OF
IT BUT WILL THERE BE IT ANY IS
THERE ANY KIND OF CRITERIA OF.
WHAT DO VERSION WILL CONSTITUTE?
WILL THEY HAVE TO GO INTO A FOR
EXAMPLE A LOCAL PROGRAM AND THEN
IF THEY DO NOT OBEY THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE PROGRAM WILL
THERE BE SOME KIND OF A SANCTION.
FOR. NOT.
BEING IN THE PROGRAM OR WALKING
AWAY FROM THE PROGRAM WILL THERE
BE A SET PERIOD OF TIME OF THE
DIVERSION.
WHAT ARE THE CONDITIONS ARE DO
WE KNOW?
JOSH DUGGAR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO WE'RE STILL WORKING
THROUGH THE FINAL LANGUAGE ON
SOME OF THESE PIECES BUT IN
TERMS OF THE TRAUMA IN FOREIGN
DIVERSION PROGRAMS FOR MINORS.
AND THE FUNDING IS INTENDED TO
BE ALLOCATED TO JURISDICTIONS
WITH HIGH RATES OF JUVENILE
ARRESTS.
FOR MISDEMEANORS STATUS
OFFENSES AND IT'S REALLY TO BE
FOCUSED ON EVIDENCE BASED OR
RESEARCH SUPPORTED TRAUMA
INFORMED. CULTURALLY RELEVANT
AND DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE
A SERVICES AND ALTERNATIVES TO A
RASTER INCARCERATION. AND AND
NINETY PERCENT OF THE FUNDING IS.
ENVISIONED WOULD GO TO AND NON
GOVERNMENTAL COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND TEN PERCENT OF
THE FUNDING WOULD BE TO
COORDINATE WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES AND. A SOCIAL SERVICES
AGENCY SO I DO THINK THAT
THERE'S ON. ALL THE INTENT THERE
TO PROVIDE THE THE I'M FRAMEWORK
AROUND THE LANGUAGE THAT BUILDS
AND SOME OF THE ACCOUNTABILITY
AND.
EVIDENCE BASED RESEARCH THAT
THAT YOU WOULD WANT AND THESE
TYPES OF PROGRAMS.
THANK YOU AND I HAVE TO SEE THE
LANGUAGE BEFORE COULD VOTE
THOUGH.
THANK YOU.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION TO APPROVE
A OF A SECOND.
ISSUE SIX SEVENTY SIX.
THREE ZERO IN THE SENATE FOUR
ZERO IN THE ASSEMBLY THAT MR
COMMUNISTIC THANK YOU.
ISSUE SEVENTY SEVEN JUDICIAL
COUNCIL.
WE SUPPORT THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE WHICH APPROVES THE
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
DISCRETIONARY FUNDING FOR THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL AND BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE EXPRESSING. LA THAT
INTENT OF THE LEGISLATURE THAT
TEN MILLION DOLLARS BE USED TO
INCREASE THE LEVEL OF COURT
REPORTERS IN FAMILY LAW CASES
AND NOT SUPPLANT EXISTING TRIAL
COURT EXPENDITURES.
THANK YOU.
THE MOTION.
GOV MOTION BECAUSE SECOND THANK
YOU.
ISSUE SERVICE OF.
FOUR ZERO WITH MISTER KILEY OF
STAINING FIVE ON THE SENATE
THANK YOU.
ISSUE SEVEN DID TRIAL COURT
CAPITAL OUTLAY.
WE SUPPORT THE SENATE VERSION
WHICH AUTHORIZES ONE POINT THREE
BILLION AND LEASE REVENUE BONDS
BACKED BY THE GENERAL FUND.
FOR THE IDENTIFIED PROJECTS AND
ADOPT TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
REQUIRING THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
TO CONDUCT AN ASSESSMENT OF ALL
THE REMAINING TRIAL COURT
PROJECTS AND SUBMIT A FUND
CONDITIONS STATEMENT WITH ANY
NEW INFRASTRUCTURE PROPOSALS.
THANK YOU.
WE GET A SECOND FACTOR THANK YOU.
WE GET A VOTE SENATE.
FINAL.
FOR.
WITH MISTER KILEY OF STANDING
IN THE ASSEMBLY.
ISSUE SEVEN ON MY PALETTE FOR
TRAFFIC ADJUDICATIONS AND
DRIVER'S LICENSE SUSPENSIONS AND
FAILURE TO APPEAR.
WE SUPPORT THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE WHICH IS TO APPROVE
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSED
ONGOING FUNDING FOR THE ONLINE
PILOT FOR TRAFFIC ADJUDICATIONS.
AND APPROVED REVISED TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE THAT IMPLEMENTS AN
ONLINE AT ADJUDICATION PILOT
PROGRAM TO BEGIN MOVING TOWARD A
CIVIL MODEL MODEL FOR EDUCATION
OF MINOR TRAFFIC VIOLATIONS.
EXPANDING UPON ON LINE ABILITY
TO PAY EFFORTS THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL BEGAN WITH FIVE PILOT
COURTS FUNDED BY THE US
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE GRANTS.
SERVICE.
I'D LIKE TO SPLIT THE
NO MISTER CHAIRMAN THE ITEM
NUMBER ONE MAY HAVE MERIT BUT
I'M A LITTLE CONCERNED ABOUT THE.
.
ON THAT AUTOMATIC.
CUT OF EIGHTY PERCENT OKAY THAT
MAY OR MAY NOT BE CORRECTED IF
WE DISABILITIES SISTER WANT TO
MOVE TO APPROVE ONE OF THOSE.
YEAH I WOULD MOVE THE NUMBER
TWO ITEM.
THE THEY REVISION THE DRIVER'S
LICENSE SUSPENSION VERY GOOD
HERE CLOSE A MOTION TO APPROVE
THAT.
TAKE A SECOND BETWEEN ME OKAY.
SO I CLARIFICATION BECAUSE SHE'S
ADD JUST ONE CLARIFICATION THE
FINAL CONFERENCE COMPROMISE
INCLUDES THE TOOL.
SUGGESTING A RECOMMENDED FIFTY
PERCENT REDUCTION RATHER THAN
THE EIGHTY PERCENT AND TO THE.
ACTUAL REDUCTION WOULD STILL BE
SUBJECT TO JUNE A JUDICIAL
DISCRETION WHICH COULD GO IN
EITHER DIRECTION WELL I'LL JUST
GROUP WITHDRAW. QUESTIONS AND
SIMPLY NOT VOTE BUT.
THAT THAT THIS IS.
GOOD.
INFORMATION BUT NOT SUFFICIENT
FOR ME.
THANK YOU WEEK WE GET A MOTION
TO APPROVE BOTH ITEMS OKAY.
THANK YOU VOTE ON THE COMPROMISE
FIVE OH IN THE ASSEMBLY.
FOR WHAT.
WHAT WOULD WE DO BOTH TOGETHER?
ALTOGETHER.
THREE ONE AND ONE IN THE SENATE
WAS CENTER NIELSEN ABSTAINING IN
CENTER MORE LOCKED VOTING NOW.
ISSUE EIGHTY JUDGESHIPS. WE
SUPPORT THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE WHICH WOULD PROVIDE.
.
I BELIEVE AROUND FOUR MILLION ON
GOING FOR TO JUDGESHIPS AND
RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND TRAILER
BILL BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE ONE
POINT TWO MILLION GENERAL FUND
ON GOING. ON EXCUSE ME THREE
POINT TWO MILLION ON GOING FOR
TO JUDGESHIPS AND THE NEW A PUBLIC COURT
JUSTICE.
AN ACCOMPANYING STAFF IN THE
SECOND DIVISION OF THE FOURTH
DISTRICT COURT OF APPEALS IN SAN
BERNARDINO RIVERSIDE.
TEN MILLION ONGOING GENERAL FUND
TO THE EQUAL ACCESS FUND
BEGINNING IN FISCAL YEAR
NINETEEN TWENTY.
THINK IT WAS BECAUSE I JUST
CRIED FIVE THREE POINT TWO
MILLION ON GOING FOR TO CORONA
COURT JUDGESHIPS CORRECT YES I
WAS I AM ADDING THE THREE POINT
TWO IN THE ONE POINT TWO SO I
APOLOGIZE.
I'M SORRY.
I APOLOGIZE.
CORRECT SO COULD YOU SAY TO GET
A BIPARTISAN ABSOLUTELY THERE'S
TWO ITEMS THREE POINT TWO
MILLION ONGOING FOR TO
JUDGESHIPS IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
WITH ACCOMPANYING TRAILER BILL
IN BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE ONE
POINT TWO MILLION GENERAL FUND
ON GOING TO FIND A NEW APPELLATE
COURT JUSTICE AND THE
ACCOMPANYING STAFF IN THE SECOND
DIVISION OF THE FOURTH DISTRICT
COURT OF APPEAL AND SAN
BERNARDINO RIVERSIDE.
CEREBRAL.
IT'S A MEMORABLE CAN REFER TO IT.
POINT TWO MILLION.
TWO JUDGES.
IN THIS.
AND AN INCH AND CORONA COURT.
THAT'S WHAT THEY RIVERSIDE
COUNTY.
SO IF THE RIVERSIDE.
COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT SALON I'M
GETTING CORONA COURT JUDGESHIPS
IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY BUT JUST TO.
SO IT A JUDGE COST ONE POINT SIX
MILLION A YEAR.
AND THERE LOOK RELATED STAFF.
YES JUST TO CLARIFY ITS IS NOT
JUST A SINGLE JUDGE ABOUT
PARTNER HOLDEN JUST NONE OF THAT
SO SOBRE CLARIFYING.
THE SINGLE JUDGE PLUS ADDITIONAL
STAFF ALL THE STUFF THAT COMES
WITH THAT COURT ROOM. TO THINK
OF IT IS TO COURT ROOMS TO LOSE
TWO AND ONE STAFF TO DO ONE MORE
POINT TWO MILLION FOR THE
APPELLATE COURT.
CORRECT SO IT'S FOUR POINT FOR
ALL TOGETHER.
YES THANK YOU.
MISTER WINANT.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THESE
JUDICIAL RESOURCES ARE BADLY
NEEDED I THINK THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL CURRENTLY ESTIMATES THAT.
STATEWIDE WE NEED MORE THAN A
HUNDRED EIGHTY ADDITIONAL JUDGES
JUST TO MEET THE CURRENT MADE
AND IT'S GOING TO GET EVEN WORSE.
BOB HOWEVER I HAVE A CONCERN
THAT WE ARE VIOLATING LONG
STANDING LEGISLATIVE PRACTICE
HERE IN.
EARMARKING THOSE TWO JUDGES FOR
A SINGLE COURTHOUSE IN A SINGLE
COUNTY. AND WHAT WE'VE DONE IN
THE PAST WE HAD JUDGES AS WE LET
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL ALLOCATE
THEM ACCORDING TO THE JUDICIAL
NEEDS ASSESSMENT AND THAT
PREVENTS.
JUDGE SHIPS FROM BEING A
POLITICAL FOOTBALL SO I LIKE TO
MAKE A MOTION THAT WE APPROVE
THIS REQUEST BUT WE ALLOCATE
THOSE JUDGESHIPS.
ACCORDING TO THE JUDICIAL NEEDS
ASSESSMENT AS WE HAVE DONE IN
THE PAST.
OKAY WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND LISTENER MORLOCK.
I APOLOGIZE MISTER CHAIR I JUST
THE MYTHOLOGY THAT SIR IF IF IF
AN APPELLATE COURT JUDGE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY COSTS ONE POINT
TWO MILLION.
THAT IS WHY WE.
BUT BUT BUT IT BETTER THIS APP
AS SUPERIOR COURT JUDGE COSTS
ONE POINT SIX.
SO IF WE APPROVE THREE POINT SIX
MILLION IS AT A. THREE POINT TWO
MILLION COULD WE GET THREE
JUDGES I DON'T A PROSPEROUS
FUNDS CAN ANSWER QUESTIONS.
SO A PART OF THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE TWO COSTS AND THERE
THERE'S DIFFERENT AS I GUESS YOU
COULD ALL STANDARD COMPLIMENTS
THAT COME WITH EACH.
TYPE OF JUDGESHIP SO THE THE
ONE POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS OF
FOR THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY
JUDGESHIPS.
ALSO INCLUDES A BAILIFF FOR
EXAMPLE WHICH IT DRIVES AN
ADDITIONAL COSTS OVER AT FOR
EXAMPLE THE ONE POINT TWO
MILLION THAT YOU'RE REFERENCING
FOR THE APPELLATE COURT JUSTICE
SO THAT'S KIND OF ONE OF THE
MAIN MAIN DRIVERS OF THE COST
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE TWO IF
THAT'S HELPFUL.
IT'S HELPFUL.
YOU THINK YOU SO WE DO HAVE.
OF MISTER OBERNOLTE IS A MOTION
TO APPROVE THE ITEMS BETWEEN NOT
YOUR MARK THE TWO JUDGES IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY CRACKED INTO
GIVEN TO JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO.
APPROPRIATE.
BASED ON THEIR FORMING.
ASSEMBLY IS TWO THREE SENATE IS
TWO THREE.
THAT MOTION FAILS CRY GET A
MOTION TO APPROVE.
I'M SORRY I'M SORRY.
STATE
TO TO IN THE SENATE WAS.
.
SENATOR ROTH EXCUSE ME
A CENTER ROTHSTEIN.
I GET A MOTION TO APPROVE ITEM
HAS. COMFORT COMPROMISE.
I GET A SECOND.
OKAY.
WE HAVE
FOUR ZERO IN THE ASSEMBLY FIVE
OH IN THE SENATE THANK YOU.
OFFICIALLY HE WON A AGAIN
JUDICIAL PRINCIPLES.
THERE ARE VARIOUS ITEMS HERE SO
GO BETWEEN THE HOUSE IS A LITTLE
BIT HELPING DON'T CONFUSE THE
MATTER ON THE COURT REPORTERS
THIS IS CONFORMING TO THE
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR G.
DISCRETIONARY FUNDING FOR THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL THAT I JUST
TESTIFIED ABOUT PREVIOUSLY. WE
SUPPORT ASSEMBLY VERSION FOR
TRIAL COURT TRUST FUND REVENUE
SHORTFALL WE SUPPORT THE
ASSEMBLY VERSION. FOR DEFERRAL
OF SENTENCE SENTENCING WE
SUPPORT THE ASSEMBLY VERSION FOR
COURTS ON ITS BUDGET ADJUSTMENT
WE SUPPORT THE ASSEMBLY VERSION
AND FOR INDIAN CHILD WELFARE ACT
WE SUPPORT THE SENATE.
SELECT.
APOLOGIZE AGAIN MISTER CHAIR.
ON.
PREVIOUS ISSUE NUMBER EIGHTY.
WAS THE TEN MILLION FOR THE
EQUAL ACCESS FUND INCLUDED IN
THE VOTES FOR THE JUDGES.
YES IT WAS.
WOULD YOU CHANGE ME FROM AYE TO
A NO ENTIRE.
SO AN ISSUE EIGHTY ARE CENTER
MORE LIKE LIKE TO GO FROM AN EYE
TO A NO THANK YOU MISTER. THANK
YOU.
ISSUE ANYONE.
THE MOTION SECOND.
THANK YOU.
VOTE.
FIVE LOW IN THE SENATE.
THREE OH IN THE ASSEMBLY THANK
YOU.
IT'S YOU READY TO.
IS THERE VARIOUS EMERGENCY
RESPONSE ITEMS WE SUPPORT THE
SENATE VERSION OF THE EARLY AT
THE EARTHQUAKE EARLY WARNING
PROPOSAL WE SUPPORT.
ACTUALLY OUR OWN PROPOSAL ON
THE EMERGENCY RESPONSE
OPERATIONS WHICH INCLUDES ONE
POINT SIX MILLION GENERAL FUND
AND EIGHT POSITIONS IN EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN AND ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION GENERAL FUND ON GOING.
TO SUPPORT SPECIFIC PROGRAMMATIC
NEEDS TO MEET THE INCREASING
DEMANDS OF EMERGENCIES IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND WE SUPPORT THE CONFERENCE
CALL FOR MY APPROVED TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE RELATED TO THE
DISASTER RESPONSE EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS ACCOUNT.
THANK YOU.
REGULAR.
SENATE IS FIVE OUT.
ASSEMBLY FIVE THANK YOU.
I'M ISSUE EIGHTY ONE.
SENATOR SKINNER WOULD LIKE TO GO
FROM AYE TO AN ABSTAINED.
DOES THAT CHANGE THE VOTE.
THE CHANGE THE.
I ISSUE A THREE.
WE HAVE A CONFERENCE COMPROMISED
THE VARIOUS I LEGISLATIVE
PROPOSALS IN THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES THIS INCLUDES
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
MUTUAL AID RESOURCES WHICH WOULD
PROVIDE FUNDING TO REIMBURSE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO THE MUTUAL
AID SYSTEM. FOR ACOSTA PRE
POSITIONED RESOURCES IN HIGH
RISK AREAS PRIOR TO THE ONSET OF
EXTREME WEATHER CONDITIONS.
TEN MILLION DOLLARS TO PROVIDE
FUNDING TO SUPPORT SERVICES FOR
INDIVIDUALS IMPACTED BY DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND SEXUAL ASSAULT.
CIVIC WE FIVE MILLION IS FOR THE
FAMILY VIOLENCE PREVENTION
PROGRAM AND FIVE MILLION IS FOR
THE RAPE CRISIS PROGRAM.
THANK YOU.
SOUTHERN ROCK.
COMMISSION CHAIR FOR THE
SENATE'S VERSION OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING SERVICE
SAYS.
WHO?
IT MIGHT ASSUME THAT THERE'S NO
DOLLAR AMOUNT THERE THEN THE
DOLLAR AMOUNT IS ZERO CORRECT.
THE LAST THREE BULLETS THE
DOLLAR AMOUNT IS ZERO.
SO NIELSEN.
I'D LIKE TO.
COULD YOU RESTATE THAT CENTER
NIELSEN.
ALL.
SO SEVEN EIGHT NINE HAVE ZERO
DOLLAR FIGURE SO COOLEY.
FLUNK THOSE TOGETHER INTO
WHATEVER YOU'RE DOING.
THOSE ALL HAVE ZERO DOLLARS.
I AM SURE.
NO NO FOR SEVEN EIGHT NINE.
OKAY CAN YOU SAY WHAT YOU'RE
SEVEN SEVEN IS.
QUEST WAS CHAIRMAN WEST.
MAKE A MOTION.
ON ONE.
TO.
FOR COULD YOU STATE WHAT THOSE
ARCS I THINK WHAT PROBLEMS WE
HAVE DIFFERENT VERSIONS OF THE
TEN MILLION FOR DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SEXUAL ASSAULT.
COMPROMISED FIVE MILLION
INTERNET CRIMES.
THE ASSEMBLY VERSION FAMILY
JUSTICE
SENATORS.
THE ASSEMBLY VERSION OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE HOUSING PROGRAM.
THE TWENTY FIVE MILLION IN THE
RESOURCE FOR MUTUAL AID AND THE
CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY CENTER I
WOULD MOVE THOSE ITEMS OKAY
THANK YOU.
LET'S TAKE A VOTE ON THOSE ITEMS.
YOU CAN'T CAN STOP REPEAT WHAT
WE'RE VOTING ON.
THREE FIVE AND SEVEN WOULD BE
THE ITEMS.
A SEPARATE VOTE.
THAT'S JUST
VOTE.
WE'RE GOING TO RECESS FOR A
MINUTE JUST TO CLARIFY THIS
THANK YOU
WATER RECESSING WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE ON.
THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME VOTE
CHANGES ON ISSUE FORTY SIX.
HOLD ON.
ISSUE FORTY SIX WE ARE
.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA WE'RE GONNA
HOLD ON FOR A SECOND TO TAKE UP
A CHANGE OKAY IT'S OKAY.
WHERE WE'LL DO THAT WHEN OUR?
OUR SECRETARY BECAUSE BACK
FOR A VOTE CHANGE ON ISSUE.
ISSUE FORTY SIX.
ARE YOU A SPLIT IT OUT.
I'M SORRY
OKAY.
SO WHICH WHICH I DON'T DO IT.
OKAY ON THE UNIFORM HOLIDAY
SCHEDULE ISSUE FORTY SIX WE HAVE
A VOTE CHANGE.
OBERNOLTE NO TO YES.
KILEY NO TO YES.
THANK YOU
OKAY WE ARE COMING BACK. TO LIVE.
OKAY ISSUE EIGHTY THREE ON GOING
ON TIMEOUT
WE'RE BACK.
ISSUE EIGHTY THREE.
CENTER SKINNER.
THANK YOU SO SINCE WE ARE VOTING
ON THESE NOW IN.
BATCHES
STATE OF AS A WHOLE.
JUST WANTED TO EXPRESS THAT.
THE.
.
THE ITEM ON HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
IT WAS A.
MY I CERTAINLY DIDN'T HEAR IT
BUT IT WAS A TWO PART ITEM.
AND.
ONE PART WAS.
FUNDING FOR SOMETHING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAD HAD FUNDED IN
THE PAST
ADMINISTERED BY THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES. THAT
PROVIDES GRANTS TO OUR
ORGANIZATIONS UP AND DOWN THE
STATE THAT DO THIS WORK.
TO PREVENT HUMAN TRAFFICKING IN
TO SUPPORT HUMAN TRAFFICKING
SURVIVORS.
AND.
.
THE BECAUSE THE WAY THE ITEM IS
CONSTRUCTED.
IT
BY TO VOTE TO.
.
TO REJECT THIS
WOULD BE WOULD BE SAYING WE WANT
TO FIND THE ENTIRE IT WAS CAN.
AND THAT IS NOT AT LEAST MY
INTEREST.
WHAT I THINK?
AT LEAST I AM I THINK SOME
OTHERS WOULD LIKE TO SEE DONE IS
TO ENSURE THAT THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES.
GRANT PROGRAM MORE ABLE TO
CONTINUE BUT THE ITEM FOREST'S
ISN'T CONSTRUCTED THAT WAY.
SO I'M GOING TO BE.
VOTING AS THE.
AS THE ISSUE IS PRESENTED.
BUT I WANT TO JUST PUT IT ON
THE RECORD THAT I HOPE THAT WE
CAN RESOLVE.
.
PROVIDING SOME LEVEL OF BASE
FUNDING TO THAT ONGOING GRANT
PROGRAM THAT THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES ADMINISTERS.
THANK YOU.
MR LOOK I LIKE A CLARIFICATION
OF FOR A FIGHT A COULD ASK.
.
THERE'S SO.
THE CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE COMPROMISED TO PROVIDE
TEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND SEXUAL ASSAULT
SERVICES AND THEN THE ASSEMBLY
VERSION OF FAMILY JUSTICE
CENTERS ARE THESE TWO SEPARATE.
APPLICATIONS FOR TWO SEPARATE
DATA PROGRAMS.
CAN YOU DESCRIBE THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE TWO PROGRAMS.
YES THEY ARE THEY ARE TWO
SEPARATE PROGRAM SO THE.
YEAH THEY.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND SEXUAL
ASSAULT SERVICES PROGRAM IS FOR
TEN MILLIONS AND PROVIDES
FUNDING TO SUPPORT SERVICES FOR
INDIVIDUALS. IMPACTED BY
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND AS
SPECIFICALLY IT WOULD BE ABOUT
FIVE MILLION.
FOR THE FAMILY VIOLENCE PAPER
PREVENTION PROGRAM IN FIVE MIL
FIVE MILLION FOR RAPE CRISIS
PROGRAM. WHEREAS THE FAMILY
JUSTICE CENTER PROVIDE FUNDING
FOR FAMILY JUSTICE CENTERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO PROVIDE
VICTIMS AND THEIR FAMILIES
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
SO.
.
I THINK YOU COULD SAY CLOSELY
RELATED IN TERMS OF THE OVERALL
LANGUAGE BUT I'M DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS IS IT WHEN YOU SAY
VICTIMS WERE TALKING ABOUT
VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
IN THE AREA FAMILY JUSTICE
CENTERS.
I DON'T HAVE THAT INFORMATION.
IN FRONT OF ME THAT MAYBE BEST A.
DIRECTED TO.
STAFF.
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
SO JUST JUST TO CLARIFY THERE
WAS SENATOR NIELSEN'S.
MOTION TO PULL OUT THREE ITEMS.
ONE WAS THE.
PUBLIC HEALTH AND PUBLIC SAFETY
UPGRADES OF SAN FRANCISCO.
THE ASSEMBLY VERSION OF THE CITY
OF RIALTO EMERGENCY EQUIPMENT
AND THE SENATE'S VERSION OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING SERVICES IS
THAT CORRECT SENATOR.
SO.
ARE YOU DO YOU WANT TO MOVE TO
APPROVE EVERYTHING ELSE OR TO
MOVE TO APPROVE THOSE THREE NO I
MOVED TO APPROVE EVERYTHING ELSE
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND JUST
REQUESTED THAT THAT WOULD BE
SPLIT. THANK YOU ORDER MOVING TO
PROVE EVERYTHING ELSE GOING A
SECOND.
THANK YOU VOTE.
FIVE OH FIVE ON THANK YOU AND
WE'RE GONNA GET A MOTION TO
APPROVE THE OTHER THREE ITEMS.
THANK YOU.
THREE EIGHT.
THREE TWO.
THREE ONE AND ONE WITH MR KHALID
STAND THANK YOU.
ISSUE EIGHTY THREE THAT'S OUR
ISSUE IT IS FOR.
SO JUST TO CLARIFY WE ARE.
NOT
TAKING ACTION ON THE SECOND POLL
THAT WE ARE REMOVING THE SECOND
BULLET.
ON THE AGENDA WE ARE ONLY NOW
DISCUSSING.
APPROVING THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISION PROPOSAL TO ESTABLISH
CYBER CRIME INVESTIGATION TEAM
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF.
JUSTICE MISS COST.
WE SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I GIVE UP.
FIVE I WON THE ASSEMBLY.
FIVE OH IN THE SENATE.
ISSUE EIGHTY FIVE INTO TRUSTS
WORKLOAD.
WE SUPPORT THE ASSEMBLY VERSION
THE ASSEMBLY APPROVED ONE POINT
EIGHT MILLION AND NINE POSITIONS
IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AN ON GOING
TO SUPPORT THE INCREASED
WORKLOAD AND THE ANTITRUST LAW
SECTION. AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
THANK YOU VERY GOOD SECOND MAKE
YOU.
VOTE.
WE GOT OF THREE TWO IN THE
ASSEMBLY FIVE OVER THE SENATE
THINKING.
ISSUE.
ISSUE EIGHTY SIX.
JOINT OR SIX NINE FOUR WE
SUPPORT THE ASSEMBLY VERSION THE
ASSEMBLY PROPOSED TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE AS A TECHNICAL CLEANUP
OF CHAPTER SIX NINETY FOUR
STATUTE OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY FORTY ONE.
TO CLARIFY THE PROVISIONS
RELATED THE FUNDING FROM THE
FEDERAL OFFICE OF VIOLENCE
AGAINST WOMEN WHICH FUNDS
VARIOUS VICTIM SERVICES PROGRAMS.
THANK YOU.
HELLO.
ISSUE EIGHTY SIX.
FIVE OH THE SENATE.
FIVE OH IN THE ASSEMBLY THANK
YOU.
ISSUE EIGHTY SEVEN STAY OFFICER
INVOLVED SHOOTING INVESTIGATION
TEAM.
WE SUPPORT THE SENATE VERSION
WHICH DENIED THE PROPOSAL.
SO JUST TO CLARIFY THIS OF THE
SENATE DENIED THE PROPOSAL SO.
WE STILL NEED TO APPROVE.
NOT DENY THE PROPOSAL THERE WAS
NO THERE THE SENATE AND I HEAR
THE SENATE TOOK NO ACTION. SO
THE.
THE PROPOSAL IS TO CONFORM WITH
THE SENATE NON ACTION.
THANK YOU.
FOUR ZERO WITH MISTER KILEY
ABSTAINING FIVE WHEN THE SENATE
THANK YOU. ISSUE IDIOT ARMED IN
PROHIBITED PERSONS SYSTEM.
APPROVED SENATE VERSION.
WE CONCUR WITH APPROVING THE
SENATE VERSION OF THE SENATE
TOOK THE SENATE TO NOT TAKE
ACTION.
NO MONEY.
GOT MUCH A SECOND VOTE.
THREE TWO IN THE SENATE THREE
TWO IN THE ASSEMBLY THANK YOU.
ISSUE EIGHTY NINE.
WE SUPPORT THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE THE ASSEMBLY.
APPROVED ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND.
TO FIND A TECHNICAL WEBSITE
CONTRACT UPDATED DATABASE WITH
CONFIDENTIAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
RELATED INFORMATION FOR A LIKE
TRONIC WARRANTS.
VOTE.
SOME MORE.
CHAIR I'M JUST WONDERING IF.
DO.
BULLET POINT THREE SAN.
AB MOVIE OTHER THREE
OKAY SO WE ARE SEPARATING OUT
TRACE.
SEE.
THE IF YOU COULD ALSO SEPARATE
ISSUE FOR PLEASE.
BUT LET'S GO BLOW BY POLISH OUR
NARRATIVE.
I GET A MOTION TO APPROVE.
ITEM ONE WHICH IS THE SENATE
VERSION OF THE BUREAU AND OF
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE.
LET'S AND I'M GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THAT MOTION FOR ALL
ITEMS SO PLEASE.
BUT ON TH.
SENATE VERSION OF BUREAU BEST
BUY MIGHT TO JUSTICE FIVE FOUR.
ZERO IN THE ASSEMBLY.
CHICAGO OF STAVING FIVE THOUGH
IN THE SENATE THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
VERSION OF YOU CRIME YOU KNOW
WEBSITE WHICH APPROPRIATES.
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND.
SO
THANK YOU.
FOR ONE WAS SENATE NIELSEN NO.
KILEY IS AT A THUMBS UP FOR.
THANK YOU FIVE OH IN THE
ASSEMBLY THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
VERSION OF TAX RECOVERING
CRIMINAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AUGMENTATION.
OKAY VOTE.
FOR ONE WITH SENATOR MORLOCK NO.
FIVE OH IN THE ASSEMBLY ASSEMBLY
VERGE OF SEX OFFENDER REGISTRY.
THREE TWO IN THE ASSEMBLY.
IN THE SENATE.
FOUR ZERO MORE LARK
STANDING.
THANK YOU.
SORT OF SKINNY OF THREE ZERO.
YES
OKAY THANK YOU.
ISSUE NINETY SEXUAL ASSAULT PARA.
WE SUPPORT THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE OBVIOUSLY WE TALKED
ABOUT THIS ITEM EARLIER THIS
WEEK THE SENATE APPROVED SIX
POINT FIVE MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND TO REDUCE THE
STATEWIDE SEXUAL ASSAULT KIT
BACKLOG. THIS FUNDING IS
AVAILABLE TO LOCALS TO ELIMINATE
EXISTING BACKLOGS OF UNPROCESSED
EVIDENCE THE ASSEMBLY APPROVED
ONE MILLION.
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND TO
CONDUCT TO CONDUCT A STATE WHAT
AUDIT OF UNTESTED SEXUAL ASSAULT
KITS THE SPAWNING CAN BE USED AS
GRANTS TO COUNTIES AND CITIES.
TO COUNT THE NUMBER OF UNTESTED
SEXUAL ASSAULT KITS IN THEIR
POSSESSION.
THANK YOU WILL MOVE.
THANK YOU VOTE.
FIVE OH IN THE ASSEMBLY FIVE OWN
THE SENATE THANK YOU ISSUE
NINETY ONE.
WE SUPPORT THE CONFERENCE ACTION
WHICH WOULD INCLUDE FOUR POINT
FOUR MILLION GENERAL FUND AND
THIRTY ONE POINT SIX POSITIONS
FOR INSTITUTIONAL STAFFING NEEDS.
ABOUT FOUR MILLION FOUR FROM THE
INMATE WELFARE FUND FOR
INNOVATIVE PROGRAMMING GRANTS
NINE POINT ONE MILLION GENERAL
FUND IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN EIGHT
POINT THREE MILLION IN NINETEEN.
TWENTY FOR CONTRABAND
INTERDICTION PROGRAM WITH
ASSOCIATED TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
THANK YOU.
MOVE TO THE CENTER NIELSEN IF I
MAY OF SEPARATE INNOVATIVE CO
READING GROUP PROGRAMMING GRANTS
AND REHABILITATIVE ACHIEVEMENT
CREDIT STAFFING AND I WOULD MOVE
ALL OF THE OTHER ITEMS.
THANK YOU COULD GET A SECOND.
THIS VOTE.
FIVE OH FIVE OUT THANK YOU.
I GET A MOTION TO APPROVE THE
OTHER TWO.
THANK YOU.
THREE TWO THREE TWO THANK YOU.
ISSUE NINETY TWO CCR.
WE SUPPORT THE CONFERENCE ACTION
WHICH IS THE ASSEMBLY VERSION.
OF THIS I TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
DIRECTS THE DEPARTMENT TO ADHERE
TO A SPECIFIED CLOSURE SCHEDULE
WHEN THE OFFENDER POPULATION
REACHES CERTAIN THRESHOLDS IN A
MANNER THAT MAXIMIZES LONG TERM
STATE FACILITY SAVINGS.
LEVERAGES LONG TERM INVESTMENTS
AND MAINTAIN SUFFICIENT
FLEXIBILITY TO COMPLY WITH THE
DEFERRAL COURT ORDER TO MAINTAIN
THE PRISON POPULATION. AT OR
BELOW ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
SEVEN POINT FIVE PERCENT OF
DESIGN CAPACITY
IT PROVIDES THAT THE DEPARTMENT
TAKES SPECIFIED FACTORS INTO
CONSIDERATION WHEN REDUCING
CAPACITY.
THANK YOU SENATORS UP FOR
QUESTION MISTER CHAIRMAN.
YES PLEASE S. TO THE HOUSING
PILOT MENTALLY ILL PAROLEES UP.
AND WHAT DID STE
ANYBODY HAVE AN IDEA EXACTLY
WHAT THIS MEANS WILL BE MENTALLY
ILL PAROLEES.
WOULD HAVE A HOUSING FACILITY
AND THEIR IN WOULD THERE BE
TREATMENT AVAILABLE TO THESE
MENTALLY ILL PAROLEES AS WOULD
BE UP FOR OUT PATIENT CLINIC
KIND OF A SITUATION.
WELL THEY HAVE TRISTA POINT OF
CLARIFICATION AS PART OF THIS
ISSUE WERE NOT FUNDING THAT
PROGRAM THE ONLY ACTION BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE IS THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE I TESTIFIED ON.
TIME THAT'S.
WHATEVER.
THERE ARE VOTE.
WOULD INCLUDE.
AND WE VERSION OF
NOT
ENDING.
THE MENTALLY ILL TRULY PROVE
CORRECT CORRECT SO.
THREE.
YES.
WHAT WOULD YOU WOULD YOU LIKE TO
MOVE SOMETHING CENTER SKINNER?
I WILL MOVE THE CAPITAL OUTLAY
MANAGEMENT PLAN MOVED TO APPROVE
THAT CAN GET A SECOND.
THIS IS THE FIRST BULLET CHO GET
A VOTE.
THREE ZERO ON THE ASSEMBLY AT
FIVE OH IN THE SENATE THANK YOU.
CAN I GET A MOTION TO APPROVE
THE SUPPORTIVE HOUSING PILOT.
IT'S THE NON FUNDING OF THAT
THANK YOU.
MOVE SECONDS.
SO I GOT THREE ZERO IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE HAVE FAR TOO.
ZERO TWO ONE ENDS TO.
WAS SENATOR SKINNER AND NIELSEN
ABSTAINING.
YES
SEVERAL MORE LIKE IS NO CENTER
NIELSEN AND CENTER SKINNER OF
STERN.
SO SENATE IS THREE.
ONE AND ONE WITHOUT MORLOCK
NO IN NIELSEN ABSTAINED THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
ISSUE NINETY THREE VARIOUS CCR
PROPOSALS.
THESE ARE VARIOUS AYE DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION PROPOSALS FROM
THE ADMINISTRATION WOULD PROVIDE
SEVEN POINT SEVEN MILLION
GENERAL FUND. AYE TO ESTABLISH A
PROGRAM TO TRAIN UP TO EIGHTY
PAROLEES AT A TIME AS
FIREFIGHTERS GOOD PROVIDE TWO
POINT ONE MILLION GENERAL FUND.
ON FOR JUVENILE JUSTICE REFORM.
AND IT INCLUDES A TRAILER BILL
TO CLARIFY EXPLICITLY A PLEA
DEAL IS NOT AN OBSTACLE FOR
COURTS AND RE SENTENCING
PURSUANT TO SEVERAL CODE
SECTIONS.
THANK YOU SENATE'S MISS BUT I
MADE UP DIVIDE THE QUESTION ON
THE CHANGE PROPOSALS REGARDING
VENTURA.
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE DIVISION
OF JUVENILE JUSTICE REFORM
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE AND THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO THE PC
ELEVEN SEVENTY D..
THAT PIERCING.
COMPASSIONATE RELEASED FOR
MEDICAL PAROLE KIND OF ISSUE.
AND THEN THE OTHERS WITH. I
WOULD MAKE A MOTION ON THOSE THE
FORTY THREE MILLION FOR THE
HEALTHCARE FACILITY IMPROVEMENT
AND THE.
ROUTE WELLNESS INITIATIVES
SO I MOVED SO YOU'RE MOVING TO
APPROVE THE LAST COUPLE OF THE
LAST TWO ITEMS AND THEN A
SEPARATE ITEM ON THE OTHERS VERY
GOOD THANK YOU VERY GOOD ABOUT.
KEPT.
FIVE OH IN THE SENATE.
CAN'T TELL HOW MR CALLIES VOTE.
THREE TWO THANK YOU.
THREE TO IN THE ASSEMBLY CUT
YOUR MOTION TO APPROVE THE FOR
TOP THREE BULLETS.
THANK YOU.
AND THE SERIAL SET IT LOOKED.
WELL I DON'T THAT.
THREE TWO IN THE SENATE.
THREE TWO IN THE ASSEMBLY THANK
YOU ALL ON THAT ISSUE MISTER.
CHAIRMAN ELEVEN SEVENTY DE IN
THE RE SENTENCING THAT.
BUT I DO I NEED TO SEE SOME
LANGUAGE FRANKLY THAT'S A VERY
VERY MAJOR POLICY ISSUE OR IT
COULD BE.
I DON'T THINK IT'S TECHNICAL SO.
I THINK WE DO HAVE TO BE A
LITTLE CAREFUL IT THAT'S.
PURPOSE OF MY DIVISION OF THE
QUESTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ISSUE NINETY FOUR JUVENILE
JUSTICE ID PROGRAM.
WE SUPPORT THE CONFERENCE ACTION
WHICH IS OUR MAY REVISE PROPOSAL.
THIS TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE WOULD
REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION TO ENTER INTO AN
INTER AGENCY AGREEMENT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES TO
ENSURE THAT ELIGIBLE JUVENILES
LEAVING CDC OURS DIVISION OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE FACILITIES. ARE
ABLE TO OBTAIN A CALIFORNIA
IDENTIFICATION CARD.
W. SECOND.
THANK YOU CENTER MITCHELL.
I THINK YOU JUST AS WEIRD
CRAFTING A TRUE THE BILL
LANGUAGE I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE CLEAR ABOUT THAT DIEM
POPULATION IMPACTED. I HAPPEN TO
KNOW BECAUSE I ESCORTED MY
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD TODAY TO GET
A STATE THAT CALIFORNIA ID.
AND IT REQUIRE QUITE A BIT OF.
INFORMATION EITHER PASSPORT OR
BIRTH CERTIFICATE.
AND PROOF OF RESIDENCE AND YOU
KNOW IT'S THE SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD
HE DOESN'T GET A LOT OF HE
DIDN'T PAY THE UTILITY BILLS
IDEAS THEY DON'T COME WITH HIS
NAME. AND SO I JUST WANT TO BE
SENSITIVE TO THE POPULATION AT
HAND THAT THERE MAY BE SOME
CHALLENGES WITH THEM ACQUIRING
THAT KIND OF INFORMATION SO.
THAT I I WON THIS THIS TO BE A
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM AND AND NOT
HINDER THEM FROM GETTING THE
IDEA THAT THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO
IMMEDIATELY PUT THEIR HANDS ON
THAT KIND OF BACKGROUND OUT OF
SO JUST. TO BE SENSITIVE DULY
NOTED THANK YOU.
SOME OF THAT YOU CAN GET A VOTE
TO APPROVE.
THREE TWO IN THE ASSEMBLY.
THREE A ONE AND ONE IN THE
SENATE WITH SENATOR NIELSEN UPS
TO START FOUR ZERO I APOLOGIZE.
FOUR ZERO IN THE SENATE HEROES
THREE LEADERS THREE TWO IN THE
ASSEMBLY THANK YOU.
ISSUE NINETY FIVE.
WE SUPPORT THE CONFERENCE ACTION
WHICH IS THE SENATE VERSION
WOULD PROVIDE A THIRTEEN POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND AND EIGHTY NINE POINT TWO
POSITIONS FOR CORRECTIONAL
COUNSELOR ONE RATIO ADJUSTMENT.
WOULD PROVIDE SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND FOR MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS BEDS.
AND THANK YOU.
I HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
THE SENATE I HAVE A VOTE OF.
FIVE ZERO THE ASSEMBLY I HAVE A
VOTE OF THREE TO TWO.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MAY ADD ON THAT
POINT.
I UNDERSTAND THAT THIS WAS A
COMPROMISE AND.
.
WHAT I'VE HAD EXPRESSED TO ME TO
INTERESTS LIKE CARE ABOUT?
THERE SOME SYMPATHY.
BUT I'M GONNA KEEP OF CLOSE EYE
ON THIS ONE BECAUSE I THINK IT
HAS A.
REPOSITORY DIG DOWNSIDE.
SO. LET'S JUST CONSIDER ME WARY
BUT OKAY WITH WHERE RAP FOR THE
MOMENT. THANK YOU SIR FOR*
THAT CLARIFICATION MOVING ON TO
ISSUE NINETY SIX JANITORIAL
SERVICES. THEY COMPROMISED LOTS
CORRECT WE SUPPORT THE
CONFERENCE COMPROMISE WHICH
WOULD EQUALLY DIVIDE THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR PROVIDING
JANITORIAL SERVICES AT THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE FACILITY
IN STOCKTON. BETWEEN A CONTRACT
WITH PRIDE INDUSTRIES AND CIVIL
SERVICE STAFF.
AND COULD YOU CLARIFY THE
COMPROMISE REFLECTS THE FACT
THAT THE CURRENT PRIDE EMPLOYEES
THAT CURRENT EMPLOYEE NUMBER ONE
TWENTY OR SOMETHIN.
THAT.
THEY WOULD ALL BUT COULDN'T
MAINTAIN EMPLOYMENT.
CLINT COUNT APARTMENT FINANCE
YES I CURRENTLY THERE'S ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY TOTAL
EMPLOYEES.
AND HUNDRED TWENTY OF THOSE
HAVE DISABILITIES SO SPLITTING
THE TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY WILL BE
ABLE TO MAINTAIN EMPLOYMENT.
FOR ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS.
WELL THAT DID THE ISSUE IS.
.
ALWAYS FICTION SUB IN THIS NOT
BROKEN AND THESE ARE.
INDIVIDUALS WITH SOME CHALLENGES
IN THESE ARE VERY GAINFUL
OPPORTUNITIES.
PRIDE INDUSTRIES DO A WONDERFUL
JOB.
AND IF THIS IS JUST REPLACING
THOSE INDIVIDUAL SO GAINFULLY NO
EMPLOYED. GOT WITH THE
CLARIFICATION I JUST THOUGHT
FROM FINANCE THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WILL MAINTAIN THEIR EMPLOYMENT.
WHAT NO NO I UNDERSTAND THAT
OKAY BUT?
IF YOU GET BACK TO THE ISSUE OF
TRUST.
THE SLIPPERY SLOPE WAS SO THIS
IS THE FIRST STEP TODAY THERE
WAS A COMPROMISE MADE THIS YEAR
NOW NEXT YEAR. THE UNION COMES
BACK AND WE'RE GOING TO FINISH
HIM OFF.
THAT'S I WANT TO GET THAT ON THE
RECORD.
THE LEAST I KEEP AN EYE ON THAT.
SO THAT MAYBE WE DIDN'T
DISPLACING NEXT YEAR THAT WILL
GET RID OF NEXT YEAR.
SENATOR MOORE LA.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THIS IS
NOT A COMPROMISE.
I CRAMMED DOWN THIS IS BULLYING.
BY GOVERNMENT AT ITS WORST AND
AND I I'M JUST REALLY I'M
SADDENED BY.
I'LL BE VOTING NO.
I'D LIKE TO ECHO THE SENATOR'S
COMMENTS.
PRIDE INDUSTRIES IS BASED ON MY
DISTRICT AND SENATOR NIELSEN IS
DISTRICT.
I HAD BETTER I'VE ENCOUNTERED
FEW ORGANIZATIONS AS INSPIRING
AS THIS ONE THEY DO TREMENDOUS
WORK THEY'VE DONE TREMENDOUS
WORK FOR OUR STATE. AND IT'S
QUITE SHOCKING AYE THERE EVEN BE
ENTERTAINED THE IDEA OF
REPLACING THESE FOLKS.
WITH THE WITH THE POLITICALLY
FAVORED.
INTEREST GROUP I'M I DID HAVE A
CLARIFYING QUESTION SO.
WILL THERE BE PUT PRIDE
EMPLOYEES WHO ARE DISPLACED AS A
RESULT THIS COMPROMISE.
SO THERE WILL BE FEWER PRIDE
EMPLOYEES OVER ALL BUT THE TO
SEE THE NUMBER OF DISABLED
EMPLOYEES ARE EXPECTED BE ABLE
TO COME.
BE ACCOMMODATED BY THIS
COMPARABLE.
THANK YOU I LIKE TO MAKE A
MOTION.
FOR ONE HUNDRED PERCENT OF THE
POSITIONS.
TO BE MAINTAINED BY PRIDE
INDUSTRIES.
NO WORRIES I MADE A MOTION FOR
ONE HUNDRED PERCENT OF THE
POSITIONS TO ME MAINTAIN MY
PRIDE INDUSTRIES AND I BELIEVE.
BOTH SENATOR SECOND IN THE
BUSHES
.
TO UP
THERE.
I'M.
SENATE VOTE HERE.
THREE I
NO.
IN THE VERY.
THREE I.
THANK YOU GO BACK TO NERVES ARE
NOT GOING BACK GOING TO ISSUE
NINETY SEVEN.
THANK YOU ISSUE NINETY SEVEN IS
A CONFERENCE COMPROMISED THE
LEGISLATIVE REQUEST PROVIDES A
ONE TIME EIGHTEEN POINT EIGHT
MILLION GENERAL FUND
AUGMENTATION TO THE BOARD OF
STATE AND COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS.
FOR GRANTS TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS FOR PUBLIC SAFETY
PROGRAMS THIS INCLUDES EIGHT
POINT SEVEN MILLION TO KINGS
COUNTY FOR PUBLIC SAFETY
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AS WELL AS ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION TO THE NEW EARTH
ORGANIZATION TO SUPPORT MENTOR
BASED ARTS EDUCATION AND
VOCATIONAL PROGRAMS THAT EMPOWER
JUVENILE JUSTICE AND SYSTEMS
INVOLVING USE AGES THIRTEEN TO
TWENTY FIVE.
SEVERAL.
TURKEY WE VOTE ON THESE
INDIVIDUALLY PLEASE.
YES.
SO I WILL TRY GET A MOTION TO
APPROVE THE FIRST ITEM AND WILL
STEPS TO THE MOTION FOR ALL OF
THOSE.
NO NO PROVIDE STORIES DIED JUST
PROVIDE NINE MILLION FOR
CALIFORNIA VIOLENCE INTERVENTION
AND PREVENTION.
I GET A MOTION AND A SECOND TO
APPROVE.
THANK YOU.
VOTE PLEASE.
FOUR ZERO WITH KILEY ABSTAINING
ASSEMBLY FIVE OH IN THE SENATE
CAN GET A. CAN GET TO VOTE ON
POMONA OF.
THREE TWO IN THE SENATE.
THREE ZERO IN THE ASSEMBLY.
KINGS COUNTY PUBLIC SAFETY A
POINT SEVEN MILLION.
FIVE OH IN THE SENATE.
THREE ZERO IN THE ASSEMBLY.
CITY OF STOCKTON HELICOPTER.
THREE ZERO. IN THE ASSEMBLY FIVE
OH.
IN THE SENATE.
BOYS AND GIRLS CLUB OF FULTON.
THREE ZERO IN THE.
AND ASSEMBLY FIVE ALL IN THE
SENATE.
VETERANS TRANSITION CENTER.
THREE.
FOUR ZERO IN THE ASSEMBLY WITH
KILEY ABSTAINING FIVE OO IN THE
SENATE.
TRAINING TO GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS.
THREE ONE IN ONE IN THE ASSEMBLY
WITH KILEY NO OBERNOLTE
UPSTANDING.
THREE TWO IN THE SENATE.
LOCAL POLICE DEPARTMENTS SENATE
VERSION.
FOUR ZERO IN THE ASSEMBLY WITH
KILEY UPSTANDING FIVE ALL IN THE
SENATE.
NEW OR ORGANIZATION.
THREE ZERO IN THE ASSEMBLY THREE
TWO IN THE SENATE.
COMMUNITY BASED REENTRY PROGRAMS
THREE ZERO IN THE ASSEMBLY FIVE
OH IN THE SENATE.
COUNTER RECREATION CENTER.
THREE ZERO IN THE ASSEMBLY FIVE
OH IN THE SENATE THANK YOU.
ISSUED NINETY EIGHT.
WE SUPPORT THE CONFERENCE ACTION
WHICH IS THE ASSEMBLY VERSION
THE ASSEMBLY APPROVED TWENTY
FIVE MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND FOR THAT COMMISSION ON
PEACE OFFICERS STANDARDS AND
TRAINING POST. FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT TRAINING INCLUDING
FIFTEEN MILLION FOR USE OF FORCE
AND DE ESCALATE ES DE ESCALATION
TRAINING FIVE MILLION FOR CRISIS
MENTAL HEALTH TRAINING AND FIVE
MILLION FOR GRANTS TO SUPPORT
INNOVATIVE TRAINING PROGRAMS.
THE FUNDING WOULD BOTH SUPPORT
CURRICULUM DEVELOPMENT AND LOCAL
ASSISTANCE IN THE FORM OF
SUBSIDIES SUBSIDIES FOR LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO
ATTEND TRAINING.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CARNESECCA THANK YOU.
VOTE.
FIVE ON THE ASSEMBLY FIVE ON THE
SENATE THANK YOU.
YOU SHOULD NINETY NINE MILITARY
DEPARTMENT PROPOSALS FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION.
WE SUPPORT THE SENATE VERSION
THE SENATE APPROVED THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL OF
THREE POINT SIX MILLION GENERAL
FUND IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND
THREE POINT THREE MILLION ON
GOING TO BE USED TO SUPPORT THE
MILITARY PERSONNEL. TO RUN THE
MILITARY COMPONENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA AND MILITARY
INSTITUTE AND THE PORTERVILLE
MILITARY INSTITUTE.
THANK YOU.
VOTE.
FIVE ALL IN THE ASSEMBLY FIVE ON
THE SENATE THANK YOU.
ISSUE ONE HUNDRED I AM THERE.
WE SUPPORT THE CONFERENCE
COMPROMISED TAKE YEAR.
THANK YOU SECOND THANK YOU.
VOTE.
FIVE OH IN THE ASSEMBLY FIVE ON
THE SENATE THANK YOU.
SO WE NEED TO GO BACK I
APOLOGIZE.
ON TWO ITEMS.
ISSUE TWENTY THREE.
ISSUE TWENTY THREE IN ISSUE
THIRTY TWO.
SO WE ARE GOING WE HAVE TO GO
BACK AND I APOLOGIZE TO THE.
COLLEAGUES.
WE ARE GOING TO GO BACK TO THE
ORIGINAL.
PROPOSAL.
WHICH IS TO APPROVE OF PLACING
ONE POINT OH TO TWO POINT THREE
BILLION AND PROFIT TO SIX
FUNDING INTO A NON. BUDGET ITEM.
AND.
FOR ISSUE THIRTY TOO WE WILL
NOT BE DOING THE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION.
TO MEDI CAL.
THE MEDICARE WAS OF AYE POT AYE
STAKE YOU.
MOTION IT IS GOING BACK TO THE
CAR GET A MOTION TO. AMEND THAT.
THANK YOU COULD GET A VOTE.
AND SCOTT.
FIVE OH. FIVE OF THANK YOU.
OUR WAY. IS THERE ANY OTHER
ANYTHING ELSE.
YES WOULD WE JUST DID
WE DID BOTH TOGETHER I POD.
SENATE NIELSEN.
PLEASE ABSOLUTE CENTER.
CHAIRMAN THIS IS THE.
IN I EARLIER RAISE SOME CONCERN
FACT I HAVE.
FOR SEVERAL DAYS ABOUT PROCESS.
AND SO.
RULED.
JOINT RULE TWENTY NINE POINT
FIVE AND I'M READING THE TYPED
OUT VERSION STAFF PREPARED TO
THESEIZURE FROM MY WEARY EYES.
THIS IS SUBSECTION SEE OF JOINT
RULE TWENTY NINE POINT FIVE IT'S
AS A COMMITTEE ON CONFERENCE OF
THE BUDGET BILL ON THESE ARE
THIS IS ALL RELATED TO HOW WE
RUN CONFERENCE COMMITTEES.
THE BUDGET CONFERENCE COMMITTEE
MAY CONSIDER ONLY DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN THE ASSEMBLY VERSION OF
THE BUDGET AS PASSED BY THE
ASSEMBLY OF THE SENATE VERSION
OF THE BUDGET BILLS PASSED BY
THE SENATE AND MAY NOT APPROVE
ANY ITEM OF EXPENDITURE OR
CONTROL THAT EXCEEDS THE
CONTAINED. THAT CONTAINED IN ONE
OF THE TWO VERSIONS BEFORE THE
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE WHAT WE
HAVE. IN OUR POSSESSION.
MAY TWENTY FIFTH THE SENATE
VOTED TO WAVE JOINT RULES TWENTY
EIGHT.
TWENTY EIGHT POINT ONE AND
TWENTY NINE.
RELATED TO THE CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE ON THIS BILL S. B.
EIGHT FORTY. THAT BILL PASSED
UNANIMOUSLY.
BUT JOINT RULE TWENTY NINE
POINTS FIVE WAS NOT WAIVED.
JOINT TWENTY FIVE POINT NINE AS
I READ IT SECTION SUBSECTION SEE
IS VERY SPECIFIC.
THAT LEADS ME TO BELIEVE THERE
IS A CLOUD OF DOUBT.
BUT MANY OF THE ITEMS THAT WE'VE
CONSIDERED. THIS EVENING.
WE'RE GOING TO ASK FOR A LEGAL
CLARIFICATION.
BY LEDGE COUNCIL.
BUT THIS DOES PUT A LEGAL CLOUD
OF DOUBT.
OVER A LOT OF ITEMS.
THAT WE VOTED ON TONIGHT.
JUST FOR THE RECORD MISTER.
THANK YOU CENTER
.
IF.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO WE
ASK ALL THE CONFEREES TO STAND
ON THE TO STAY FOR ONE SECOND TO
SIGN. THE CONFERENCE REPORTS.
WE LIKED AGAIN JUST JUST WANTED
KNOWLEDGE THE LATENESS OF THE
HOUR WANTED TO THINK.
BOTH SAID IT IS SIMPLY BUDGET
STAFF BOTH REPUBLICAN BUDGET
STUFF LA KNOW AS WELL AS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IN THE
SERGEANTS FOR A FABULOUS.
JOB VERY MUCH APPRECIATED IT
VERY SUCCESSFUL.
BUDGET HEARING THANK YOU
EVERYBODY.
AS SOON AS WE SAID THE
CONFERENCE REPORT WE DO NEED TO
ASK EVERYBODY TO CLEAR. THE ROOM
SO THAT WE CAN RECONCILE.
SO WITH THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND WE WILL BE ADJOURNING
SHORTLY BUDGET CONFERENCE GREAT
THANK YOU
PROPOSAL WOULD HAVE TO PROVE.
YEAH LIKE IT'S.
FLICKR.
THAT THE. CHILDREN GREAT IDEA
AYE AYE
I FULLY INTEND TO THE.
PART OF THE.
NOT.
PAGE.
SALINAS WITH WITH THE QUEEN
TOGETHER WE SIGN THIS PAPER.
FIND EVERYTHING YOU NEED. UNDER
ME.
SITE.
I THINK ATTORNEY.
MORE THAN.
GOOD JOB.
I SPOKE TO.
I SPOKE TO HIM I JUST I SAID HOW
CAN WE KNOW RIGHTS. HIGH.
ON.
YEAH THERE IS A MOMENT OR.
YOU KNOW.
THOSE PROGRAMS PROVIDE TWENTY
FIVE PERCENT OVER PURCHASE
REALTORS.
LIKE I SAID FROM HOW WE OUGHT TO
CONSIDER IRVING OUT.
I. HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONAL.
AND SHE SAID WILL THE PRIMACY OF
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN BUT AS IT IS
RIGHT.
WHATEVER.
NO I'M NOT BECAUSE I AYE
SENSIBLY MY SKETCH.
I MEAN DID DID SYSTEM OUTRAGEOUS
POSITION. NEARLY BEFORE
AFFIRMATIVE THURSDAY WITH.
THE BUDGET FLUCTUATE THE REVENUE
FLUCTUATES MORE EASILY.
I JUST HAVE SOME.
AND I MEAN
OKAY I BELIEVE IT'S TIME TO
CLEAR THE ROOM IF WE CAN ASK
EVERYBODY BUT STYLE OFTEN. SO
THAT THEY CAN RECONCILE VERY
MUCH PRE IS NOT.
SO SENATOR MITCHELL IS SAYING
YOU KNOW I'M HOME. BRB THAT'S
RIGHT
WE ARE ADJOURNED